[Musique]
R B
bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Je suis
avocat et euh et écrivain. Donc j'ai
représenté des personnes comme Julien
Nassange et Wikileaks
euh dans d'autres domaines de la Ligue
A, le championnat de foot espagnol
contre le PSG sur l'affaire Mbappé, des
supporters du Barça aussi pour ceux qui
aiment le foot.
Mais aussi et surtout je pense qui est
le plus important aujourd'hui, c'est
d'une part des gilets jaunes et à peu
près toutes les personnes qui sont
opposées au pouvoir actuel et de l'autre
beaucoup de penseurs et d'activistes
panafricains dont des personnes qui sont
passées par la prison et sont
aujourd'hui à la tête d'un certain
nombre d'états. J'ai aussi écrit un
certain nombre de livres, 15, dont un
qui m'avait évalu votre dernière
invitation il y a 5 ans, crépuscule qui
s'est rendu à par miracle à 170000
exemplaires après avoir été téléchargé
plus d'un million de fois et qui
décomposait en fait le le fonctionnement
du système politique français et
annonçait son effondrement.
Aujourd'hui, on vous reçoit euh on
voudrait savoir, on voudrait comprendre,
on voudrait avoir une prise de
température de ce qui se passe sur le
petit le petit bout d'Afrique que vous
avez
visité. Vous êtes fait emprisonner ou
vous est arrivé des bricoles. On
commence par le commencement, on vous
laisse expliquer et on posera les
questions ensuite.
Peut-être qu'on commence par ça. Oui,
j'ai été kidnappé en Mauritanie euh mais
dans la géole des services secrets d'un
régime qui est un une sorte de prison à
ciel ouvert qui est financée et
instrumentalisé par le pouvoir français
et par les autorités occidentales.
C'est assez euh assez tangible quand
vous y êtes. C'estàd que vous retrouvez
dans une situation où la peur est
omniprésente, le racisme aussi parce que
ça a été un territoire où de facto
l'esclavage était aboli.
Quel pays
? On parle de la Mauritanie le plus
tardivement
au monde. Donc c'est entre le Maroc et
le Sénégal. C'est euh c'est un
territoire qui est euh largement
désertique où le désert touche l'océan
et qui euh et qui sert en fait de zone
tampon par rapport au flux migratoire et
euh à différents trafics pour essayer de
d'éviter qu'il touche euh l'Europe avec
chaque fois moins de succès. Il faut
savoir qu'au Sénégal, il y a 18 millions
d'habitants à peu près et l'âge moyen
est de 19 ans. Donc vous avez à peu près
10 millions de personnes qui sont
mineures ou à peine adultes qui vivent
dans des conditions catastrophique avec
des revenus quasiment inexistants et qui
sont poussés par le système économique
et politique qui nous gouverne à tenter
leur chance que ce soit aux États-Unis à
travers des pays d'Amérique latine ou en
Europe à travers des bateaux qui les
poussent jusqu'au Canari puis après
jusqu'à l'Espagne, la France et et ainsi
de suite, voir à travers le Mali, puis
après en remontant vers l'Algérie ou
voir le Niger à travers les déserts pour
pour arriver en Italie.
C'est une masse humaine euh qui est
d'abord précipitée vers la ville, vers
Dakar depuis les campagnes et les
territoires plus plus excentrés du
Sénégal. Mais je vous parle du Sénégal
pour vous donner un exemple, c'est le
cas dans beaucoup de pays africains et
qui poussé à cette misère et à une
situation de quasi
esclavage et bien se retrouve dans une
situation où il où il où ils sont
obligés de de pousser encore plus loin
pour fuir pour fuir ces conditions et
une fois qu'ils investissent parce que
c'est plusieurs milliers d'euros pour
pour traverser ses océans, ses mers, il
faut 5 jours pour partir partant de
Dakar ou de Saint-Louis pour arriver
jusqu'aux île Canarie dans des bateaux
qui coulent régulièrement et euh qui
provoque des milliers de morts chaque
année. Et bien, on se retrouve dans une
situation où ils essayent de de
ensuite euh de rendre une partie de
l'argent qui a été souvent collectée par
des familles, par des amis, ainsi de
suite pour leur permettre à eux de
réussir entre guillemets de renvoyer un
certain nombre de ressources et l'échec
qui arrive très souvent les empêche de
revenir. les empêche de revenir et les
mettre dans la situation que l'on
connaît euh dans des territoires comme
la France avec des violences
extraordinaires et une réaction
évidemment phobique d'une partie des
sociétés d'accueil qui ne supporte pas
cette désagrégation qu'il qu'ils peuvent
incarner et qui ne supporte pas qu'il y
ait pas d'ordre en fait dans leur propre
territoire et qui provoquent des
dynamiques de rejet qui alimentent les
spirales politiques auxquelles on est
confronté aujourd'hui. Et donc au
Sénégal, je représentais un homme,
Ousman Sonco, qui a incarné l'espoir
d'un peuple qui avait été emprisonné
pour cela, accusé de viol, de
terrorisme, de téléphone portable et qui
à un moment
de téléphone portable. Ouais.
Ouais. C'est c'est là où en fait on
comprend que le pouvoir lorsqu'il est
désespéré cherche absolument enfin est
obligé de s'appuyer sur des prétextes
plus des prétextes pardon plus ubueces
que les uns que les autres. ce qui va
leur permettre en fait euh de euh mettre
en œuvre des mécaniques judiciaires
parce qu'ils font toujours mines de
respecter l'ordre. Ils ont toujours
besoin de prétexte. Et donc là, c'était
un téléphone pseudo vol de téléphone
portable qui avait justifié
l'emprisonnement de la personne la plus
populaire et du principal opposant
politique au régime de Macky Sall qui
était soutenu évidemment à bout de bras
par la France et en particulier par
Emmanuel Macron.
Comment vous le savez ça ?
Comment je sais quel parti ?
Comment vous le savez qu'il était
soutenu directement par la France ? par
la France tout simplement parce qu'il
est aujourd'hui l'employé de l'Élysée
Macky Sall qui a euh fait tirer sur la
foule et tuer des manifestants
pacifique. vous entendez par employé de
l'Élysée
est aujourd'hui envoyé spécial du forum
pour la paix qui a été créé par Emmanuel
Macron une sorte de pseudoinitiative
diplomatique afin en fait de lui offrir
l'immunité diplomatique et une sorte de
porte de sortie euh après qu'il ait
quelque part en fait assuré le maintien
de l'ordre suffisamment d'années dans
son propre territoire au nom de la
France et agit comme comme comme leur
instrument. Donc cet homme-là qui donc
comme je vous le disais a fait tirer sur
la foule ce qui nous a amené à à mettre
en œuvre des procédures pour essayer de
de protéger ce peuple sénégalais qui
avait cru en le changement à travers cet
opposant politique.
Changement démocratique,
changement justement qui est intervenu
par miracle démocratiquement mais on y
reviendra. Et un des instruments qu'on a
mis en œuvre pour à cette fin, ça a été
le droit le droit qui nous a permis en
fait de gagner du temps par rapport aux
dynamiques politiques et de nous assurer
qu'éventuellement à un moment donné on
arrivera à bon port. Mais à travers donc
tous ces épisodes et sachant la menace
que je représentais pour eux euh ils ont
émis les autorités sénégalaises de
l'époque donc l'année dernière he
c'était tout récent ont émis évidemment
avec la complicité de du pouvoir
français un ordre un mandat d'arrêt
international.
Pourquoi avec la complicité du pouvoir
français ? Mais je vous je vais vous
donner les éléments que pour qui vont
vous permettre de tr factuel sourcé
carré cubique pas diffation très simple
le 20 juin 2023
j'annonce le dépôt auprès de la cour
internationale d'une procédure contre
crime contre pour crime contre
l'humanité contre Macky Sall et 200 des
membres de son régime. C'estàd que j'ai
fait avec mes équipes une immense un
immense travail d'enquête qui
permettrait de qui permettrait de
d'établir des responsabilités pénales
pour la commission des crimes dont je
vous parlais, de torture, de détention,
de meurtre et ainsi de suite jusqu'au
niveau des petites brigades de
gendarmerie dans des des des villages de
du Sénégal. Je fais ça hasard de
l'histoire le jour où Macky Sall est en
France pour participer à un sommet
dans lequel la France lui réassure de
son soutien malgré les massacres qui
sont commis par son régime avec plus de
1000 prisonniers politiques à l'époque
dans des géoles que j'ai eu à fréquenter
du coup en tant que détenu moi-même où
ils étaient il faut quand même se rendre
compte de ce que ça veut dire euh 200
dans 50 m² c'est-à-dire qu'on on avait
pas l'espace pour s'allonger pour dormir
il fallait dormir dos à
2 tiers des prisonniers politiques de
cette prison qui était une ancienne
écurie qui avait été transformée en
prison euh était donc des prisonniers
politiques, des médecins, des élus, des
simples citoyens, des jeunes qui avaient
décidé de se mobiliser, qui étaient
envoyés encore une fois avec l'appui de
la France et notamment dans cette
communication, je révélais qu'il y avait
un agent de la DGSE qui était un
collaborateur au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur sénégalais.
Vous avez été poursuivi pour ça ? Non.
Voilà, c'est ce que c'est là où j'allais
justement faire la jonction. Donc on
découvre que au sein du cabinet du
ministre d'intérieur sénégalais qui
était Antoine Félixium à l'époque, il y
avait ce qu'on appelle un conseiller
technique qui était chargé en fait de
l'aider à organiser tous ces
dispositifs. Donc on l'expose, on expose
un certain nombre d'individus dans cette
liste. En fait, on l'intègre parce qu'on
évidemment il joue un rôle clé dans
l'organisation de de ce qu'on appelle le
maintien de l'ordre.
Euh, on découvre que par ailleurs toute
une série d'armes et de d'instruments
qui sont utilisés pour maintenir l'ordre
sont produits en France par des sociétés
qui qui fournissent qui fournissent les
autorités sénégalaises malgré
l'aggravation de la situation et qui ne
cessent pas en fait les exportations de
matériel qui peuvent être considérés
comme des armements de guerre. Il y a un
comité au sein de Matignon qui est censé
charger censé surveiller que les
exportations respectent un certain
nombre de critères. On découvre qu'ils
ne le sont pas. Bref, on établit un
certain nombre d'éléments. Vous
découvrez comment ?
Et par justement un travail d'enquête,
de source, on découvre que le palais
présidentiel, donc dirigé par Macky Sall
à l'époque, avait en leur propre nom,
c'est-à-dire le gouverneur du palais, le
gouverneur militaire du palais avait
commandé des millions de munitions. Donc
c'estàdire qu'il se préparait à une
confrontation dure avec le pouvoir
évidemment avec la propagation de la
France.
Le contrat datait de quelle pour les
munitions ? Dataéit de quelle année ? Il
datait de l'année précédente de 2022
sauf erreur. Il faudra vérifier. J'ai
publié j'ai publié l'ensemble des des
sources et on a parce que j'ai j'ai reçu
le document du gouverneur militaire
et qui m'a été fuité avec la commande et
enfin lors de réception dans mon
souvenir et
expertisé.
Ouioui. Oui. Là il y avait aucun aucun
doute sur le fait que c'était un vrai.
Donc on lance cette procédure qui en
fait provoque un immense et moi par un
miracle. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a parfois
encore aujourd'hui, y compris dans des
grands dispositifs de pouvoir comme
peuvent être la FP, l'Agence France
Presse ou Associé de Press à
l'international, des personnes qui font
leur travail et ces personnes
lorsqu'elles font le travail leur
travail, elles peuvent sauver des vies
et en l'occurrence ces personnes qui
vont suivre et qui vont publiciser cette
initiative que l'on mise en œuvre, qui
vont empêcher l'étouffoir qui étaient en
train d'être organisé sur la répression
qui était en cours au Sénégal. Et cette
initiative force quelques jours plus
tard Macky Sallallon
à un 3è mandat qu'il brigait contre la
Constitution. D'accord ? Donc ça c'est
le premier élément. Immédiatement après,
le Cadors euh annonce à travers le JDD
qu'ils ont initié une procédure pénale
contre moi du fait de la révélation de
ces informations. Donc contre moi qui
agit comme avocat de victime de crime de
contre l'humanité pour les révélations
d'un nom d'agent français. voilà des
agents français de la coopération de que
la France avait avec ce régime qui était
en train de de devenir un régime vous
reprochez en fait d'avoir balancé le les
mecs de la DGSE euh euh
d'avoir non seulement les personnes en
question mais aussi le dispositif en
fait de coopération qui s'était maintenu
y compris euh dans le cadre de la
répression nécessité de dévoiler leur
nom
évidemment évidemment parce que c'est la
seule façon de s'assurer que ça s'arrête
quand vous êtes pas au pouvoir quand
vous êtes juste un citoyen ou un avocat
la seule si vous ne dudez pas
complètement le pouvoir c'est une leçon
que j'ai eu avec Julien Nassang Wikilix
c'est ce Ce qui a fait que Jan Nassang
etilix ont été à ce point poursuivi
tandis que le New York Times, le monde
ainsi de suite était protégé. C'est
parce qu'ils ont compris que la seule
façon de changer factuellement les
choses, c'était de révéler, de montrer
dans pas de jouer au traficant
d'information, voyez, de prendre à
droite pour donner à gauche avec en
protégeant des sources et ainsi de
suite. C'est c'est de d'offrir aux
citoyens la possibilité de contrôler
eux-mêmes.
Je peux vous passe bien sûr.
Le le Wikileak a pas mis en danger des
agents.
Ils ont prétendu pendant 13 ans et
tenter de justifier mais ça c'est les
opérations de communication. Il faut
savoir qu'en France, à Paris par exemple
aujourd'hui, il y a plus de personnes
qui sont employées par des agences de
communication et qui sont chargés de
trafiquer l'information que ce que l'on
appelle des journalistes qui la plupart
eux-mêmes aujourd'hui malheureusement
sont encore sont sont désormais pardon
des employés d'oligarques et des
opérateurs en fait comme ça. Il y a la
déontologie journalistique, il y a la
charte de Munique, il y a encore des
journalistes intègres. Ouais, c'est
intéressant ce que ce que vous me dites,
mais euh on en reparlera peut-être et je
vous dirai un mot sur euh sur ça et en
fait la la façon dont dont les dont les
instructions sont données au sein des
rédactions de façon à préserver
l'illusion pour le journaliste lui-même
qu'il est indépendant alors qu'il n'est
qu'un instrument euh au sein d'une
mécanique de pouvoir bien plus large qui
souvent se satisfait de sa bêtise ou de
son ignorance ou les deux et de sa
satisfaction, de son arrogance pour
l'orienter dans la direction qui est qui
est donnée. Il y a très peu de personnes
courageuses, intègres et qui arrivent à
survivre dans des systèmes comme cela.
Et euh
on en reparlera mais alors
revenons à l'Afrique.
Donc le Cadors euh porte plainte contre
moi, ce qui est quand même intéressant,
ce qui est quand même logique.
Euh vous avez souvent vu un ministère
des affaires étrangères porter plainte
contre un avocat de son pays parce qu'il
défend des victimes de des gens qui sont
été torturés, qui ont été tués parce
qu'il manifestaient pacifiquement, qui
ont été détenus dans les conditions que
je vous décris et qui cherchent à
détruire l'avocat. Est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous attendriez si
vous êtes un citoyen qui n'est pas
habitué aux affaires détail ainsi de
suite d'un pays comme la France ? Ça
c'est le premier point.
Ensuite en parallèle, c'est pas une
question parce que je pense qu'on a on a
on a tous la réponse à ce niveau-là. En
parallèle, c'est plus pernicieux. Ils
entamment les mêmes démarches auprès de
l'ordre des avocats de Paris pour me
faire radier du barreau en parallèle.
Vous voyez quand même la la la
perversion et surtout la volonté
d'hylation qui qu' les habitent à ce
momentl. Ils essaient de me retirer ma
robe.
Ils vont ils vont ils vont porter
plainte parce que vous dévoilez le nom
de de deux agents français.
Et parallèlement à ça, si j'ai bien
compris, il porte plainte pour euh
auprès de l'ordre des avocats pour
parce que vous avez vous avez des
éléments du dossier.
Non, mais est-ce qu' il y a il y a pas
en fait c'est intéressant, vous vous
essayez de trouver une rationnalité là
où il y a juste un dispositif de pouvoir
qui essaie d'écraser un adversaire. Donc
on peut l'habiller, on peut dire "Ah
oui, c'est pour euh mise en danger parce
que c'était ça le prétexte, mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui." Enfin
n'importe quoi. Euh en plus c'est
intéressant parce que c'est les agents
de la DGSE mais c'est le Cadoret et pas
le ministère de la défense qui est euh
le ministère auquel ils sont rattachés
qui ent qui signe le geste en fait c'est
le Kedoret qui cherche à contrôler son
emprise sur le Sénégal qui est chargé
avec ses diplomates de
pr ministère de la défense, il y a pas
d'agent.
Et ils ne font rien. Et l'avocat OK 48
heures après en fait qu'est-ce que fait
en faisant ça aussi l'État français ?
Ils envoient un signal aux autorités
sénégalaises. 48 heures après, que font
les autorités sénégalaises ? Ils
émettent un un mandat d'arri
international contre moi, le procureur
euh de Dakar. raison
pour terrorisme, complot et ainsi de
suite. C'est qu' ils montent les mêmes
dossiers qu'il montaient contre leur
propre enfin contre les personnes qu'ils
essayaient de détruire sur le terrain.
Ousman Sonko, c'est quelqu'un qui était
c'était pas un chef rebelle dangereux
compagnie, c'était un énarc parce qu'
évidemment colonie oblige. On a fait
adopter les mêmes institutions dans ces
pays que que celles que l'on l'on l'on
connaît avec un succès assez similaire
d'ailleurs. Et il était inspecteur des
impôts et en fait, il s'était fait radié
par le président parce qu'il avait
dénoncé un scandale de corruption et
c'est de là qu'il a qu'il a commencé une
en fait une force politique déjà pour
survivre, pour pas se laisser écraser et
d'autre part pour essayer d'empêcher
cette sorte de connivance et c'est un
c'est un opérateur très critique au sein
de du dispositif sénégalais de
l'influence maintenue de du colonialisme
français et ainsi de suite.
48 he après, je suis ciblé pour les
mêmes raisons que les personnes que je
défends. Ce qui me dérange pas parce que
en tant qu'avocat, ça c'est votre
interprétation.
Non, c'est factuel. C'estàd c'est les
mêmes crimes pour lesquels je suis
poursuivi qui enfin qu'il poursuivait
pour lesquels il poursuivait mes
clients.
Mon client
est arrêté quelques semaines plus tard
pour ce prétexte de voile de téléphone
portable. On est en juillet.
Il est évident pas que
Oui. Non mais l'arrestation le prétexte
c'est qui se retrouve devant le en garde
à vue devant l'OPJ d'abord céléphone 24
heures après c'est terrorisme et
compagnie mais 24 parce que en fait ils
avaient essayé de lui faire un ce qu'on
appelle un compromate. Ils avaient
essayé de l'accuser de viol et on venait
de réussir à faire dérailler la
procédure ceci. Pour ça qu'il m'en
voulait un peu. C'estàd qu'on avait
réussi à démontrer en fait que tout ça
était un habillage pour tenter de
l'éliminer politiquement tout ça
justement après l'avoir accusé de de
beaucoup d'autres choses dans une
mécanique qui est devenue assez
classique et que on commence à à
connaître tous. Et donc cet homme-là en
prison, en garde à vue, en garde à vue
encore pardon, me désigne et moi, il est
évident que je ne pas me laisser
intimider et que j'ai pas laisser mon
client euh en présence évidemment de mes
confrères sénégalais, mais sans
l'assistance qu'il mérite. Et donc
héritage de mes années Wikileak et de
la découverte de ce que
une forme de semiandestinité
exige pour être protégé par rapport aux
appareils d'état. Je trouve un moyen de
me rendre au Sénégal sans me faire
intercepter à chaque étape qui m'amène
jusque là. Donc illégalement,
non pas illégalement, légalement
justement, je trouve une façon de
rentrer sans violer aucun mais avec ce
mandat d'arrêt international annoncé par
le procureur dont on découvre en fait
qu'il n'existait pas. C'est un coup de
bluff. C'est un communiqué du procureur
qui ne l'avait pas demandé ou alors
qu'il n'avait pas obtenu parce qu'on lui
avait dit "Mais attends Coco, on va pas
faire une notice rouge Interpol contre
un contre un avocat parce qu'il a fait
une plainte à la CPI." Enfin, on se
calme. Il faut savoir que le Sénégal a
toujours été considéré comme la perle de
la France-Afrique. C'était la capitale
de la OEF. Et donc c'est un c'est un
territoire qui en a hérité une un une
grande capacité à à générer des normes
et à les respecter. C'estàd que le
Sénégal est réputé dans le monde de par
son attachement au système de droit et
en fait ses avocats sont les avocats les
plus brillants qui existent sur
l'Afrique dans l'Afrique de l'Ouest et
ainsi de suite. Donc c'est des gens qui
sont très très d'une c'est un peuple en
fait qui a adopté une sorte de rigueur
extraordinaire dans son rapport à la
norme. Et donc ils sont pour obligés de
la contourner,
ils essayent à chaque fois de tenir de
tenir droit en quelque sorte. Donc
j'arrive à Dakar
et
je participe à une conférence de presse
qui était en cours pour défendre mon
client et je dis au procureur
je suis là, je suis là et nous n'avons
pas peur.
Et donc j'explique à quel point ce qui
est en train de se passer grave. À
l'époque, on était avant le 7 octobre.
Euh je rappelle la solidarité
internationale des luttes. Donc je parle
des enfants de Gaza, je parle des gilets
jaune et je parle du peuple sénégalais
en disant il y a une sorte de continuum
là de résistance qu'il faut absolument
préserver et je suis là pour faire ce
pont et pour être à vos côtés. On défend
depuis euh des victimes auprès de la
CPI, des victimes de Gaza justement de
familles qui sont et on en reparlera
peut-être. Donc je pars et là on sait
très bien que la machine s'est mise en
brun. Il y avait pas de mandat d'arrêt.
Là, ils en sortent un. Ils en sortent
un. Et on se retrouve dans une situation
où il faut pendant 4 jours échapper à
des forces de police déchaînées qui euh
du haut euh du plus haut du sommet de
l'État cherchent absolument à m'arrêter.
Et donc c'est perquisition dans une
ville Sainte à Toubaas. Perquisition, il
défonce la porte du domicile de mon
client. Il me cherche dans tout le pays
et il me trouve pas pendant 4 jours.
Pourquoi ? D'une part ? parce
queévidemment on a ces techniques de de
clandestinité mais surtout parce qu'il y
a un peuple qui nous protège parce qu'il
y a un peuple qui n'en peut plus de ce
système d'oppression et qui fait tout
son possible pour s'en émanciper. Au
bout de 4 jours, je pars.
Je suis peut-être le premier occidental
à à avoir fait ce chemin. Donc on prend
une petite barque de pêcheur, petit
bateau avec un moteur et on part la nuit
et on fait 25 he dans cette
je sais pas s'il appelait ça une pirogue
mais enfin bref avec deux pêcheurs pour
aller à en Mauritanie. J'avais plusieurs
choix. J'avais le Cap Vert, la
Mauritanie, le Mali, la Gambie c'était
pas possible parce que c'est un pays qui
est complètement soumis au au à ces
liens. En fait, c'est une autorité qui
était complètement soumise au pouvoir à
l'époque. Le Mali, risque
extraordinaire, c'est donner
l'impression que tout ça éit une
opération de déstabilisation plus ou
moins directement liée aux Russes parce
que évidemment au Mali, on le sait, il y
a les autorités russes qui donnent un
appui au militaires au régime via Wagner
et et donc il y avait un risque très
important
de mauvaise interprétation qui puisse
nuire à mon client.
C'estàd que on puisse penser qu'en fait
mon client était en train d'essayer de
déstabiliser la France et ainsi de
suite. Donc même si c'était la solution
de loin la plus facile et la plus
préservée, je l'exclu pour cette raison.
Le Cap Vert, c'est 4 jours euh dans
l'océan profond. Donc c'est-à-dire dans
avec le bateau qu'on avait la mort
assurée, la Mauritanie.
Donc ça pourrait arriver à Noakot à la
capitale mais le Capvert avait un
avantage, c'est qu'il demandait pas de
visa à l'arrivée parce que l'idée à
chaque fois c'est de respecter
parfaitement les règles. C'estàd c'est
ne jamais donner prise à une quelconque.
Et donc je prends avec ces deux pêcheurs
qui nous appuyaient le bateau et et le
bateau évidemment ne résiste pas à la
haute mer. C'estàd qu'on était on était
obligé d'être suffisamment loin des
côtes pour ne pas être repéré. Donc on
voyait pas les côtes et au bout de bon
donc il y a la nuit, la journée, il y a
une nouvelle nuit, on on commence à
arriver à à
Noakot, on est à 100 km mais le bateau
commence à couler enfin la barque
et on commence à écoper l'eau. Et donc
il y a un moment donné où on comprend
qu'on va pas arriver à Bonport et c'est
un peu comme presque le compte des
milieux une nuit une sorte de masse
bleue clair qui apparaît sur le rivage
des Artiques et je leur dis bon bah
autant tenter quoi. Donc ça avait l'air
d'être un palais. En fait, c'était une
caserne de garde-côte dans un village de
je sais pas de 100 habitants. Et donc
j'arrive, je me présente, disent "Bon
bah très bien, bah à No Shot, enfin peu
de problème quand on verra."
Et sauf que il y a un problème, c'est
que c'est des frontières
euh où il y a des mélanges de population
et donc il y a un sénégalais qui me
reconnaît et qui montre son bracelet
super fier en fait d'avoir l'avocat
d'Osman Sonco euh sur place et qui
commence un peu à ébruiter le truc et
les gardes du côte comprennent que je
suis peut-être un enfin en gros qu'il
faut qu'il fasse gaffe quoi. Donc là
commence toute une sorte de d'ysée. on
mamène d'une caserne de gendarmerie à
l'autre et cetera jusqu'à ce qu'on
décide de de mettre dans les services
secrets dans dans le la direction
générale des des services secrets
maitaniens qui a un endroit où on
torture les opposants ou c'est c'est des
endroits assez sinistres avec un
durcissement assez palpable de leur
rapport à moi au fur et à mesure du
parcours et euh et je sentais de
l'embarras et je sentais surtout qu'il y
avait au sein de cet appareil de pouvoir
plusieurs lignes concurrentes qui
essayaient en fait de soit récupérer
soit de se débarrasser du dossier mais
avec des instructions contradictoires et
une sorte une importante confusion à
mesure que le temps passait,
on arrive, j'arrive à avant de me faire
prendre mon téléphone portable à
prévenir les autorités espagnoles que je
suis dans cette situation et sans entame
une démarche pour pour temps simplement
me permettre de d'être apatrié. Et là,
il va se passer quelque chose d'étrange,
c'est que je vais être cagoulé, men
noté, mis dans un pickup et emporter de
la capitale vers le Sénégal à nouveau où
en fait on va me mettre dans un bateau
parce qu'il y a un fleuve qui sépare à
la frontière, on va me transférer de
force dans un dans un autre pickup.
D'ailleurs, il y a des il y a des il y a
des vidéos qui ont qui ont fini par
sortir de de militaire qui avaient filmé
à ce moment-là et donc entouré de gens
mitraillet et cetera, il m'amène sur un
avec le bateau dans un dans un endroit
assez reculé, pas du tout à l'endroit où
se font les circulations. Et je me
retrouve là dans cette situation avec à
côté du il m'enlève la cagoule, je vois
qu'il y a des vaches qui qui sont en
train de boire à côté de moi et on
m'amène dans un autre
dans un autre convoi qui lui-même va
m'amener à un autre convoi. Et en fait
de fil fil en aigu, on va me passer de
main en main jusqu'à ce que j'arrive à
Saint-Louis, donc la ville du nord de du
Sénégal où je vais être remis aux
autorités sénégalaises qui vont m'amener
à Dakar et qui vont me mettre dans cette
prison. euh dont on parlait.
Vous avez été molesté, tapé, torturé ou
pas ?
J'étais euh
l'avocat du
du représentant du peuple.
J'étais un français, j'étais un avocat
et donc en fait j'étais les Américains
diraient high value target, c'est
quelque chose avec lequel il fallait
donc dans l'illégalité
mais euh en faisant attention. Pourquoi
? parce que ça pouvait avoir des
conséquences pour chacun de ceux qui
étaient avec moi. Il savait qu'en fait
ils étaient en train de jouer beaucoup
et le gros avec ce qu'ils étaient en
train de faire et qu'il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de hiérarch d'échelons
hiérarchique a-dessus d'eux qui étaient
en train de regarder de façon très
précise ce qui est en train de se
passer. Donc ils avaient en tout donc ce
qui est évident c'est qu'il y a pas eu
instruction euh de me torturer ou de me
blesser de la part de la hiérarchie. Il
y a eu des provocations euh il y a eu
des des tentatives de déstabilisation
pendant plus de j'ai passé euh mais mais
il y a eu surtout de ma part euh une
résistance à toute forme de
compromission avec eux. C'est-à-dire que
si j'avais été arrêté au Sénégal,
j'aurais accepté. C'estàd que on a joué,
on a perdu. Là, il y avait une une
violation des règles de leur part. Il y
avait et c'est là où je suis désolé.
Est-ce que vous pensez vraiment que les
autorités mauritaniennes
auraient osé arrêter un avocat avec une
certaine surface comme la mienne
français franco-espagnole
sur leur territoire, le kidnapper, le
cagouler et l'envoyer au Sénégal en
dehors de toute procédure d'extradition
de de tout cadre juridique sans
l'autorisation à minima ou sans
l'instruction de l'Élysée. Là, c'est une
question qui n'a pas été traitée et ça a
été très intéressant parce que comme
vous le savez, j'ai un rapport assez
confrontationnel au pouvoir français de
du fait de ma représentation de beaucoup
d'opposants mais aussi du fait de la
révélation d'un certain nombre
d'informations cagé sur leur
fonctionnement et leur et leur
naissance. Euh j'ai vu le traitement
médiatique qui a suivi euh cette
situation et lorsque j'ai étis enfin
libéré parce que en même pas 24 heur, il
y avait une pétition avec 25000
personnes qui l'avaient signé en France
qui avait des gilets jaunes qui avaient
déjà organisé des manifestations qui
avait en gros toute une litanie de
personnes qui elles tiennent aux
principes fondamentaux. C'estàd que à
l'Élysée, on répondait à Mooka, c'est
pas notre problème. C'est c'est pas de
l'ordre, c'est c'est pas du niveau de
l'Élysée. Débrouillez-vous.
le chef d'état portugais parce que mon
père est portugais, les minis d'affaires
étrangères espagnoles, eux étaient en
train d'harceler les Sénégalais pour
leur dire vous ne faites pas ça et vous
ne touchez pas à cet homme. Vous voyez
la différence ? Alors que ma vie est
faite en France,
au côté du peuple français en grande
partie ces dernières années avec
beaucoup de sacrifices, on avait des
autorités qui prétendaient,
est-ce que vous pensez un instant qui
n'était non seulement pas au courant
mais qui n'était pas au surplus
consentant par rapport à à ce qui se
passait. Et quand j'ai été libéré, vous
savez ce qui ce que ce à quoi j'ai eu
droit, le monde propriété xavienne.
Quel est l'article, le titre d'article
qu'ils font ? Au Sénégal, la libération
de Rian de Brco fait polémique.
Fait polémique.
Non pas un avocat d'un opposant
politique qui est lui-même en prison
côté de 1000 personnes et enfin libéré
des interrogations sur le rôle de la
France. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Non
non non. Ils ont essayé de prétendre
qu'il était peut-être anormal qu'alors
que j'avais été parce que mon mandat de
dépôt et lescou c'était pour perpétuer
et je le savais et ça faisait pour
certains de mes camarades de cellules 2
ans qu'ils étaient enfermés dans ces
conditions là et on avait aucune
garantie de ce qu'il y a une quelconque
résolution dans les mois ou années qui
suivent. Et si la Macronie
n'avait pas mal calculé son coût et ne
s'était pas rendu compte du soutien
populaire mais aussi justement
institutionnel à l'étranger
qui qui s'apprêtait à se mobiliser pour
me sortir, leur calcul était justement
ils s'étaient débarrassés d'un problème.
Donc la France Afrique aujourd'hui
fonctionne comme ça. Et d'ailleurs
quelques mois plus tard une jeune
française de même pas 30 ans Coline F
qui se retrouvait au bord d'une
manifestation au Sénégal
s'est fait arrêter. Il a fallu 3 mois
pour la libérer. 3 mois pour la libérer.
Alors que Macky Sall avait déjà
entre-temps, alors même qu'il était
encore président de son pays, été
recruté par l'Élysée pour devenir son
employé. Et on a prétendu que peut-être
qu'on arriverait pas à la faire libérer
ainsi de suite. Pourquoi ? Pour envoyer
un signal. Une jeune une jeune fille qui
était là qui était kinésithérapeute, qui
n'avait rien fait de On l'a laissé là
pendant 3 mois dans ces géoles sans
aucune pour envoyer un signal pour dire
ce système est notre système et on va le
protéger quel que soit les coûts
encourus.
Et donc la libération a pu intervenir et
en fait ça a déclenché
un mouvement institutionnel, une mise en
visibilité qui n'ont pas réussi à
étouffer qui nous a permis insistance
après insistance avec mes confrères
quelques mois plus tard d'obt obtenir la
libération d'Osman Sonko et dont son
numéro 2 qui était lui aussi en prison
et euh
de leur permettre de se présenter aux
élections et d'être élu dès le premier
tour avec 54 % et de devenir
respectivement premier ministre et
président du Sénégal. Il a fallu en
passer par tout cela pour arracher un
peuple au fait qu'en fait la France le
imposait avec son sous-préfet de passage
qui pour tout cela a été récompensé et
recruté à l'épréfet
mais il se comporte comme tel. C'est ça
qui le rapport que ces dirigeants ont à
la France est sidérant. Il il est euh
aujourd'hui encore un certain nombre de
des principaux euh tenants de ce pouvoir
viennent dépenser leur argent, leur
fortune dans notre territoire en ayant
accumulé euh pour certains des dizaines
de millions d'euros. Et après il y a des
procédures de bien malaki et jean pass
question
quand vous étiez dans les jaules de du
pays
vous avez eu une délégation diplomatique
française pas du tout qui v voir aucune
assistance consul vous voulez que le
crime soit signé je vous l'offre
ça c'est une supputation que vous avez
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
je pense non quand vous vous retrouvez
dans une situation comme celle-ci
d'avoir assistance consulaire espagnole
l'Espagne tout de suite envoie son
consul tout de suite. Tout de suite. est
vraiment attendez la terre entière était
connue de ce qui était enfin la terre
entière je dire enfin c'est ça faisait
la une de tout le pays et même en France
il y avait on l'entendait d'ailleurs les
maises mais ce qui est très touchant mes
compagnons de cellules sont venus me
voir pour me dire ça y est tu es sauvé
les gilets jaunes ont annoncé une
manifestation c'est surfi pour te pour
pour te défendre ce qui ce qui montre
aussi là aussi de façon très forte la
l'écho qu' a eu ce mouvement
En fait, c'est peut-être une des
dernières choses qui a qui a fait
briller la France auprès des peuples.
Vous voyez, pas des médias oligarchisés
ou bourgeois qui s'excite avec des
cérémonies de Jeux Olympiques et ainsi
de suite. Des choses qui font la fierté
de ce pays. Il y en a pas beaucoup. Et
et il considérait que dès le moment
qu'il commença à y avoir en fait une
partie du peuple français parce qu'il
considèrent que les gilets jaunes
étaient une représentation du peuple
français qui commençait à se mobiliser,
le pouvoir ne pourrait rien euh pour
empêcher que je sois
Vous connaissez le surnom qu'on a donné
au gilet jaunes ? Allez-y.
Le canarie dans la mine de la
mondialisation,
c'est le c'est le les gens n'ont pas
compris que c'était le premier mouvement
écologique de masse populaire. C'est des
gens en fait qui ont refusé euh que la
le poids économique de la transition
énergétique à laquelle on on nous on on
nous qu'on nous impose en fait soit
supporté par le peuple.
Ça naît de la taxe carburant, vous vous
souvenez ? C'est-à-dire théoriquement,
c'est comme ça, c'est ce que prétendait
à l'époque Édouard Philippe, une taxe
qui était censée financer justement les
dispositions de transition énergétique
qu'on a découvert, enfin c'est moi
d'ailleurs qui est révéler avec Wikiliak
que c'était en fait une manière de
financer le CCE, une des exemptions
fiscales qui aujourd'hui nous valent la
situation dans laquelle le budget de
l'État est et qu'ils avaient échangé
entre eux pour se dire bon comment on
déguise ça ? fait une transition et les
et les g jaunes ont compris sans même
avoir la source, ils avaient pas besoin
et ils sont sortis pour dire vous ne
toucherez pas et c'est pas nous vous et
lite bourgeoise qui depuis des décennies
en train de profiter du système de
l'hydrocarbure en gros du pétrole du gaz
et ainsi de suite qui vous êtes
engraissé à pas à pas savoir quoi faire
qui n'avaient rien fait pour que d'une
part ça soit redistribué les revenus de
tout ça mais aussi pour structurer la
société pour la préparer après.
Maintenant, vous voulez que nous qui
avons été exploités pendant toutes ces
décennies, on soit à nouveau les dandons
de la farce et qu'on vous aide à
préserver vos richesses, votre position
sociale, alors vous servez à rien et
qu'on qu'on continue à en fait à à
trimer pour vous permettre de vous pour
que vous rien ne change. Vous vous
continuez à partir en vacances où vous
voulez, ainsi de suite. Nous par contre,
il faut qu'on on voit nos conditions de
vie un peu plus dégradé. les gens n'ont
pas compris à quel point ça a été un un
moment de prise de conscience et de
résistance politique mais encore une
fois écologique et une conscientisation
extraordinaire. Moi, c'est ma je pense
que c'est mon plus grand honneur, c'est
d'avoir été du côté de ce peuple pendant
cette période pour toute une série de
raisons notamment par amour et qui m'
qui m'ont permis en fait de de me porter
à les côtés à leur côté de les défendre
des personnes comme Christophe d'Étinger
comme Maxime Nicole comme Régis
Portalaise intens des personnes qui ont
qui ont pris le risque
si sinon de leur vie au moins de leur
intégrité physique parce que on s'en
rappelle hein amputation liée à des à
des ébornements à des des grenades des
encerclantes qui explosaient dans la
main ou dans le pied ainsi de suite. On
a on a 25 français qui ont perdu des
membres. C'est presque un spectacle
pasolinien voyez, de sadisme, d'exercice
de démonstration de sadisme pur de la
part du pouvoir qui empute des membres
des citoyens pour
je dirais pas de sadisme, je dirais, si
vous m'autorisez à reformuler votre
pensée, des mesures
contre-insurrectionnelles dignes d'un
pays du tiers monde
et en et en état de choc. C'est un
pouvoir en état de choc qui n'arrive
plus à contenir euh à contenir la vague
la vague populaire qui vient qui vient
les dévaster et qui ne les a pas dévasté
par choix parce que à l'Élysée, on
rentrait sans aucune difficulté, j'y
étais.
Revenons à l'Afrique. Euh comment vous
sentez les rapports France Afrique ?
Moi, j'ai
donc moi j'ai le privilège en fait de
représenter plusieurs euh segments de ce
qu'on appelle enfin de cette résurgence
idéologique qui est le panafricanisme.
Donc on a d'un côté
ce qui s'est passé au Sénégal, on a de
l'autre des personnes comme Kemy Sebba
ou Nathalie Yomb dont dont je suis les
l'avocat aussi qui
en ce qui concerne Kemy Sebba ont
théorisé intellectualisé à partir de son
expérience notamment
auprès de la Nation of Islam qui était
le grand mouvement intellectuel et
politico-religieux qui avait fécondé
Malcom qui avait fécondé
toute une série de de grands mouvements
en fait. Enfin, c'était la la branche
radicale en gros du mouvement pour les
droits civiques. Il y avait d'un côté
Martin Luther King qui défendait
l'option
de la résistance citoyenne, c'est non
violente. Et il y avait de l'autre
Malcomic et tout un certain nombre
d'organisations, le NCAD et ainsi de
suite qui avait pour vocation
de s'assurer que le rapport de force
serait suffisant pour éviter
l'écrasement des mouvements de
contre-insurrection etfin par des
mouvements de contreinsurrection qui été
mis en place par notamment dans un
premier temps ouvert le FBI et la CIA et
ensuite toute une série d'autres
d'autres dirigeants. Ça m'a fait ça m'a
ça m'a intéressé parce que vous avez
reçu la semaine dernière quelqu'un qui
avait l'air bien sous tout rapport et
qui vous a demandé son salaire, vous a
dit "Bah je gagne 5000 et quelques euros
par mois et qui vous expliquait faisait
du journalisme d'investigation en
consortium international."
Euh
attention, il est pas là pour se
défendre.
Ouais. Mais donc je juste dire quelque
chose de très factuel. Il y a une
question qui a qui a été oubliée qui qui
aurait été intéressant de poser, c'est
qui le finance ? qui finance ce
consortium qui théoriquement lutte
contre la corruption et ainsi de suite.
Et en fait c'est très facile à vérifier.
on va sur le site et ainsi de suite. Et
il y a une quinzaine de fondations
internationales. Et en fait ces
fondations internationales parmi elles
et les principales, il y en a deux qui
s'appellent la fondation Ford et l'autre
qui s'appelle la NED, National Endowment
for Democracy. Moi, il se trouve que
j'ai euh j'ai débattu devant 15000
startupers au Web Summit, ce qui a valu
d'ailleurs le patron du Web Summit euh a
raconté dans un entretien que ça lui
avait valué des pressions de
gouvernement euh pour empêcher que je
sois invité à nouveau. Là, c'est c'est
assez intéressant. vous pourrez le
retrouver euh facilement. Et je m'étais
retrouvé face à quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Michael Pillsbury qui était le
conseiller de Trump officieux pour tout
ce qui était la Chine et l'Asie et qui
était surtout la personne qui a
participé à la création de de l'une de
ces fondations, la NED qui en fait et il
le décrit, la explicité lui-même est un
une couverture de la CIA. C'estd que
dans les années 80,
il a explicité ça où ?
Bah dans ses mémoires, il le raconte en
fait. Oui, parce qu'en fait c'est
maintenant c'est quelqu'un qui a 70 et
quelques donc qui a décidé de raconter
sa vie. C'est on a on découvre souvent
comme ça en fait le fonctionnement des
appareils de pouvoir du fait de l'ego et
de la nécessité de reconnaissance que
des personnes qui ont participé dans
l'ombre très longtemps.
Et en fait, il raconte comment au début
des années 80
euh les États-Unis ont compris que bah
la marque CIA commençait un peu à à se
retrouver dans une certaine difficulté.
Euh c'est l'époque où on finance les
contrats, où on finance les mujahidin
afghan contre l'URSS, on commence à les
financer. Donc on se retrouve avec euh
avec euh bah Al-Qaeda, enfin les les
début de ce qui va devenir Al-Qaeda, Ben
Laden, tout ça qu'ils ont retrouve avec
des des missilis Stinger. Donc c'est lui
justement qui euh organise les
livraisons de Stinger en Afghanistan à
Bernaden et quelques autres. Et en fait,
on commence à avoir un certain nombre de
scandales qui touchent à à
l'organisation aussi. la révélation de
toutes les pratiques qui avaient été
mises en œuvre contre un certain nombre
de mouvements civiques pour les
déstabiliser dans toute un série de pays
dans le monde. Et donc ils se disent
"Mais on va faire comme les les
communicants en fait. Qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand une marque
est morte ? on en crée une autre et en
fait on va faire passer les financements
à travers ces fondations. Et donc la
fondation Ford, ça c'est Mccoy qui
l'avait raconté déjà 20 ans auparavant,
c'est que ces êtres-là qui sont en fait
suffisamment moyens pour ne pas
interroger le système dans lequel il
s'insère en fait sont des instruments de
ces appareils de pouvoir et en
l'occurrence indépendant, il traite les
sujets qu'il veut sur des sujets chou ou
mais en fait justement moi je me suis
intéressé parce que je l'ai vu à peu
près tenir ce discours. Ça m'a fait
penser à Chomski qui raconte que il a
rencontré un journaliste dans une
dans un aéroport. Il lui dit "Mais moi,
on m'a jamais donné d'instruction et
compagnie." Et il lui répond deux
choses. Bah c'est pour ça qu'on vous a
recruté parce qu'on a pas besoin de vous
donner d'instruction. En fait, votre
espace mental, psychique, votre
connaissance, votre intelligence sont
suffisamment limité pour s'assurer que
vous irez jamais battre les portes qu'il
ne faut pas aux portes qu'il faut qu'il
faut auxquelles il faut frapper. Et
l'autre l'autre figure assez classique,
c'est pardonnez-moi, c'est un peu
violent, mais je pense que c'est assez
nécessaire. Euh le chien qui ne tire pas
sur la laisse ne se rend pas compte
qu'il a une laisse. Donc c'est c'est la
même image c'est pour se sentir libre
faut-il encore faire bouger ses
commencer à faire bouger ses chaînes ?
Ouai bah c'est euh la même image en gros
sauf que
sauf que c'est pas un chien.
Oui sauf que moi c'est un peu plus dur
en effet. Mais mais j'ai quelques
raisons d'avoir euh je vous laisser
interagir avec lui. J'ai un rapport
assez dur en fait à pour mesurer son
indépendance et
et qu'en tout cas moi j'ai eu une sorte
de sentiment petit d'effroi en en voyant
en fait comment euh parce que ça fait
des années voir des décennies qu'on sait
en fait que le Ned que la fondation Ford
et cetera sont des instruments. Il y a
pas que je pense qu'il y a pas que eux
qui fin aller voir les autres. C'est
intéressant. Euh on va on va s'amuser et
et en fait ça le niveau de porosité en
fait la la capacité instrumentalisée
manipuler l'espace public est est très
angoissante en fait. Moi
c'est pas lui il fait pas ça.
Ah non bien sûr que non. Non non bien
sûr. Lui c'est c'est
essaie de de continuer des enquête. Il y
a des journalistes qui sont tués. Ou ou
bien sûr. Oui c'est c'est très c'est
vraiment un storytelling
tellement parfait. C'est tellement
incroyable. Non, je c'est vraiment je
qui de malhonnête pourrait avoir l'idée
d'utiliser le capital symbolique d'un
journaliste qui s'est fait butter de
dire "Ah oui mais enfin non mais vous
voyez ou pas la grossièreté de c'est
c'est magnifique, c'est génial, c'est
parfait. comment on pourrait contester
quelqu'un qui euh reprend le chemin de
Et la réalité c'est que moi j'ai été
confronté, il se trouve que je le savait
parce que parce que en fait je me suis
rendu compte en faisant mes recherches
après avoir vu cet entretien euh qu'ils
avaient euh ils avaient essayé euh de
dégommer justement un certain nombre de
personnes que je connais de façon très
malhonnête et à l'époque j'avais pas
l'élément donc ça m'avait perturbé. Je
me disais mais pourquoi ce consortium
qui d'apparence et si honnête et
compagnie fait cette ce qui ne pouvait
pas être une erreur. Enfin voyez enfin
c'était trop gros comme manipe. Je je je
connais pas l'affaire. C'est quoi ?
C'est Kemy Seba. C'est intéressant. Kemy
Seba, c'est quelqu'un que vous avez reçu
euh qui an
il y a voilà et qui qui est qui est
quelqu'un qui a très vite été détruit
dans l'espace public. C'est c'est
quelqu'un qui s'est français qui donc
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est autoforé euh
de parents béninois.
et à qui on a retiré donc le passeport
dans une procédure qui a été euh c'est
super intéressant, c'est une procédure
qui a été créée sous Dalier. Donc
c'était le premier ministre qui dans les
années 30 avait en gros lancé les camps
d'internement contre les républicains
espagnols et déjà un certain nombre de
personnes qui avaient des origines que
la République ne tolérait pas parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de Vichi mais on
parle pas en fait des périodes
précédentes et qui avait adopté ce
décret qui permettait de retirer sa
nationalité aux personnes sous certaines
conditions. un décret qui n'avait pas
été utilisé depuis les années 60
et qui a été appliqué par Darmanin dont
on sait
le contenu antisémite de l'un de ces
livres et l'entourage d'Action française
qui l'a accompagné.
J'ai pas lu le livre en question. C'est
quoi ces références là ? Ah, vous vous
souvenez pas de de de cet extrait
extraordinaire dans dans l'ouvrage de
Darmanin dans lequel il fait référence à
des à des tropes antisémites
particulièrement violente en expliquant
comment Napoléon avait de part justement
sorte de purge qu'il avait mise en œuvre
avait permis à cette en gros à cette
communauté d'usurier c'est comme ça
qu'il se retrouvait qualifié de
s'intégrer à la nation française. Vous
avez pas vu ça ? C'est c'est pas
étonnant parce que on essaie de d'éviter
de ressortir les dossiers un peu un peu
gant un peu gênants chez ces gens. Et
donc cet homme-là euh a décidé 50 ans
après de de faire retirer sa nationalité
française à à Kemba. Mais en fait c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé la réalité. On
s'en est rendu compte en consultant le
dossier d'Armanin et ce qu'il a marqué
dans ses livres, c'est c'est car c'est
lui qui l'a publié. Donc à partir de
D'accord, c'est pas une interprétation,
c'est
Ah mais ça vous le retrouverez vraiment
je pense en en 3 minutes. Et donc
Kemy Seba, Andre, c'est quelqu'un qui
est devenu la principale figure du
panafricanisme et de l'anti-impérialisme
en Afrique, en Afrique francophone en
particulier. D'accord. C'est quelqu'un
qui est à l'origine des mobilisations
qui ont amené à à la remise en question
du franc CFA. C'est quelqu'un qui a eu
un rôle capital dans le fait qu'on ait
pas envahi le pays le plus pauvre au
monde l'année dernière, le Niger il y a
2 ans, pardon. Vous savez quand Emmanuel
Macron dans l'un de ses nombreux faits
d'armes avait décidé de faire kidnapper
son ambassadeur. En gros, il avait les
autorités nigériennes avaient demandé à
l'ambassadeur de France de partir et
Macron avait ordonné à l'ambassadeur de
rester dans l'ambassade et donc les
autorités
normal
ce qui est normal. Vous connaissez mal
la pratique diplomatique mon cher ami.
Quand on déclare quelqu'un persona, un
diplomate, il part, il part et il a on
lui laisse un
lui prolonge pas son visa diplomatique.
Oui, mais monsieur Macron a a considéré
que en gros le Nigère est une terre
française en gros hein, c'est sous
préfecture, on en revient à ça. Et donc
les autorités avaient beau faire ce
qu'elles voulaient, il allait rester.
Bon, ça dure un mois. Évidemment, les
autorités nigériennes finissent par
enfin tout en
arrêter la livraison de croissance.
Voilà, c'est ça. En respectant les
conventions de Bienen, c'est en ne
rentrant pas dans la prémise
diplomatique parce que eux respectent
les conventions de vienne. Donc il
respecte le fait qu'on ne rentre pas
dans une ambassade quoi qu'il arrive et
on ne touche jamais un à un personnel
diplomatique quoi qu'il arrive. C'est
des règles sacrées si on commence à les
violer, on
violé plusieurs fois cette année
ailleurs
au dans l'ambassade du Mexique en
Équateur et quelques années auparavant
pour un un quelqu'un qui qui a marqué ma
vie et l'a changé Julian Nassange au
sein de l'ambassade d'Équateur à
Londres. Donc on se retrouve dans sauf
que ça avait été habillé, on en
reparlera. En gros, ils avaient acheté
le chef d'état équatorien pour pour
tenter de le faire à peu près
formellement. Donc euh on a droit à
cette pantalonade au cours de l'été. Et
en parallèle, que fait Emmanuel Macron ?
Il essaie de convaincre les chefs d'état
de CD CDAO, la CDAO, c'est en gros les
syndicats de de chef d'État d'Afrique de
l'Ouest, euh de déclencher une opération
militaire contre le Niger, le pays le
plus pauvre au monde, je me rappelle,
mais où on a via Orano des intérêts
stratégiques, notamment en Uran. avait
on avait parce que ces nouvelles
autorités nigériennes leur ont demandé
de partir avec beaucoup de cordialité
tout en respectant toutes les règles et
et ils ont dû partir de la même façon
que la base les franç les militaires
français et États-Unis qui étaient sur
place ont dû plier Bage
de façon encore une fois tout à fait
réglementaire. Donc on se retrouve dans
cette situation-là et euh il faut faire
contrepoids à ce délire absolu qui
consiste à à amener les nuées de la
guerre dans le pays le plus pauvre au
monde. Enfin, je veux dire, on est dans
une situation qui est quand même
effrayante et parmi les personnes qui
font contrepoids, il y a Cabisba.
J'ouvre une parenthèse sur votre client.
Quand il est accusé d'être financé par
les Russes d'avoir reçu 300000 ou 400000
€. Moi Ouais. Moi, je défends pas je
défends pas les gens qui
mon combat de façon générale, c'est pour
le nettoyage de l'espace public. C'est
pour rendre de la souveraineté au au
peuple. Et pour rendre de la
souveraineté au peuple, il faut que
l'information ne soit pas trafiquée. Il
faut pas qu'il y ait de masques, il faut
pas qu'il y ait d'intérêt caché. Il faut
pas qu'il y ait des oligarques qui
achètent des médias pour leur dire quoi
penser. Il faut pas qu'il y ait des
influenceurs, voilà, qui soient achetés
par Et donc Kemy Sebba, moi j'ai accepté
de le défendre pour une raison très
simple. il a toujours assumé
complètement euh le fait d'avoir euh euh
rencontré Prigogine, d'avoir euh il n'a
aucune difficulté à ce niveau-là et il a
une théorisation en fait qui est très
claire à ce niveau-là qui est dire "Moi,
le Esbola euh euh les Russes, les
Cubains, les Vénzuéliens, ils peuvent
tous venir m'aider. Moi, j'ai une cause.
La cause c'est la libération de mon
continent, la libération du peuple noir
des dernières vagues de colonisation qui
existent encore. Et qui veut m'aider ?
Je l'accueille. Jamais je me soumettrai
eux." et il est parfaitement conscient
que le peuple russe n'est pas des plus
progressistes dans le rapport au
racisme, à enfin voyez, enfin il n'a
aucune difficulté à l'égard d'assumer
ses alliances géopolitiques de
circonstan tant que ça lui permet
justement de mener de bien. Moi s'il
l'assume ça me convient parfaitement.
J'ai n aucune difficulté. Il a en effet
donc en 2019, je sais pas, je veux pas
dire de bêtises sur les dates ni sur les
chiffres exacts, mais tout a été tout a
été clair et il a il a fini par rompre
avec eux au moment où ils essayaient de
l'instrumentaliser, c'estàd justement où
ils essayent de créer un un un une
vassalisation. Il lui demand ils on
donné les instructions pour et il a dit
"Bye bye, merci beaucoup, c'était très
sympa. Maintenant, je suis mal".
D'ailleurs, il a fait un discours euh je
sais plus si à Moscou à
Saint-Pétersbourg dans un des forums qui
est organisé par les autorités russes
qui était très clair en disant "Écoutez,
si vous êtes là pour être les nouveaux
colons, euh ça ira. Merci beaucoup." Et
donc typiquement cette personne-là va se
mobiliser de façon extraordinaire sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment, mais
aussi avec des manifestations
pour prévenir du danger de cette guerre.
Et qu'est-ce que fait du coup la DGSE ?
Et on l'a appris parce que en fait, il
demande de lui retirer au ministère
d'intérieur d'enclencher son
sous-directeur qui s'appelle Cédric Deb
déclencher la procédure. Oui, pour c'est
intéressant parce que le courrier de
Cédric Deb sous-directeur là qui a passé
sa c'est c'est des parcours
vous avez eu accès à ce courrier là
mais parce que ils sont obligés quand
même d'envoyer un courrier pour prévenir
qu'ils vont retirer un citoyen français
né en France de parents français sa
nationalité.
La réalité c'est que quand vous êtes de
couleur noire et ou que vous avez un
lien avec une colonie, une ancienne
colonie, vous serez jamais un citoyen
français. C'est ça en fait ce qui s'est
passé, ce que ça démontrait. Mais en
l'occurrence, il fallait quand même
qu'il respecte un certain nombre de
formalismes euh juridiques pour en gros
habiller la mariée. Et donc là, il
commence à dire "Oui, dans le courrier,
le courrier est fascinant, c'est pour
voir les mentalités qui au ministère de
l'intérieur encore domine." Donc ce
Cédric Debon euh qui est un qui est un
fonctionnaire, donc je veux dire, il
exécute des ordres mais qui a un
parcours intéressant, c'est-à-dire qu'il
a toujours été à Mayotte, dans les
Antilles, à la à sous-direction chargée
d'expulser des étrangers de France.
Enfin, il a une continuum, enfin, il
s'inscrit dans les restes du continuum
impérial français. Vous voyez en gros
ça c'est votre interprétation
son parcours. Je dis pas moi j'ai pas
accès à à Et donc ce monsieur parle de
Kemyba en disant d'origine qu'il est
qu'il a des parents d'origine béninoise.
Enfin on parle c'est la première fois
depuis Vichi qu'on utilise les origines
de quelqu'un pour justifier qu'on lui
retire sa nationalité du fait par
ailleurs de ses idées politiques. C'est
quelque chose de très très particulement
par une puissance extérieure,
non ? Parce que les dispositions, on
peut rentrer dans le détail juridique,
mais en gros, il faut pour appliquer ce
décret qu'il y ait qu'on que la
nationalité d'origine
de la personne concernée
soit en fait en gros qu'il ait servi cet
état au détriment de la France. Donc en
l'occurrence Kemy SBA était
franco-béninois, il est béninois
aujourd'hui seulement parce qu'on lui a
retiré son passeport et donc il aurait
fallu qu'il serve le Bénin contre la
France. Sauf que le Bénin c'est enfin
l'extension parfaite de la
France-afrique. C'est c'est le pays le
plus les autorités de ce pays sont les
plus serviles et les monsieur Talon et
et une sorte de
ça c'est votre point de vue
de sous-préfet supplémentaire.
Non mais d'ailleurs ils étaient en tête
pas de dénigrement avec ça.
Il était en tête de fil euh de des
démarches visant à en gros envahir le
Niger. Donc c'est il faisait partie du
du cœur de chef d'état qui était prêt à
mettre à disposition les moyens
nécessaires parce que c'est un pays
frontalier avec le Niger. Et donc
juridiquement ça tenait pas mais le
Conseil d'État qui comme on le sait tous
comme l'ensemble des magistrats après
avoir condamné à mort de Gaul et jurer
fidélité à Péin, on finit par condamner
à mort enfin les magistrats la pas le
conseil d'état par condamner à mort
Pétin enfin voyez enfin bon on sait ce
que ce qui est la magistrature française
non mais qui a toujours été donc en
l'occurrence s'asser sur ses propres
principes en sachant évidemment une
chose c'est que Ken
conseill maintenant c'est pas le
conseiller d'état du tombe de goule
c'est la même structure de pouvoir avec
les mêmes réflexe légitimiste dans tous
les domaines. Et si je demain comme
hier, on décide que blanc et noir et
noir est blanc, c'est pas le Conseil
d'État qui vous a empêché de le faire.
Le Conseil d'État, j'adore parce que ils
disent que ça aucune conséquence mais
vous savez qui est le président du
Conseil d'État,
c'est le premier ministre.
Alors, on a inventé tout un formal
juridique extraordinaire qui se dire
"Oui, mais en fait le pouvoir est
dansement du vice-président. C'est juste
formel et oui, sauf que c'est une façon
de le rappeler.
Ton président mon pote, c'est l'autorité
politique que tu es censé contrôler." OK
? du calme si tu as envie d'aller.
Je connais assez bien ces institutions
qui d'ailleurs ont gangrainé le conseil
constitutionnel, le conseil d'état, les
conseil en fait le conseil constel c'est
un vous avez la l'apparence, vous avez
Laurent Fabius qui dort quand vous
plaidez devant lui à côté de Alain Jupé
et de et d'autres éminences
intellectuelles et politiques de notre
temps. Et vous avez derrière en fait,
j'ai gagné une procédure au conseil
constitutionnel pour faire annuler une
élection législative en argant notamment
du taux d'abstention depuis 80 %. Et
vous avez en fait derrière ceux qui
décident, c'est les conseillers d'état
alignés comme ça nana et qui en fait
écrivent les décisions, font les
rapports et et font signer.
Vous pouvez pas comparer le conseil
d'État qui a condamné de Gaul à la mort
avec le conseil d'Ét d'état, c'est les
magistrats. C'est magistrat. Attention,
il y a le Conseil d'État, c'est ceux qui
les conseillers d'État, c'est ceux qui
écrivent les législations anti-juives
sous la guerre à leur initiative pas sur
demande des Allemands qui consiste à
exclure de haute fonction publique, de
l'université, ainsi de suite euh les
juifs euh et sans qu'il y a aucun moment
une quelconque sanction qui soit prise
par la suite. pas seulement les juifs
d'ailleurs sur enfin il y a tout tout ce
système qui a été construit et qui et
qui se perpétue après au pouvoir des
décennies après sans qu'il y a aucune
forme de su de sanction de purge ou quoi
que ce soit. Faut faut pas oublier hein
ces institutions sont des instruments.
Le droit est un instrument du politique.
La f critiquez l'institution ou vous
critiquez les gens qu'il y a dans cette
institution ?
Moi je critique rien. Je vois des
adversaires et des ennemis c'est pas
pareil. Et je sais contre qui et
pourquoi j'ai à me battre. C'est des
gens qui en fait à chaque instant vont
faire le nécessaire pour protéger. Vous
souvenez de cette interdiction de 4
jours de manifester pendant la période
Covid sur tout le territoire parisien.
Tout le territoire parisien parce qu'ils
avaient peur de du convoi des libertés
que j'ai que je défendais. Vous vous
souvenez du déchaînement de violence
contre des gens qui demandaient juste à
ce que les mesures qui étaient prises
cessent parce qu'il n'y avait plus aucun
sens à ce qu'elles soit prise. Euh qui
vous souvenez du policier qui dégaine
son arme devant une manifestante sur les
Champs-Élysées ? J'ai vu les les crânes
fracassés dans les cellules de garde à
vue
des commissariats, pardon, de gens en
garde à vue. Les policiers ne savaient
même pas pourquoi ils étaient là. J'ai
vu les arrestations massives, j'ai pas
vu que la période du gilet jaune. J'ai
vu après en fait la violence débridée de
l'État et de ses forces de l'ordre
contre des partis du peuple français qui
essayaient de de s'émanciper et j'ai vu
surtout la validation qui a été offerte
par ces institutions à ces actes et la
protection qu'encore aujourd'hui les
magistrats offrent. Certains beaucoup de
magistrats offrent au pouvoir politique
pour s'assurer qu'il puisse continuer.
J'ai vu l'instrumentalisation de ce
pouvoir judiciaire y compris. Mais c'est
un c'est un effet de système. Quand vous
avez par nécessité un contrôle sur les
promotions et les nominations des
magistrats par le pouvoir politique, par
définition, vous filtrez ceux qui vous
résistent.
Vous filtrez ceux qui sont trop
intelligents, trop honnêtes, trop
intègres. vous assurer qu'aux instances
de pouvoir qui infiné vont édicter le
droit se trouvent des personnes qui vont
aller dans la direction que vous leur
demandez. On pourrait faire tout un
layus. Moi, j'ai vu en tant qu'avocat de
personnes politiques en France en
Guyane, j'ai vu des gens condamnés à la
prison de ferme et envoyé en détention
pour avoir brûlé des pneus devant une
préfecture.
D'accord.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Bon, on fait pas
de généralité pour pour revenir à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Vous avez un foyer insurrectionnel avec
un état qui est en panique où il y a des
puissances étrangères qui s'amusent à
exciter la population locale en plus des
revendications légitimes d'une
population qui a des problèmes de
d'inflation, des problèmes énergétiques,
des problèmes d'accès à tout un de
choses.
La guerre à 1500 km.
La guerre à 1500 km
et qui se rapproche
l'État
avec une puissance nucléaire. L'État
quand il voit ça, il panique. Il il
panique pas, il écrase
et donc il écrase il écrase.
Vous pensez qu'ils sont contentés de
l'épisode mauritanien avec moi ? On
parle d'un avocat, on parle pas de
moi c'est j'ai dû passer tout le premier
semestre 2024 loin de mes terres au
Mexique, au Sénégal à essayer de
survivre et d'éviter des arrestations
arbitraires, des menaces. Je suis sorti
donner une conférence au Mexique
fin janvier, donc juste avant qu' la
bascule au Sénégal. euh les policiers
qui m'embarquent à Roissi dans la
cellule de garde à vue et qui me disent
alors je connaissais même pas cette
fiche et pourtant je suis assez expert
dans le domaine fiche 91 et il me disent
moi j'ai l'instruction ni de vous
laisser rentrer ni sortir du territoire
je dis faudrait choisir non enfin je
rentre ou ou je sors enfin je et
finalement après tout un carambolage de
tr qu4 d'heure il m'amène au port de
l'avion qui évidemment était fermé mais
il y a un miracle parce qu'il y a un
bagage je sais pas quoi. Donc je finis
par pouvoir embarquer. De semaines plus
tard, je suis convoqué pour me faire une
nouvelle fois placer en garde à vue pour
des tweets. D'accord avec un signal et
et quand mon avocat et quand mon avocat
appelle l'OPJ m'a tenté, il est en train
de donner conférences à projet parce que
la convocation est à court délai. Vous
savez qu' la réponse ? Oui, on sait.
Ça veut dire quoi ? C'est dire tu
rentres, tu vas tu vas en cabane
pour des tweets.
Les tweets incriminés, pourquoi il vous
reprochez des tweets ?
Des tweets dans lesquels ? parce que
comme vous savez, j'ai eu le droit à ma
litanie ces dernières années de
procédure judiciaire pour essayer de
notamment depuis crépuscule, donc un peu
grâce à vous euh où je me suis retrouvé
dans une situation où on a essayé de
déventrer mon intimité notamment à
travers une procédure qui dure depuis 3
ans 3 ans 3 ans passés à perquisitionner
chez moi, à me placer sous contrôle
judiciaire, à interroger mes parents, ma
sœur sur mon intimité, mon rapport
sexualité et cetera parce que j'ai
couché avec une femme qui selon ses
propres mots avec qui j'ai été selon ses
propres mots très doux et avec qui parce
qu'elle me demandait si j'avais quelque
chose et cetera et que je suis
malheureusement un garçon assez sain et
cetera. On avait partagé une géule de la
maline c'estàd un tiers de trè qui est
ouvert c'est une instruction par on
parle pas
c'est un dossier qui est ouvert.
On en parle pas alors qu'il y a eu 150
articles de presse sur cet article
un tiers de côte de l'prenier de côte de
l'pren d'accord on on c'est une
procédure qui est en cours. Non non non
non non. en plus les droits de la
défense
et donc parce que après 150 articles de
presse qui ont essayé de me faire
passer, c'est très important que vous
entendiez ça pour un violeur, pour un
drogueur, pour un droguer, pour tout ce
que vous voulez, tout n'importe quoi.
Euh moi, j'écris pour me défendre.
La justice s'est pas encore passé.
J'écris pour me défendre et il décide de
me faire arrêter pour ça.
Donc vous écrivez pour vous défendre et
vous mettez des pièces du dossier.
Non, j'écris je mets des des extraits
comme on le fait dans dans toutes les
situations et comme ça a été fait
largement d'ailleurs en sens inverse
pour expliquer ce qui s'est passé pour
prouver parce que sinon c'est quoi ? Je
suis innocent mais vous êtes
journaliste, vous êtes pas vous êtes pas
journaliste et vous êtes parti pr.
Il y a pas il y a pas de il y a pas de
il y a pas de privilège pour le
journaliste à ce niveau-là. Et
journaliste, lui qui fait œuvre de
journalisme en France. Il y a pas du
tout de la carte de presse a pas du tout
de notion juridique. Moi je sais très
bien ce que Non non non attendez les
cocos. À un moment donné 8 mois plus
tard alors que le Sénégal est à nouveau
en ébullition qui recommence à y avoir
des morts dans les rues et qu'on est en
train de pousser sur procédure
judiciaire de l'accord avec on me dit tu
rentres plus en France parce que c'est
ça. Ils m'ont pas sinon ils m'auraient
arrêté enfin ils m'auraient convoqué en
garde à vue quand j'étais là. Non non,
ils attendent que je sois à l'extérieur
pour dire toi tu rentres plus au motif
de cette chose 3 ans après. Il faut
qu'on en il faut pourquoi ? Parce que je
vous dis c'est quand même cette affaire
là et on en parlera un jour en détail
pas aujourd'hui. Il y a c'est
l'exemple typique
de l'instrumentalisation de l'appareil
judiciaire à des fins politiques.
C'est la démon Non mais attendez donc
j'ai pas besoin de on va pas rentrer
dans un débat à ce sujet. Je juste vous
me donner votre point de vue sur le
sujet. Mon point de vue sur le sujet,
c'est la l'épitomée de l'exempli de
comment on va détruire quelqu'un pour
des raisons politiques en s'asseillant
sur toutes les règles de droit
applicables pendant 3 ans. D'accord ?
Pendant 3 ans et on va le soumettre à
une pression extraordinaire en le
menacant de 15 ans de prison et ainsi de
suite dans le but non seulement de le
stigmatiser dans l'espace public, mais
en plus de l'entraver dans son action en
tant qu'avocat et ainsi de suite et
enfin de lui faire peser évidemment la
violence atroce. psychique la peur la
peur de rencontrer quelqu'un de
l'empêcher d'aimer ainsi de suite. C'est
quand même c'est pas du tout un odin et
quand on essaie de le couler na c'est
130 150 articles vous mais ce que c'est
150 article enfin quel genre d'affairire
a autant de d'articles en 24 heures par
contre quand on démontre que c'est faux
alors là vous avez pu trouver vous avez
pu trouver un journaliste qui va dire ah
oui bah je vais essayer de réfléchir je
vais essayer de trouver
comment quand vous démontrer en détail
quand ce sera démontré
la machination mais non mais ça l' c'est
factuel moi je vous donne demain le
dossier d'instruction je le mets dans
l'espace public je vous mets au défi de
trouver une personne qui dira cet homme
a fait quelque chose
mais dans les propres mots de la
personne en question c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans c'est c'est il y a pas
besoin de le prouver. Bon bref, mais
c'est très important. C'est très
important pour vous dire que la machine
à fabriquer et à détruire selon que vous
serviez des intérêts ou qu'au contraire
vous y soyez opposés fonctionne de telle
façon que croire en l'espace public, en
la en la possibilité de par
l'information, par le processus
électoral institutionnel de changer les
choses et c'est ce qui m'amène enfin ce
qui nous amène peut-être au livre, elle
est complètement
on est on est pris dans un étau
populationnellement. Là, je parle plus
moi en tant qu'individu, ainsi de suite.
C'estd que on ne peut pas sortir du
cadre qui nous imposé électoralement et
ainsi de suite. Il y a une limite qui
vous est fixée et qui fait que si vous
débordez, si vous allez sur le côté,
vous êtes fini. Moi je suis l'enfant moi
je suis l'enfant parfait du système. Moi
je suis j'ai pass j'ai bossé au kad
c'estàd que c'est mon ancienne maison
qui a porté plein contre moi. J'ai bossé
à cour pénationale
d'ors. C'est ça. Vous avez reçu notre
première interview il y a 7 ans sur ce
sujet. sur ce sujet, j'étais à la schol
de Yel qui est quand même la maison de
de la CAM et genre de Bill Clinton et
compagnie enfin vraiment dans les lieux.
J'ai fait toutes les grandes écoles qui
fontana.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, vous étiez dans
le le le la homchool de la CIA.
Ouais.
Mais alors est-ce que vous êtes un agent
de la CIA ? Bah je pense que je suis pas
très efficace si c'est le cas ou alors
enfin vous me direz ils sont tellement
nuls que
procher les modes de financement de de à
l'autre journaliste
mais parce que j'avais à l'époque
j'étais complètement dans enfin moi ce
qui moi mon miracle c'est d'avoir mon
miracle en général dans la vie c'est
d'être un grand naïf. Moi je je je
comprends rien au début. Donc je me suis
laissé science po normale. De normal je
vais à yel à yel je all school je fais
mon doctorat nana qui dorsait enfin vous
voyez tout s'enchaîne. J'ai l'impression
que la vie était sauf que je rencontre
Juliane à 100 entre-temps et que j'ai
quand même une sorte de curiosité pour
la vérité ainsi de suite. Donc je pars
au centrafrique au moment où on prétend
qu'il y a un génocide qui avait pas du
tout pour justifier une intervention
armée au Centrafrique. L'année d'avant
j'étais allé au Nord Kivou pour enquêter
sur les milices du M23 qui à l'époque
déjà existait. c'està dire en 2012 et
j'ai écrit un article pour mon
diplomatique à ce sujet. Donc j'ai quand
même un rapport un peu peut-être
excentrique à c'estàdire que en fait
tout ça né de la Coupe internationale où
j'ai travaillé avec le procureur d'abord
comme stagiaire puis après il m'a
recruté parce que j'étais un peu malin
et je me disais c'est quand même bizarre
qu'on narrête pas de travailler sur des
zones et des des situations des
civilisations, des crises qu'on ne
connaît pas c'est qui sont à des
milliers de kilomètres de nous et à
aucun moment on va aller chercher
information et donc moi je me dis bah
faut y aller faut y aller faut aller
voir et puis
et puis tant pis si enfin il y a même
pas de de peur ou pas. C'est pour ça que
j'étais à Haïti cet été. Euh par exemple
où j'ai passé plusieurs tous vos
vaccins,
pardon.
Vous avez tous vos vaccins ?
Lesquels ? fièvre jaune
parce que maintenant Oui oui cela oui
d'autres peut-être pas mais bon ça c'est
c'est passé on va dire euh la question
de
pas vous déconcentrer hein ben
j'essaie j'essaie de de tenir le lien
mais en même temps enfin on n pas de
structure mais parce que il y aussi ce
bouquin un moment pas pour pas pour
parler du livre mais par rapport à la
conclusion que j'ai tiré de en gros de
ces 15 ans de traverser des appareils de
pouvoir et de la nécessité de sortir du
cadre ça me semble fondamental et donc à
Haïti par exemple je rencontre barbecue.
Vous savez qui est barbecue ? Jimmy
Ferisier, c'est le plus puissant chef de
gang de Porto Prince. Donc en gros, vous
lisez sur IT, vous avez l'impression que
c'est Mad Max. Enfin, tout le monde vous
explique qu'on peut pas mettre les
pieds, que
il y a des murs.
C'est c'est donc moi j'y vais. Sauf que
il se trouve que un certain nombre de
personnes tendent à considérer que je
suis un allié parce que en fait je
défends des gens qui qu'on a essayé de
détruire comme Kemy Seba, comme Ousman
Sonco dans un dans un registre très
différent, ainsi de suite. Il vous a
nationalisé il vous a nationalisé il
vous a il vous a accordé la nationalité
qui
Ousman de Sonco.
Non alors on parlerait peut-être du
pouvoir sénégalais parce que j'aurais
peut-être quelques éléments à dire parce
qu'une chose c'est de aider un peuple à
se libérer et aider à la libération de
1000 personnes et autres. Une fois c'est
ce que ces personnes-là font de leur
liberté une fois qu'ils arrivent au
pouvoir. Et ça le rapport aux politiques
est par nature je pense fondamentalement
déceptif. Enfin quoi qu'il arrive mais
on en reparlera. Non, mais en tout cas,
ils ont pas eu cette pensée à ce stade.
Il se trouve donc que Haïti
ces figures là qui en France sont
considérées comme la l'antéchrise par
exemple KBA, on a dit que c un
antisémité et compagnie parce que il y a
15 ans, il y a 20 ans maintenant au
moment où il y avait eu un crime
horrible antisémite en France, il y
avait eu une organisation extrémiste qui
s'appelle la LDJ qui est classé
terroriste aux États-Unis ainsi de suite
qui avait en gros menacé de tuer ou
d'atteindre à l'intégrité physique de du
coupable de ce crime qui était noir et
Kamis Sebba qui a une position très
radicale comme l'ont toujours eu les
organisations les plus en pointe de la
libération des peuples.
Il a trouvé très intelligent de prendre
tous ses copains et d'aller dans le
sentier. C'est ça.
Attention, c'est presque ça mais c'est
pas vraiment ça. Avez commencé par dire
vous ne toucherez pas à ce frère qui
doit être jugé, qui doit être jugé pour
ses crimes. Donc il dit il doit être
jugé mais par contre si vous le touchez
et vous en gros vous le lynchez parce
que c'est à ça que ça fait voyez là il y
aura des problèmes. OK, donc commence un
jeu de provocation dialectique et en
gros la LDJ décide de de le défier et
donc il va aller se friter il a 20 ans
et quelques avec la LDJ rue des Rosier
et de
il a des gamins, il y a des personnes
âgées, il y a des commerçants. Quel est
l'intérêt de faire ça ?
Et vous pensez qu'il a touché ça ? Oui,
voilà. On essaie d'en faire la la nuit
des des enfin pardon le le on essaie
d'en faire un pogrome quoi. Mais il allé
chercher une des organisations enfin je
veux dire pour que les États-Unis
déclarent une organisation terroriste,
ils doivent y aller enfin qui sont
inscrits dans toute une liste de
sanction et compagnie.
Parlez de laquelle ? La
la LDJ. Non non la LDJ. LDJ et il se
fera il se il se il se
organisation de l'époque elle a pas été
classée comme
la tribuca est dissoute dans la foulée
parce que pourquoi ? Parce que
évidemment de façon très intelligente on
transforme ça en gros tentative de
pogrome ou nuit de cristal. Enfin,
voyez, un truc un peu un peu déliant.
Qu'importe, ils l'ont brûlé euh dans
l'espace public français. Donc, il
décide de revenir dans la terre de ses
ancêtre et de se reconstruire à partir
de là. Et il devient en fait l'une des
plus grandes figures. Donc cette
personne qu'on a brûlé dans l'espace
français pour une instrumentalisation de
ce stigmat qui est fondamental. Je veux
dire, c'est quand même fondamental de
s'assurer qu'on retombe pas dans les
heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire. Moi, c'est ma spécialité,
hein, les violences de masse. Moi, ma
thèse, c'est en gros une réflexion sur
qu'est-ce qui provoque la violence
politique. Et toute ma vie, c'est une
lutte pour éviter la violence politique.
Et je pense que maintenant, au bout de
10 ans, on a commencé à comprendre à
comprendre la chose et et mon mon manuel
là pour fabriquer des guillotines, c'est
une idée fondamentale qui à mon avis est
très précieuse. Bon, c'est assez
complet, mais un des éléments
c'est c'est alors on n pas lu le livre,
c'est une boutade, c'est pas une
boutade, c'est une référence historique,
c'est un appel à la violence. Moi je
pense que j'ai compris en fait, j'ai mis
l'expérience des gilets jaunes m'a m'a
beaucoup marqué mais aussi
comment ça s'appelle le bouquin ?
Comment fabriquer une guillotine ?
En gros, on n'est pas rentré à l'Élysée
parce qu'on savait pas quoi faire ni en
terme programmatique ni en terme de
moyens. C'estd que
vous étiez pas invité.
On était pas invité mais on avait les
forces de l'ordre qui reculaient.
J'étais là hein et si on voulait on y
serait rentré de la même façon que
quelques semaines plus tard le monsieur
Grivotu devait prendre les jambes à son
coup pour partir du porte-parole du
gouvernement. Ce qui a un geste
symbolique magnifique, c'est que les
Français,
c'est votre perception,
demandent au gouvernement d'ouvrir les
portes
du porte-parola. C'est de leur laisser à
nouveau être entendu. C'est
symboliquement et il ne touche
évidemment à personne et il ne casse
rien et compagnie. C'est juste pour
symboliquement ouvrir ce République
qui leur appartient. Le F qui était à
côté parce que Saint-Laurent était en
train grâce à la fraude fiscale qu'ils
ont mis en œuvre Kering de rénover un
hôtel particulier qu'ils avaient acheté
à grand. Vous
avez des sources de ça ? Ah oui oui,
c'était rendu public, il y a une
procédure en cours. Ouais. Alors vous
pourquoi pourquoi je suis assez embêtant
pour pour les personnes au qui à qui on
est opposé, c'est qu'il nous m'ont donné
tous les instruments pour pas commettre
d'erreurs à ce niveau-là. Je fais très
attention.
C'était peut-être une erreur d'ouvrir
une porte de ministère au fenouw
mais c'était symboliquement la chose la
plus belle qui qui puisse arriver. Vous
rendez compte ou pas ? C'est avec un
instrument du peuple en plein 7e
arrondissement, un hôtel particulier qui
a été saisi par la République censé
représenter le peuple et vous avez des
gens qui sont en train de se faire
massacrer au gaz lacrima, au tiers de
LBD, aux grenades des encerclantes qui
pourquoi ? Parce qu'il réclament de la
dignité et d'être entendu par le pouvoir
et qui tombe sur un FWI. Donc dans le 7e
arrondissement, on s'attend pas à ce que
quelqu'un cherche à voler un un Fick.
Donc les mecs ont laissé les clés sous
sous le truc, ils ouvrent, ils disent
"Putain, il marche". Et un peu dans la
folie du moment et pourquoi en fait ça
arrive ? C'est parce qu'ils étaient
allés manifester, ils étaient venus
toute la France, ils allaient manifester
devant l'Assemblée nationale, ce qui est
quand même plutôt légitime et il s'était
fait sortir voilà à cause à 10h du mat.
Donc vous pensez que vous sortez des
milliers de personnes qui sont venues de
toute la France pour manifester, pour
réclamer, qu'on les protège ainsi de
suite et vous pensez qu'ils vont rentrer
chez eux à 10h mais vous pensez qu'ils
vont rentrer chez eux à 10h30 du mat ?
On dit "Ah bah et rentrer voir leur
famille et dire "Ah bah en fait bon bah
j'ai pris la voiture toute la nuit ou le
bus ou le train je sais pas quoi." Mais
euh bah non bah du coup il commence à à
errer euh dans le quartier des
ministères le 7e arrondissement et
miracle. Non seulement il tombe sur le
fun mais il tombe sur la petite plaque
de Benjamin Grivveau. Du porte-olio
celui rappelez-vous qui disait "Moi, la
France de ceux qui fument des gitanes et
roulant diesel c'est pas ma France. Cet
homme porta la parole de la République.
J'ouvre une parle qu'il vient pas
diable. Ils ont ils ont pas besoin.
Les gilets jaunes, ils représentent pas
tous les Français.
Ah moi, pour moi, ça a été ça a été la
dernière fois où le peuple de France a
d'ailleurs 80 % d'approbation dans les
dans les enquêtes d'opinion à l'époque.
Donc c'est la dernière fois où en gros
il y a une coagulation de la France qui
fait unanimité pour dire ça on accepte
pas là ça on fait société. C'est pour ça
que c'est à ce point. Moi ça me Wikiliak
m'a fait comprendre l'importance euh de
d'appartenir à à un d'être protégé par
un état. Pourquoi ? parce que en fait je
me retrouve avec la DGI qui commence à à
me suivre à 25 ans parce que j'ai révélé
que les communications du enfin parce
que Wikileaks a révélé mais que je
représente Wikileaks à l'époque les
communications des des présidents de la
République et des principaux chefs
d'entreprise et compagnie ADGSI est
tellement soumise
aux puissances américaines en gros à la
NSA et compagnie que plutôt que de nous
recommander la Légion d'honneur et
compagnie décident de nous de nous
mettre sur leur liste de
contreespionnage. Donc moi je sais ce
que c'est la vulnéraalité leur boulot.
Ah ouais. Ah oui, pour eux pour eux vous
êtes peut-être une puissance qui va
déstabiliser la force. Leur boulot,
c'est pas de s'assurer que nos
conseillers, nos diplomates, nos
présidents puissent communiquer de façon
sécure sans être espionné par les
États-Unis et compagnie. C'est pas au
moment de Pegasus enfin d'empêcher même
c'estàd que une entreprise privée
aujourd'hui est capable de pirater les
communications du président de la
République. Et pardonnez-moi, mais
ces ces insuffisances là, je je vais
essayer de pas être insultant, vous me
l'avez demandé.
pour eux. Donc il foire complètement
tout et en plus il s'attaquent aux
citoyens français qui le révèl, qui
l'exposent et qui essaent de lutter
contre ça. Mais enfin, pardonnez-moi,
qui a qui devient pas révolutionnaire
après avoir vécu ça ? Qui devient pas
révolutionnaire après avoir fait cet
effort énorme ? Les sacrifices et les
risques énormes qu'on a pris pour notre
vie pour défendre la France. On se
retrouve contrôlé au postefontière à
l'entrée et ciblé pardonnez-moi alors
là, je être impressionné par ces tocar
qui depuis leur bureau à Levaloin était
incapable de protéger un instant.
Tocar s'est déplacé.
C'est le minimum qu'on puisse dire de
ces gensl
non ? Parce que ces gens-là détruisent
des vies.
C'est quand même détruisent des vies et
détruisent peut-être les les esprits les
plus précieux de notre pays. Au lieu
d'essayer de les accompagner, de les
protéger, de les alimenter, ils essayent
de retourner la société contre
elles-même. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils
acceptent d'être des instruments de
lutte, de pouvoir, de faction et de
personnes qui elles-mêmes sont soumises
à des puissances étrangères. Et après,
ils prétendent le faire au nom de la
société.
C'est quoi la théorie des bayonnettes
intelligentes ?
Vous vous en parlez souvent, mais
j'oublie à chaque fois.
On en reparlera. Revenons à l'Afrique.
Dans les prochaines années, il faut
s'attendre à quoi selon vous ?
À des crises politiques intérieures
produites par ce qui se passe en
Afrique, en France, je veux dire, parce
que l'existence aujourd'hui du
Rassemblement national et le résultat
de politique d'abord coloniale, puis
néocoloniale et ensuite du n'importe
quoi qu'on a laissé s'installer au sein
des autorités politiques de ces pays.
C'est ça qui produit la la pression,
c'est l'avarie. Et là qu'apparemment
d'un certain nombre de nos instances et
de nos élites, les mêmes qui nous
soumettent en France, qui vont soumettre
les peuples là-bas, s'assurer qu'ils ne
vont pas avoir accès à une juste
rémunération de leurs ressources, un
digne de venir et qui du coup se
retrouve dans une situation de devoir
partir et s'exiler. Et tant qu'on traite
pas ça, vous pensez qu'on va donc il y a
ça et pourquoi est-ce que ça crée des
crises intérieures ? pour une deuxième
raison, le pillage est tel dans notre
propre territoire qu'on assure même pas
notre capacité à avoir des services
publics de base qui nous permettent
d'une part de traiter les Français et
éventuellement d'accueillir des
personnes étrangères. Donc évidemment,
qu'est-ce que vous faites quand vous
privez de leurs ressources
des membres d'une population ? Et bien,
elles commencent à retourner leur
violence contre eux même contre eux même
et contre ceux qui sont qui seraient
identiquement ou mieux traités que dans
leur perception. Et donc vous retrouvez
avec une sorte d'ambiance de guerre
civile actuelle, ce qui est nourri
artificiellement par ses pouvoirs euh
facux et qui amène à la crise politique
actuelle. On est dans une situation où
euh où euh où euh les gens
en fait on nous on on nous fait oublier
euh
l'effondrement
d'abord de nos élites parce que c'est
devenu des élites Comprador. C'estàdire
que la fonction aujourd' nos élites,
c'est de laisser passer les pouvoirs
étrangers contre quelques formes de
corruption ou autre. En gros, une grande
partie de nos élites fait exactement ce
que faisaient les élites des États
africains que l'on avait colonisé
aprèsmelle, c'est-à-dire s'assurer de
faire la transition et que il y a des
pouvoirs étrangers qui puissent venir
dans le pays, sortir les ressources et
repartir.
Conscient, c'est pas conscient, c'est
selon vous,
mais c'est c'est c'est de l'impensé pure
à 99 %. C'est des c'est des complicités
systémiques. C'est comme votre
journaliste qui gagne 5500 € par mois,
probablement parce qu'il pense qu'il est
très brillant. Il avait rien fait de sa
vie jusque là pour permettre. Je peux
pas je peux pas vous laisser dire ça.
c'est c'est pas vrai. C'est c'est
dégradant pour rien.
Vous le connaissez pas.
Ah si si, mais je connais son travail.
Mais pas lui personnellement mais lui ne
m'intéresse pas qui se souvient de son
pas là. Il est pas là pour se défendre
mais il il serait pas capable de se
défendre. C'est pas lui le problème
encore une fois. Ah bah bon courage à
lui pour m'expliquer la fondation Ford
et la Ned. Je pense qu'il sait même pas.
Mais c'est ça c'est ça qui est
passionnant. c'est que je pense qu'il
sait même pas ce qu'elle aide, il
accepte les fonds. Enfin, voyez, je
pense qu'il sait pas.
K et après mais non parce que Kemyba le
sait très bien. C'est très bien que
Prigogin quand un moment il essaie de
l'instrumentaliser, c'est qu'il a il a
un objectif derrière mais sauf que lui
il a une conscience encore plus aigue du
fait que derrière ce sera les ennemis
d'après.
Non mais lui il a une conscience aigue
du journalisme.
Ah bon ? Ça s'est pas vu hein. C'est pas
vu. Moi un autre truc
l'avait peut-être pas vu.
Ah si un autre truc intéressant c'est
pas lui encore une fois sur Non non non.
pas là pour se défendre. Ça sert à rien
de l'incriminer et de dire que
il est financé par la CIA. Donc c'est
forcément soit un mec qui bosse pour la
CIA ou soit il est tellement stupide
qu'il en rend même pas compte.
Je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
mais c'est un peu comme Média Part qui
créé grâce à un proxénet qui s'appelle
Xavier Niel. Ancien proxenet. Attendez,
il a été condamné pour blanchissement
décision judicière définitive pour
blanchiment d'activité lié au proximisme
parce qu'il avait des sex shop qui
employaient des prostitués qui allait
chercher l'argent liquide tous les
vendredis tous les premiers vendredis
mois pour aller pour aller financer ces
autres activités pardon hein. Donc ça
c'est factuel, ça a été raconté
plusieurs fois et donc Médiapart c'est
pas factuel on d'accord
et Miaappart utilise ses fonds pour se
lancer après quand je l'expose prétend
le nid et cetera et surtout derrière
prétendre se transformer en chevalier
blanc de la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et ainsi de suite
instrumentalisation de la cause à chaque
fois sans avoir jamais dit un mot du
fait qu'ils ont été fondés par quelqu'un
qui a fait de l'exploitation de la femme
son fond de commerce et une continuité
structurelle qui n'a jamais été variée.
ce genre de situation par lesquelles
vous avez un une instrumentalisation
d'une cause noble à des fins de services
d'intérêt qui vont vous permettre de
dégommer un tel ou un autre selon
justement la la dynamique de pouvoir
dans laquelle vous insérez et c'est très
difficile de se rendre compte et
d'éviter d'être l'instrument. Moi, c'est
ma panique permanente. C'est ma panique
permanente, c'est que faute
d'information suffisante sur la personne
avec qui je vais travailler, je devienne
moi-même l'instrument d'opération
d'influence qui par définition vocation
rester secrète. Et j'ai peur en
permanence. Par exemple, en Haïti, c'est
une une association de diaspora qui
m'invite, qui me dit "Bon voilà, on
aimerait bien que vous nous aidiez, que
vous trouviez des instruments juridiques
pour essayer de régler ce problème de
criminalité endémique et qui qui pourrit
le territoire."
On fera venir à Louis Plenel pour vous
expliquer que que vous puissiez vous
souvenez quand vous avez après notre
dernier thinkerview, vous avez invité
Edou Penel, vous lui avez posé une
question sur moi et il a dit "Il faut
qu'il fasse attention parce que en gros,
je me souviens plus le terme exact mais
on le retrouve parce qu' est filmé. Donc
en gros, on ne survit jamais seul dans
ce système." Bah c'est là où il lance
une opération pour me dégommer 2 ans
plus tard. Pourquoi ? parce que j'ai
révélé que Niel était l'un de ses
premiers financeurs et qui s'est appuyé
sur lui pour lancer son canard.
Ça c'est de la supputation
et c'est c'est chronologiquement suivi.
C'est chronologiquement votre
Mais non, c'est pas une interprétation.
C'est un c'est un c'est un suivi de fait
assumé par la personne en question qui
vient vous le dire en plateau et envoyer
son petit message je vais te dégommer
dans 2 ans.
Il a dit quoi ?
Je sais pas.
Comme les mafieux. On ne survit jamais
seul. Voilà c'est c'est bien pire. C'est
c'est c'est exactement le genre de
pratique qui sont utilisé. Non, c'est
pas une interprétation, c'est un signal
qu'on envoie clairement. C'est ce qu'on
fait en fait dans ce genre de de milieu.
On cible. Et on va revenir peut-être si
vous voudrez sur toutes ces questions,
mais parce que vous voyez, c'est très
intéressant pour moi qui en tant
qu'avocat euh est censé tenter de
protéger des personnes d'opération de
cet ordre-là. devenir ciblé moi-même,
c'est c'est un signe de dérédiction
d'une société quand vous attaquez non
plus nécessairement à à l'objectif
direct, mais à celui qui a pour fonction
dans votre société théoriquement
simplement de le protéger. C'est ce qui
se passe en Russie beaucoup. On attaque
les avocats et pas seulement les
opposants politiques. Donc dans cette
situationlà, Haïti donc j'y vais nana et
je me rends compte qu'en gros on est en
train de me tendre un piège. C'estàdire
qu'on est en train d'essayer de de de
manipuler pour participer pour aider des
gens qui en fait sont en train d'essayer
de fa monter un coup d'état. Vous voyez
? Et à ce moment-là, vous êtes dans une
difficulté assez importante parce qu'en
plus, vous êtes dans un territoire qui
est quand même pas des plus safes. Vous
êtes entre les mains des personnes qui
étaient censé s'assurer comment vous
sortez de cette situation. Mais déjà, il
faut il faut l'admettre. Il faut
admettre qu'on s'est fait avoir. Il faut
avoir l'humilité de se dire bah voilà,
j'étais naïf. L'intelligence de
comprendre que quand on est dans une
position en l'occurrence comme la
mienne, on devient un poisson
appétissant. On a envie de s'utiliser,
de l'utiliser et de l'orienter et de
faire passer par un projet justement de
financement d'initiative démocratique.
On vous repère, on se dit bah lui il a
une bonne image. Bah en fait on va on va
essayer de récupérer cette image pour
couvrir quelque chose qui a l'air sain
et qui en fait est juste une opération
de prédation ou de déstabilisation. Et
mais pour comprendre ce qui se joue, il
faut d'abord travailler d'arrache-pied
et il faut avoir l'unité suffisante pour
se dire "Mais je suis pas je suis pas un
héros, vous voyez, je suis pas je suis
pas un mec qui tout d'un coup attire
plein de causes super jolies et
compagnie pour des raisons angéliques et
et parce que en fait je suis je sers le
bien." Non non, c'est il faut avoir
l'unité de se dire "Attends Fichi que
tout d'un coup on commence à me demander
de faire telle ou telle chose, est-ce
qu'il y a pas derrière une tentative
d'instrumentalisation et ainsi de suite
C'est c'est une question fondamentale.
C'est mais oui mais que très peu de
personnes ont et non seulement les gens
n'ont pas le réflexe mais derrière
souvent ils ont pas la connaissance
suffisante pour se rendre compte de et
si vous et donc il est très facile même
après avoir fait pendant 20 ans des
choses géniales et sincères à en donner
sans le vouloir ou peut-être aussi par
l'assitude parfois de façon volontaire
en fait devenir soit un instrument de
corruption soit la corruption soi-même.
Et ça c'est une lutte permanente qui qui
exige aussi une capacité à prendre des
risques. C'est à un moment donné à
s'exposer et à dire bah je suis prêt à
me retrouver RSA, je suis prêt à me
retrouver à nouveau dans une misère
noire ou à lâcher les ponts de ce qui
était censé me protéger, sauver ma vie.
Je suis prêt à prendre le risque de
devenir une cible plutôt que de
continuer à être protégé par un système
dont je sens qu'il est pas tout à fait
tout à fait sain.
On vous fera revenir avec Laurent
Richard et Plenel. Vous vous occuperez
euh
J'ai pas besoin de parler à vous
occuperez à délayer votre ch
ils sont pas on n'est pas au même
niveau.
Bon, revenons à l'Afrique. L'évolution
de tout ça, il faut s'attendre à quoi ?
Je vous laisse continuer de délayer.
On a donc plusieurs formes de
souverainisme concurrent.
On a euh
il y a des il y a des il y a des forces
politiques comme celle d'Osman Sonkoco
qui cherche à qui ont pour priorité
d'améliorer à court terme le niveau de
vie de leur population
tout en maintenant leur insertion dans
la mondialisation. C'est qu'en gros ils
sont
consci enfin pardon à raison ou à tort,
ils considèrent que le rapport de force
est tellement défavorable qu'ils peuvent
pas rentrer en être en rupture avec le
système existant. Il y a que des pays
comme la France qui pourraient provoquer
cette rupture. Et encore, c'est
difficile mais il y a la possibilité
réelle pour la France de refonder un
système économique, productif et
politique qui soit pas cette insertion
dans l'espace
mondialisé dominé aujourd'hui par les
États-Unis, mais qui demain fera de nous
probablement les esclaves de la Chine.
C'est les derniers espoirs de
révolution, paradoxalement parce qu'on
est une des populations les plus
bourgeoises au monde, réside dans des
territoires comme le nôtre. Ça c'est euh
et c'est pour ça que la la période
actuelle est très intéressante. C'est
pour ça qu'on commence à fabriquer des
manuels euh pardon à à éditer des
manuels pour pour fabriquer des
guillotines. Parce que je me dis que si
euh on commence à planter euh des
guillotines dans des jardins euh en face
ils vont commencer à comprendre que le
rapport de force est réel parce que pour
l'instant ce qu'ils ont vu, c'est qu'il
suffit d'arracher quelques mains et de
tirer dans le tas pour pour régler le
problème. Donc qu'en fait si on comprend
pas qu'à un moment donné le rapport de
force est paradoxalement la seule façon
d'éviter la violence et d'éviter de se
faire piller et de voir nos conditions
de vie se dégradé au fur à mesure et
bien il faudra en passer par une
dynamique qui finisse par les inquiéter
et par les faire trembler. Ce qu'avait
fait les gilets jaunes en rentrant dans
l'arrondissement dans les centres des
des grandes villes et ainsi de suite. Ça
c'est un élément.
Donc ça c'est un souverainisme. Je vous
coupe.
Ouais.
La violence c'est la force des faibles
et commence où s'arrêtent les
connaissances. H
planter des guillotines dans les
jardins. C'est fait pour quoi ?
fabriqué,
c'est fabriquer des guillotines dans les
jardins. C'est c'est pour un rappel
historique, un rappel de tradition
rappel qu'on coupe la tête. Est-ce que
c'est pas un appel à la violence ?
Est-ce que c'est pas
non, c'est un évitement de la violence.
La violence, elle est la violence
aujourd'hui dans cette société, elle est
dans un système politique qui ne sert
plus ces populations et qui cherchent
seulement à enrichir ou protéger un
certain nombre de personnes qui
eux-mêmes sont des passeurs pour des
pouvoirs plus importants.
Je pense que
essayez essayez de faire l'avocat. Vous
avez essayé de vous faire soigner cet
été dans un hôpital ? Vous avez essayé
d'aller aux urgences ?
J'ai j'ai
pratiquement jamais malade.
Ouais.
Mais j'ai des infirmières et des
médecins urgentistes qui me tiennent au
courant des conditions euh dans certains
Vous seriez mort si vous aviez une
urgence réelle. H
c'est ça. On est c'est on parle d'une
des plus puissantes c'est une nation qui
était 2è puissance mondiale
économiquement parlant à un moment dans
les années 60. 2e, d'accord ? C'estàd
que en 50 ans euh et aujourd'hui euh euh
la crise du Covid, c'est la même chose.
La crise du Covid, c'est une crise de la
souveraineté. C'est une crise des
capacités hospitalières. C'était juste
qu'en fait on avait déjà saturé
tellement les urgences que la moindre
petite chose euh menac en fait et qu'il
fallait on préférait arrêter le pays
plutôt que de se retrouver avec des gens
qui mouraient de façon explicite faute
de pouvoir les soigner par moyen. Par
moyen pas par à cause de la gravité du
Covid des compagnies. Non non, juste
parce que l'État a été tellement pillé
qu'il a plus d'infrastructure
hospitalière et médicales suffisante
pour soigner sa population en temps
normal.
C'est sûr que trier les patient sur les
trottoirs, c'est compliqué.
C'est à là qu'on arrivé parce que parce
qu'il y a déjà un tri effectif à chaque
épidémie de gripe. Donc imaginez-vous
juste même c'est pour ça même une
épidémie relativement bénine comme l'a
été le Covid finalement on s'en est
rendu compte après coup. une épidémie
qui ne faisait mourir que les plus de 65
ans.
Oui. Alors c'est pas si bénin que ça ça
gros ta mortalité mais
même chez les jeunes même sur les covid
asymptomatique.
Et bon, les covidatiques, on en
reparlera. Mais en tout cas sur vraiment
quand vous regardiez les les courbes de
mortalité,
elle n'avait il avait d'effet
significatif que puis on est dans une
société relativement vieille he il faut
pas sous-estimer l'impact que ça a et
puis c'est important de sauver justement
c'est important de pouvoir soigner des
gens même s'ils ont 70 ans 80 ans et
ainsi de suite. Mais c'est ça qu'on
était incapable de faire. C'est pour ça
qu'on a enfermé tout le reste de la
population aussi pour éviter qu'en fait
il y ait une sorte de de mort de masse
chez les chez les plus âges encore une
fois parce que on avait pas les
capacités hospitalières pour pour gérer
à temps réel. On parle des écoles de la
on n'est même plus qu' enfin cette
promesse annuelle qui consiste à dire
oui oui, il y aura un professeur devant
chaque classe. Moi j'ai été prof
remplaçant de reprise par justement par
des vouements citoyens alors que j'avais
quand même les euh la volonté de faire
autre chose et enfin la capacité pardon
à faire autre chose si je le souhaitais
à Saint-toin et à et à Tier euh 3 mois
sans cours avant que j'arrive et ils
m'ont recruté euh enfin vous avez une L3
en quelque chose. On va très bien.
Allez, on vous envoie du jour lendemain.
Il passe le bac dans 6 mois et en SP
hein, enfin ses en SP. Donc c'est-à-dire
avec à l'époque c'était le bac donc COF9
en sciences économique et sociale.
C'était COF9 enfin c'était où est leur
bac ? Je peux vous je peux vous dire
qu'il il j'entendais pas une mouche
volée hein. Ils étaient tellement les
pauvres gamins, vous voyez. Pour pour
des gamins déjà arrivé à un bac général
euh quand vous venez de d'une condition
sociale euh défavorisée en France, c'est
c'est-à-dire c'est à la fois un effort
et un sacrifice de la famille, du gamin.
C'est pas la norme. On est loin de la
norme. C'est je sais qu'il y a une
naturalité euh dans les classes
bourgeoises de se dire "Bon, c'est
facile de bac et compagnie." Pas du
tout. En fait, il y a une telle
discrimination en terme de social euh
qu'on se retrouve dans une situation où
donc et les gamins en fait se retrouvent
3 mois sans prof, ils étaient terrorisés
terrorisés par ce qui leur arrivait et à
tien philosophie
j'en parle pas. Donc quand vous êtes
dans une situation comme ceci où la
France entière a commencé à respirer
soulagé euh quand elle a vu qu'elle
était capable d'organiser une cérémonie
d'ouverture d'un événement
international, je veux dire, on en est
arrivé là, on en est arrivé à ce niveau
euh d'angoisse existentielle à l'égard
de notre propre médiocrité, de
conscience de ce que le pays est en
train de s'effondrer et on a dû vider,
on a dû vider la ville de ses habitants
pour pouvoir l'organiser cette société,
cette cette cet événement. Donc donc
voilà, je parle même pas du système
judiciaire qui est dans un état. Moi,
c'est la honte ce système judiciaire
français. C'est la honte à la fois pas
tant parce que les salaires des
magistrats sont très confortables, trop
confortables peut-être, il les écartent
d'une grande partie de la population et
de l'autre côté une sorte de
on en fera on en fera parce que en fait
ce que j'ai vu m'a profondément dégoûté
en pourtant pas longtemps mais ces temps
de barre j'ai découvert un système qui
détruit à une vitesse effroyable les
gens et qui au contraire est organisé
structurellement pour protéger ceux qui
doivent l'être sur des fondements de
classe ensuite éventuellement sur des
orientations politiques et ainsi de
suite.
et au détriment de au détriment enfin
demander faites un sondage sur la
confiance qu'à la population dans
l'appareil l'appareil judiciaire
français. Alors si vous avez un pays qui
ne sait plus soigner ou seulement dans
des conditions parce qu'on a encore de
très très bons médecins dans l'élite
mais qui n'arrive plus à soigner la
population générale dans lequel le taux
d'obésité a doublé en 20 ans dans lequel
le système scolaire universitaire en
train de s'effondrer, dans lequel quand
vous arrivez avec un doctorat moi
j'avais j'avais conseillé à Ousman
Sonco, le prénonci, je dis mais créer un
institut de recherche avancée, vous
allez voir les meilleurs chercheurs de
France, ils vont tous venir parce qu'ils
commencent leur leur carrière à 1600 € à
peine au-udessus du SMIC après et ils
sont 200 à 300 à se battre pour un poste
ou deux au CNRS et avec un doctorat tous
des publications et compagnie. le niveau
de popérisation de l'université
française, le niveau de pillage de
l'université française avec des
dispositifs comme le Crédit Impôt
Recherche qui sient euh les fonds public
au service des grandes entreprises et au
détriment de la formation initiale et
est une honte et qui est en fait en
train d'obérer le devenir de la nation
de façon dramatique. l'impossibilité de
se loger à Paris pour la jeunesse, pour
les classes moyennes, pour les classes
populaires. La spéculation enfin du fait
de la spéculation immobilière qui elle
même généré par les politiques
monétaires qui sont adopté aux seines
européennes, ça fait 20 ans que ça
le manque de projet immobilier, c'est
c'est des vies qui sont brisées. C'est
que là là je vous parle de on fait de
l'abstraction, on fait de la politique
mais dans dans le réel c'est des gens
qui après 15 20 visites d'appartement
sont brisés en fait et voi leur leur
couple se brise, leur leur projet de
famille se brise, leur capacité enfantée
à régénérer la société française, leur
désir d'exister, leur sentiment de
reconnaissance des gens qui ont fait des
efforts immenses pour faire des bonnes
études ou tout simplement pour réussir
économiquement pour et à côté de ça, on
a une société qui tient grâce à quoi ?
grâce à l'immigration clandestine de
milliers de Bangladéchi qui viennent des
esclaves du contemporain qu'on qu'on
dont on profite des des fragilités
générées par la loi pour en faire des
livreurs à vélo des classes moyennes
pour que les classes moyennes se sentent
une histoire j'ai une histoire d'amour
avec une une étudiante en cinéma de de
25 ans il y a quelques années
avec sans la maline
sans avec ou sans qu'importe d'ailleurs.
Ça ça ça n'aurait jamais dû concerner
qui que ce soit. Et vous avez eu raison
d'ailleurs de de mettre à distance tout
de suite dire "Attendez, c'est c'est le
réfle". Sauf que quand vous rentrez dans
un tel niveau d'éventrement euh de votre
propre vie et de votre intimité, vous
êtes obligé de rentrer là-dedans. Moi,
j'ai vu ça avec Julian qui a passé 10
ans à se justifier de la fausse
accusation du qu'il avait subie, du fait
d'être un agent du FSB, du fait d'être
et cetera. Et je me souviens de lui dire
"Mais arrête d'en parler, tu as pas
c'est pas grave, c'est pas c'est pas un
sujet, c'est c'est pas ce que tu es en
train de faire est tellement énorme et
et c'est tellement téléphoné et et en
fait c'est impossible de pas tomber dans
ce piège." Et ils le savent et en fait
il vous il vous harcèlent et il vous
tamborine avec ça pour éviter que vous
pensiez et parliez des autres pour vous
rentrer sur dans un dynamique à
vous-même. Et donc je finis juste sur
cette cette
jeune femme
brillante, cultivée, ambitieuse, qui
voulait faire du cinéma, enfin Bra et
qui et qui
et qui donc pour étudier et vivre à
Paris et et était serveuse dans un dans
un dans un dans un restaurant un peu un
peu chic parisien et euh
et à à qui on
avait convaincu
euh qu'elle faisait partie de la classe
moyenne alors qu'elle gagnait euh à
peine au-dessus du SMIC et euh et un des
facteurs qui lui permettait de croire à
cette propre illusion qui s'est brisée
quelques mois plus tard, c'était le fait
qu'en fait les vrais prolétaires,
c'était ceux qu'on montre jamais aux
terrasses de restaurant ou c'est ceux
qui sont en cuisine, ceux qui font et
qui eux ont tous la même couleur de
peau, en l'occurrence viennent tous
d'Asie du Sud-Est et qui triment euh et
qui sont traités comme des moins que
rien et qui permettent au système de
tenir. Ces gens-là ont des enfants qui
commencent à avoir la majorité
aujourd'hui qui ont grandi dans une
société dont ils ont vu comment elle a
traité leurs parents
et on va voir quel niveau de
politisation et c'est sur eux que repose
une partie de mon espoir c'est des gens
qui ont vu en fait ce que c'est ce qui
était devenu la société française et sur
quoi sur les les bases très friables et
qui vont avoir envie d'être reconnu pour
leurs talents, leur travail et ainsi de
suite et pas évidemment de perpétuer
l'exploitation de leur leur leurs
parents. Et je suis allé au Bangladesh
justement aussi pour travailler sur ces
questions et pour voir les conditions
dans lesquelles et ce qui génère en fait
ces filiales clandestines qui à travers
l'Afghanistan. Vous imaginez pas les
parcours qui sont qui sont qui qui sont
traversés pour arriver jusque là. Et
c'est pour ça qu'ils acceptent n'importe
quoi parce qu'en fait ils ont tellement
dû sacrifier, tellement dû s'exposer
pour pour arriver sur cette terre que
que
voilà que ça crée en fait un un rapport
où où la ténacité et l'acceptation de la
de la dureté de la vie est démesurée.
des 150 millions de Bangladéis qui
rêvent d'un mode de vie à l'occidental
parce qu'on les bombarde culturellement
de la même façon que nous on est
bombardé par les États-Unis par les
contenus qui nous amènent en fait à ça
c'est une critique que j'ai pour la
gauche actuelle ce qu'on appelle la
gauche des ram on en reparlera
et qui essayent à leur façon de limiter
sur place pour ceux qui restèrent qu'
vous voyez émerger doucement une classe
moyenne au Bangladesh et ce qui explique
en grande partie les les mobilisations
de l'année dernière mais aussi de
l'année précédente qui étaient en
théorie différente mais qui en fait sont
très similairire qui des renversements
du pouvoir euh qui qui du coup en fait
construisent
d'une façon très sale
avec des gens pendus à des ponts. Euh
mais vous vous mensez que à un moment
donné quand quand vous avez
littéralement des esclaves du
contemporain, la libération va se faire
avec des œillets comme comme
vous pensez que l'élite française
redoute ça et est-ce que vous pensez que
cette angoisse les rend de plus en plus
dur ? Mais les gilets jaunes qui que
j'ai croisé
descendant la rue de Ren, donc dans le
6e arrondissement de Paris,
qui m'ont fait pleurer d'émotion de les
voir dans cette terre qui était la
mienne
sont les mêmes qui moi m'ont ému au
larmes. Par exemple, pu justement
c'était peu après un peu avant
crépuscule qui venait remercier aussi
pour pour l'engagement qu'on avait ainsi
de suite. Ce sorte de moment de
fraternisation sont les mêmes qui
faisaient que tous les bars, tous les
magasins étaient
complètement
euh enfin non seulement fermé mais
barricadé par peur de ce peuple. Paris
se vidait les samedis, ils étaient
terrorisés à à l'égard de ce qui se
passait. Et ce qui dit aussi le niveau
de mes connaissances qu'ils ont par
rapport au peuple français. C'est pas
les mêmes peuples aujourd'hui. On est on
est sur deux mondes qui qui n'ont plus
rien à voir. C'est ce que dit Luxman
quand il dit "Je me sens plus proche
d'un d'un New Yorcais que que habitant
de la Creuse." Bah moi, c'est pas le
cas. Moi, je peux vous dire que je
préférais 1000 fois la rupture avec New
York ou avec une quelconque d'ailleurs
puissance étrangère et et pour pouvoir
régénérer du lien social, pour lutter
contre la solitude qui est en train de
gangriner notre société, pour refaire
justement société autour d'une idée
commune que de continuer à alimenter ce
système mondialiste prédatorial qui
détruit des vies mais aussi des
écosystèmes à des dizaines de milliers
de kilomètres de chez nous. Je ferai
tout moi pour m'assurer que plus jamais
des populations
comme cette jeunesse sénégalaise qui est
privée de toute perspective se retrouve
dans une situation où ils sont prêts à à
braver la mort et à prendre le risque de
la noyade qui est peut-être la pire mort
qu' àquelle on puisse être confronté
pour pouvoir finir par arriver en
Espagne en France et vivre dans les
conditions que l'on sait ostracisé comme
ils le sont. Donc pour revenir à à
l'angoisse de l'élite supposée euh euh
de la vindicte du peuple qui se qui se
relève et qui se redresse selon selon
votre façon de le de le percevoir,
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
angoisse
de se faire attraper
euh à la fourche, passez-moi
l'expression historique et ancestrale
ou à la guillotine,
ça l'étend un peu et est-ce que ça
l'étend pas un peu que vous vous mettiez
un tutoriel dans un livre de comment
faire une guillotine dans un jardin.
Et pourquoi vous pensez qu'il m'arrive
ce qui m'arrive ? Vous pensez que en
fait regardez les
Vous cherchez un peu quand même.
Regardez les reportage de presse qui
était fait sur moi. Regardez par
exemple, il y a une émission qui est
encore en ligne qui s'appelle le
supplément sur Canal Plus qui avait fait
un portrait de 15 minutes de moins en
2016. Regardez comment je suis l'enfant
chéri de l'élite idéal idéal parfait et
ainsi de suite. Regardez comment
aujourd'hui je suis décrit, construit et
évidemment en quelques années je serais
devenu un monstre absolu. Pourquoi ?
parce que j'ai exposé
le fonctionnement de ce système parce
que j'ai arrêté de déjeuner avec des
oligarques avec Xavier avec Bernard
Arnaud et que j'ai pas voulu jouer au à
mon camarade de classe à Gabriel Atal
âme au diable pour pour un poste et une
sorte de devenir.
Vous l'avez votre camarade de classe,
c'était quand même pas sympa. Alors là,
ça c'est marrant l'instrumentalisation
de
des luttes, on en revient toujours au
même. Je pense que c'est le mal
contemporain, c'est-à-dire que vraiment
donc là en l'occurrence des gens qui
n'ont jamais rien fait jamais rien fait
pour défendre la cause minoritaire en
l'occurrence de LGBT et compagnie qui
ont toujours profité de leur position de
pouvoir bien installée pour et qui parce
que vous exposez des liens népotiques,
on parle pas qui en a quelque chose à
faire de la sexualité de ces personnes.
En tout cas, moi pas. Moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir si un
conseiller politique décide de donner à
son conjoint avec lequel il est paxé, ça
pourrait être sa conjointe, j'ai rien
faire la meilleure circonscription
disponible pour essayer de le promouvoir
au sein d'un système donné pour servir
en retour ses intérêts. Je donne une
information intérêt générale qui a
d'ailleurs été récupérée et pillée après
toute l'ostracisation dont j'ai fait
l'objet y compris par Media part quand
ils ont révélé que tous les deux avaient
privatiser le palais d'ien donc le
palais du conseil économique et social
en 14 juillet pour regarder leur feu
d'artifice au frais de la princesse et
de l'État parce que évidemment
évidemment entre-temps cel l'un est
devenu premier ministre
les gardes du corps qui étaient derrière
à attendre
et et à ben ils auraient pu l'ouvrir au
peuple alors. Ah ben tiens ce réflexe on
l'a pas. Ah tiens, on se dire bah c'est
quand même grâce aux efforts de millions
de Français qui se prennent quand même
une des fiscalités les plus élevées de
la terre pour des services publics qui
sont en train de s'effondrer, ce serait
peut-être bien de leur rendre un peu de
ce qu'il nous donnent au quotidien et
qui nous ont permis d'asquer.
Raconterai une histoire quand j'ai été
invité à l'Élysée euh sur un
pen test organisé à la à l'Élysée. Ils
ont essayé de me sortir parce que je
posais des questions à des potes à cœur
sur Assange et sur Snowdon et et la la
conseillère pas la conseillère la
comment on appelle ça la porte-parole de
l'Élysée il me dit bon on a déjà été
sympa de vous recevoir chez nous
voilà je dis attendez attendez ici vous
êtes pas chez vous êtes chez nous
il y a un F qui
ça l' calmé ça l'a calmé tout un F qui
leur a rappelé donc je suis étonné que
ça ça vous a ça vous aidait plus la
voquer du diable et je suis contre la
violence
il y a quelques minutes mais c'est pas
une violence al attendez ouvrir les les
portes d'un palais de la République sans
toucher un homme sans détruire
structurellement ou quoi que ce soit qui
requisit des efforts importants au bu au
fenou bah c'est détruit
donc c'est ça la violence donc casser
une fenêtre c'est de la violence mais
par contre quand vous détruisez des vies
au quotidien ça ça quand vous demandez à
des gens de travailler 2 ans de plus à
des millions de personnes d'un coup pour
essayer de financer le trou que vous
avez créé dans les finances publiques
pour alimenter ceux qui vous ont fait
propulser au niveau de l'État ça c'est
pas de la violence ça c'est bah non mais
ça c'est ça c'est c'est du fauteuil en
velour et avec quelqu'un qui est bien
maquillé, qui est bien qui est bien
habillé et qui a tellement tous les
relais et l'appareil d'état entre ses
mains qu'il peut décider sans que
personne ne puisse y résister. Et donc
en ça, c'est pas violent. Mais en
réalité, il y a pas d'autres
difficultés, il y a pas d'autres nature
de violence. Enfin, la définition de la
violence, elle est particulièrement à
revoir. C'est d'ailleurs le la 4è de
couvre là de de ce livre. C'est c'est
faut-il croire en la violence ? La
question est mal posée. Rappelons ce que
disait Jeunet, donc un des plus grands
écrivains du 20e siècle. Il n'y a pas
plus violent que la rose qui naî.
Réfléchissez à cette idée. Il n'y a pas
plus violent que la rose qui naî la rose
qui est clos et qui rond
la structure végétale dans laquelle elle
était insérée, elle détruit quelque
chose en théorie, elle fait naître une
beauté. Donc à un moment donné, il faut
rompre avec ces ces mots valises qui
sont en fait des non signifiants qui
n'ont et comprendre comment notre
objectif c'est d'éviter que des corps
soient détruits, quel qu'il soit de
l'ennemi ou non. On veut éviter que
l'irrémédiable dans l'esprit, dans le
corps s'inscrive. Mais ça ça exige le
rapport de force.
Est-ce que vous êtes mis à la place de
ceux ?
Mais j'ai été à leur place. Je viens, je
suis eux. Enfin, vous le voyez bien.
J'ai j'ai grandi avec eux. Enfin, Gaby
de ses 11 à 23 ans, il a dû cirer les
mêmes les mêmes bans d'école puis de
sciencepo que que les miens. Je je suis
je les je enfin c'est c'est ils sont
c'est pour les sauver aussi. Moi encore
une fois, j'étais amoureux des mêmes
personnes qu'ils ont aimé. J'ai j'ai
connu j'ai connu la misère que ça génère
aussi, cette solitude existentielle,
cette incapacité à à avir. Regardez
regardez sa tête aujourd'hui. Regardez
la différence entre deux personnes qui
ont le même âge. Ça s'inscrit et
il a été premier ministre de la France
avec toutes les contraintes que ça ça
Non non. Avant oui bien sûr. Ouais.
Je pensais que c'était des palais de la
République qui leur appartenaient. Non,
arrêtez vous. Ça s'inscrit en eux. ça
s'inscrit en eux et dans leur âme et
dans leur capacité à se lié à l'autre et
ça ça génère de laideur. Ça génère de la
leader aussi pour il faut avoir ça à
l'esprit. C'est pour ça qu'on a pas
besoin de de les dévaster. C'est pour ça
qu'on je l'espère on aura pas besoin de
les guillotiner. Il suffit de leur
montrer que espérez encore heureux qu'on
pas les guillotiner.
Comment est-ce que vous voulez rompre
avec un système politique dans lequel
des personnes
on ont fait de la vidité leur leurs
règles ? Qui sont prêts à à mutiler des
gens pour rester au pouvoir ?
C'est une question que vous me posez. Je
suis pas là pour
moi je ser assez curieux de de votre
réponse.
J'ai j'ai eu ma façon de percevoir les
choses qui est très personnel. Vous
voulez pas rajouter un mot sur l'Afrique
ou est-ce qu'on continue sur la France ?
Moi moi c'est de toute façon c'est c'est
des destins liés mais par le peuple pas
par pas par les systèmes oligarchiques
tels qu'on les a connu jusqu'ici. C'estd
que moi au Sénégal je suis pas allé pour
défendre un homme politique. Je suis
allé défendre le sentiment qui générait
chez des millions de personnes et leur
adhésion et l'espoir et c pour protéger
parce que la la le politique c'est a une
fonction de
transubstation des transubstention des
des sentiments. C'est en gros ça purge.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on a cette passion
pour enfin qui est en train de décliner
? parce que voilà, on voit très bien que
ça n'a ça ne se joue plus à l'échelle à
laquelle qu'on nous présente, mais
théoriquement on a des passions
contradictoire sur le politique parce
que à travers les figures d'incarnation
successive qui nous sont présentées, on
va se sentir dans l'espoir, dans la
frustration, dans la colère et ces
figures ont pour vocation d'essayer de
gérer ça et d'amener un faire société
commun qui nous permette de nous aimer,
de continuer à vivre de façon apaisée.
et la violence qui commence à traverser
la société finit par se purger à travers
des dispositions politiques, de
changement de pouvoir, de révolution.
Et là et et tout tout programme
politique doit avoir pour fonction
d'aider les êtres à s'aimer, à être
heureux, à se lier, à se régénérer.
Comment on fait ? Comment on fait euh
comment on aide sa population quand on
est dans un contexte de stress
énergétique, de stress des matières
premières, de guerre ? Comment on fait
pour continuer à leur fournir 2200
calories par jour au minimum ? Comment
on fait pour leur assurer tout ça dans
un contexte où on a plus nos partenaires
en Afrique, on a plus nos amis en
Afrique, on a plus nos amis en Russie,
on a plus nos amis partout. Comment on
fait ? On continue à faire de la dette,
on continue à à avoir des lunettes roses
ou on a Michel Barnier ? Je pense que on
commence par euh euh enfin des
mécaniques. Euh je je pourrais vous
décliner la réponse à chaque à chaque
niveau. Je pense que le principal c'est
on cesse d'accaparer en pensant qu'en
accaparant au détriment des autres, ça
va nous permettre de nous préserver soi.
Ça marche pas comme ça. Ça c'est c'est
l'erreur du colonialisme qui,
rappelons-le, est une pensée de gauche
hein pour calmer aussi ceux qui euh à
chaque fois s'érig perd la morale par
rapport à à leur idéal et ainsi de
suite. On cesse de penser qu'en envoyant
des milliards d'armes
alimenter un conflit plutôt que
d'essayer de le régler et de détruire un
pays. Vous savez qu'il y a une tasse
force qui a été créée 3 mois après le
début de la guerre en Ukraine au CADRC
pour préparer l'obtention de contrat, le
soutien aux grandes entreprises
françaises pour obtenir des contrats
pour la reconstruction du pays. Je veux
dire
construction de la Russie
non de l'Ukraine c'est donc ils étaient
déjà partis sur l'idée de toute façon on
va gagner premier point et deuxième
point il faut qu'on soit dans la compète
un peu comme avec l'Irak vous voyez sous
avec tous les fins esprits français
notamment Kadors notamment Gérard Aro
donc qui rappelonsle l'ambassadeur de
France à Washington mais aussi en Israël
qui s'est vendu à Pegasus ambassadeur de
France
Oui à l'époque oui oui bien sûr qui est
aujourd'hui à retraite après avoir été
conseiller d'administration de Pegasus
cette entreprise créée par en en
collaboration avec le Mossad pour
espionner les les présidents français,
les autorités françaises et qui
continuent
ils ont jamais été ils ont vendu c'est
ça s'est retrouvé
parce que vous pensez que ils l'ont pas
utilisé
tant que j'ai pas les preuves en main.
Ils l'ont vendu au Marocain mais mais
eux eux ils étaient
maro c'était peut-être pas les marocains
derrière d'ailleurs.
Ouais ça aussi les bah vous aurez dû
demander ça à votre copain de la semaine
dernière. Passons
déjà attention au vocabulaire. OK
il m'a ça m'a un peu irrité mais mais je
suis désolé. Ouais. Non mais on est
irrité mais il faut être au-dessus de
tout ça.
Donc question on continue sur la France.
Comment vous voyez la France ? Comment
vous voyez le budget de la France ?
Comment vous voyez l'immigration ?
Comment vous voyez
les
OK, donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
peuple à sauver. C'estd que là on a une
guignolade qui s'appelle le le NFP, le
Nouveau Front populaire. Donc qui est en
gros la gauche Zara qui pense d'une part
avoir gagné les élections. La gauche
Zara Zara vous savez l'entreprise
espagnole d'Initex là qui qui fait
fabriquer au Bangladéhi des des
chemises, des pantalons, des souettes et
des shorts à 10 fois moins le prix qu'il
faudrait payer en France et qui
distribue ça dans le monde entier qui
fait qu'on s'habille tous pareil en
exploitant des organisation. Oui, mais
et du coup, on a une gauche des
progressistes en France qui décident que
leur programme politique consiste en
gros à augmenter notre capacité de
consommation de ce genre de produits
pour que les gens ne se rebellent pas.
C'est la seule fonction. Alors que la
crise identitaire qui nourrit l'extrême
droite est liée justement à des
mécanismes comme celui-là. Pourquoi ?
parce que évidemment ça crée une perte
d'emploi dans enfin je dire on a on a
oublié que la France était la principale
puissance textile au monde. Je dire tout
pourquoi vous pensez que tout le nord de
la France est complètement dévasté ?
C'est parce qu' en 20 ans, on a décidé
littéralement de piller ces espaces là.
Al d'un côté avec bon tous les
mécanismes qu'on a déjà décrit sur LVMH
et la dévastation d'un Pierre Bousac
améliorer la compétitivité de
l'entreprise aussi. Mais chers camarades
de gauche, c'est qui qui offre Bousac à
Bernard Arnaud ?
Qui ça ? C'est camarade de gauche.
Ah la gauche sympa la gauche non ? qui
participe à la désindustrialisation de
un/ers du territoire français pour
l'offrir à un milliardaire qui
aujourd'hui a 250 milliards en banque et
qui n'emploie que 40000 personnes dans
le monde
et qui sousraite une grande partie de sa
production. Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. C'est
très bien. Ouais. Et qui et et qui en
fait évidemment confronté à l'avarice
ultime qu'il représente a recruté des
agences de communication. Donc en gros,
pardonnez-moi mais là pour le coup comme
on parle de personnes particulier, je
peux le dire, toutes les prostituées du
petit Paris qui qui vivent de ce système
et qui et qui leur enfont cet élément de
langage extraordinaire. ont créé 10000
emplois par an
et il a répété ça pendant des années.
Il a 40000 employés en tout. Vous
m'expliquez comment vous créer 10000
emplois par an alors que ça fait 30 ans
qu'il est stable à 40000 employés et
qu'il compresse. C'est donc il y a
l'aspect économique et aussi l'aspect
créatif c'estàd qu'il fabrique c'estd
que ce qui était identitaire justement
le luxe c'est quand même quelque chose
que l'État français a créé hein. Je veux
dire combien de Français ont vécu dans
une misère noire pour alimenter toutes
les industries du textilaire et ainsi de
suite qui alimentaient à leur tour la
cour sous Versailles et et ainsi de
suite ? Donc en fait, on a des
générations de Français qui ont été
sacrifiés, ce qui a permis au final de
constituer un capital qui nous a permis
de commencer à en tirer des bénéfices en
revendant parce que voilà et puis même
une sorte de glamour à la française et
compagnie. C'est vachement intéressant,
non ? Et aujourd'hui, on le fit ça à des
entités privées, on dit "Allez
gavez-vous" et puis même quand ils
veulent quand ils veulent faire leurs
opérations financières comme avec leur
achat de Tiffanis, on mobilise le Cadors
pour les aider à faire baisser le prix
pour le pour leur permettre d'engranger
des revenus.
Faut pas s'étonner après qu'ils
habillent gratuitement Brigitte Macron.
Comment ?
Faut pas s'étonner après qu'ils
habillent gratuitement Brigitte Macron.
Donc pourquoi on parlait de le VMH ?
Donc la donc on a une gauche qui n' qui
ne propose
pour seul politique de LVMH plus de
213000 personnes dans le monde
en France. Ah et combien en France ? On
va chercher ça. Donc on a on a on a la
gauche Zara qui en gros son objectif
c'est qu'on puisse consommer un peu plus
de iPhone de euh de de produits qui sont
fabriqués à étrangers ainsi de suite et
qu'on importe
avec des terres rares africaines.
Oui. Avec et surtout l'industrie de la
mode. Non mais la la catastrophe en
terme écologique en terme de d'eau de
ressources primaires qui sont épuisées.
Quel recyclage ? Vous vous
on peut avoir du mal avec des figures
médiatiques comme Hugo Clément et
compagnie, mais au moins ils font ils
font un peu du boulot de
visisibilisation qui permet pour les
gens qui ont pas forcément un rapport
intellectuel ou politique quand même de
voir les conséquences que ça de choses
qui ont l'air banal au quotidien et
complètement. Et donc ça crée une crise
identitaire non seulement parce que en
fait on produit plus localement et donc
on a plus à côté de nous les artisans,
les gens enfin vous voyez toute cette
boucle qui fait société. Vous vous
habillez, vous allez vous avez
cordonniers. Moi, j'avais des
cordonniers en bas de chez moi en
Espagne quand quand j'ai grandi et des
et des fabricants de chaussures en cuir
et compagnie. Enfin, vous voyez, il y a
une petit écosystème. Vous habitiez dans
un endroit où vous alliez à la pêche,
enfin il y avait des pêcheurs pardon qui
qui avaient ramené le marché. Enfin, des
choses qui aujourd'hui semblent presque
exotiques. Aujourd'hui, les tris/4 des
marchés en Europe, c'est devenu, vous
savez, des centres de dégustation.
Enfin, ils ont ils ont vidé ça. C'est
vous le retrouvez dans toutes les villes
euh les principales villes européennes
de Budapest en passant par Barcelone et
euh souvent avec la même entreprise
reste les Halles de Lyon.
Et donc et par contre le marché est
préservé pour les classes les plus
bourgeoises qui eux ont droit au marché
bio et compagnie. Alors elles par contre
pour prendre soin de leurs intérêts,
elles le font. Par contre le reste du
peuple il peut aller il peut aller
serer. Et donc il y a non seulement une
crise identitaire du fait de la la
rupture de ces boucles mais aussi une
crise identitaire à cause de quoi ?
à cause du fait que si vous fabriquez
pas l'habillement, c'est un c'est un
geste fondamentalement politique et les
sociétés sont mimétiques.
C'est les effets de miroir qu'on génère
les uns sur l'autre qui vont conformer
nos comportements, qui vont nous amener
à construire en fait une société. Si
vous vous habillez sur quelque chose qui
est produit pensé et façonné à des
centaines ou des milliers de kilomètres
de chez vous et qu'en fait on vous fait
vous habiller exactement comme quelqu'un
de votre classe sociale en Amérique
latine, en Asie et compagnie, vous
n'êtes plus rien en fait et ça crée
presque une angoisse, une solitude.
C'est vous êtes obligé de vous référer à
des mimétismes mais qui n'ont plus aucun
rapport avec vos territoires, avec vos
proches et ainsi de suite. Et donc vous
vous retrouvez dans une situation où bah
vous finissez par pour vouloir vous
refermer par et donc cette crise
identitaire qui qui alimente le vote
d'extrême droite diabolisé parce que
bah parce qu'en fait il fait peur à ce
système là aussi dans cette partie-là.
C'est qu'il y a pas de réponse et je
comprends pas que la gauche n'offre pas
une réponse à ces questions là. Au lieu
de la course à l'échalotte qui consiste
à dire oui mais c'est que les questions
économiques au sens superficiel du terme
de consommation qui compte, pas de terme
d'appareil productif, pas de terme de
souveraineté économique, ainsi de suite.
Non non
est-ce que le système il est pas trop le
système mondialisé est pas trop intriqué
pour pouvoir revenir ? C'est en gros
c'est c'est donc Kemisba pour revenir à
l'Afrique parce que ça c'est c'est
Kemyba considère que il y a pas de
souverainisme panafricaniste réel qui ne
passe par une réinauguration des
traditions et la révention des
traditions locales y compris
spirituellement y compris enfin voyez il
veut restructurer entièrement la société
se défendre du modèle consumériste
mondialisé et largement occidental et ce
faisant faire qu'on sera moins dépendant
des indicateurs économiques.
parce que notre système J'arrive
j'arrive j'arrive parce que notre
système référentiel enfin parce que
chacun aura son système référentiel et
ne se jugera pas par rapport à ce qui
est fabriqué à Hollywood, ce qui est
fabriqué à la télévision, enfin voyez
dans sur réseaux sociaux et ainsi de
suite. Ousman son c a une théorie
beaucoup plus sociale déémocrate qui
consiste à dire on essaie de sauver à
court terme notre population en la
faisant s'intégrer au ventre mou de la
société mondialisée. En gros, moi je
pense que en France, on a la possibilité
d'être en rupture parce qu'on a une
capacité industrielle, technique,
intellectuelle encore pour pas longtemps
qui nous permet d'avoir ces armes. Et je
me bats pour provoquer cette révolution
politique et pour moi cette révolution
politique n'interviendra que par une
rupture qui soit radicale avec
l'existant à la fois par rapport à
l'édifice de l'Union européenne, à la
fois par rapport à évidemment des
imbrications qu'on a avec le système
états-unien pour refonder une
souveraineté qui soit complète.
Il va y avoir quelques trou d'air
évidemment. Mais évidemment, mais à un
moment donné, on va avoir vous êtes une
société oùel vous avez vu les
Quel type de trou d' on va avoir ?
Attendez juste, je vais répondre mais
juste avant ça la mais immense
technologique, on s'effondre des
processeurs en France. Je pense queon
doit éventuellement peut-être qu'on a la
capacité pour
mais je pense que c'est même pas le cas.
J'allais dire du
au niveau au niveau de de 20
cm, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
On est à trois, on on est à 3 nanomè là.
Enfin et on Non, mais j'allais dire 20
nanomè. Enfin, voyez, je suis quand même
plus en je suis même pas sûr de que ce
soit vrai. Et euh bon, pardon, c'est
peut-être un peu technique, mais on
reviendra, on reviendra à ce niveau-là.
Là, je parle des applications civiles.
Enfin, mais avec
là, vous m'avez déconcentré pour la
première fois. On était sur Oui, parce
que vous parliez des trous d'air et
j'allais vous répondre. Il y en a plein
et je les ai justement tout mon travail
est de est de et de et de répérage. Mais
avant ça, voilà c'est ça, avant ça, je
voulais quand même vous dire, vous avez
vu euh le taux de dépression, de suicide
et de rapport sexuel, c'est quand même
consommation de neurolépique
d'antidépresseur chez les jeunes.
Ah non, j'ai pas eu.
Ça a explosé. Ça a explosé et à une
vitesse folle, c'estd en moins de 10
ans. Voilà,
c'est que en gros ça a un peu commencé
avant et là on a atteint des une société
qui n'arrive plus à faire que les jeunes
s'aiment, que les jeunes désirent. C'est
c'est c'est des jeunes qui sont c'est
toute une génération qui est prise par
l'angoisse
et des angoisses en plus qui sont à
chaque fois projectives. C'estàd que on
est passé d'une sorte de de panique
morale absol enfin un truc vachement
intéressant. Vous avez vu en France
qu'il y a eu Vous vous souvenez de il y
a eu les punaises de lit intéressant non
? De façon c'est apparu et ça a disparu.
Oua à chaque fois. Oui. Mais vous vous
souvenez avant les seringues ?
Les seringues
vous souvenez pas de ça ? Il y a eu 1000
1000 dépôts de plainte
euh du fait
pour les gens qui se faisaient piquer
dans les concerts.
Dans les concerts. Vous savez combien de
procédures judiciaire ont abouti ? Zéro.
Ça n'existait pas. Et vous savez ce
qu'on a découvert ?
Que au milieu du 19e siècle, il y avait
déjà eu une panique morale similaire. Et
donc ça c'est des symptômes d'une
société qui devient phobique et qui en
fait que des gens s'autoconvainquent
qu'ils sont victimes de quelque chose et
qui rentrent dans des rapports
d'autodestruction. notamment favorisé
par la position victimaire qui en fait
est devenue gagner ça.
Il y a des gens qui se sont fait piquer
dans les concerts hein.
Non quand une Non, c'est ça qui est
incroyable. Non, ça n'est pas arrivé, ça
n'existait pas. Sauf que par mimétisme,
ils ont fini par s'autoconvaincre.
sincèrement, il y en a quelques-uns qui
qui probablement vous les surf sur mais
la plupart pensaient être sincèrement
victime de ce phénomène. Vous rendez
compte la psyché humaine est-ce que ça
dit sur la relativité de et ça c'est
alimenté aussi par une quelque chose qui
arrive souvent dans des sociétés qui
sont en cours d'effondrement ou en tout
cas transition forte, c'est la
valorisation de la de la position
victimaire. C'est la victime devient
une figure valorisée au sein de la
société. Donc devenir victime c'est pres
ça peut devenir pour certains objectif
pour sortir de les taux psychique
économique ainsiqu sont sortis et se
revendiqu sont pas qui ne se sont pas
autant convaincus d'être des victimes.
Il y en a plein des victimes.
Non mais dans tout domaine il y a des
victimes en général mais en l'occurrence
il y a des phénomènes qui sont étudiants
en psychologique qui s'appellent les
paniques morales et qui vous amènent à
vous inventer en fait des faits
traumatiques ou non et ainsi de suite
qui vous serai arrivé et qui vous
redonnent un statut au sein de la
société. voyez qui vous permettent en
fait de quelque part de retrouver un
petit peu de et ça c'est des choses qui
sont en général générées par quoi ? Par
la solitude, par la détresse, par le
sentiment d'échec, par l'humiliation. On
est quand même le pays maître. Tout
notre système en France repose sur
l'humiliation. Les grandes écoles, le
bac avant ça, le système scolaire et
ainsi de suite. C'est un système
d'écrasement. C'est comme ça qu'on
maintient l'ordre. C'est comme ça que la
République est née et qu'elle a écrasé,
qu'elle a réussi à unifier ce territoire
là. C'est en écrasant celui qui parlait
avec un accent. C'est en écrasant les
patois. C'est en écrasant les langues
les langues régionales, en écrasant leur
culture, en unifiant avec une violence
extraordinaire hein, c'est une culture.
Et aujourd'hui, on est en train de
s'aborder cette culture. Tant qu'avoir
fait des sacrifices, autant essayer de
la préserver, de la protéger, non ? De
la nourrir dans d' dans faire peut-être
un vecteur positif de régénération de
quelque chose. Ces sortes de conversion
comme ça qui nous permettent à un moment
donné de rayonner. Et bien non, là
maintenant, on est en train de la de la
vendre en fait. Et quand vous voyez
l'affissement du niveau de nos élites,
on critique beaucoup les politiciens.
Vous avez vu les concours les concours
de Normal Sup c'est c'est
il y a 100 étudiants qui sont pris
chaque année, 100 élèves. Ils sont
sélectionnés sur une base de 15000 qui
ont réussi à rentrer dans des hippoca,
donc dans des prépas parmi les plus
sélectifs du c'est non seulement les
sujets sont d'une médiocrité crass mais
il y a il y a plus
Oui mais pour moi des exemples de sujets
je préfère pas vous le dire parce que
c'est trucs de littérature un peu enfin
c'est c'est des théories de jeunette
enfin c'est des choses qui qui sont pas
c'est comme si là je vous pas enfin un
un polytechnicien commence à vous
expliquer le sujet de enfin ça enfin
voyez c'est c'est des c'est des moyens
d'entrées qui sont pas forcément
tangibles en fait. Mais mais mais juste
c'est parce que c'est pas que le
problème c'est que moi j'ai des gamins,
moi j'ai pris des stagiaires, normal à
un moment il s'est retrouvé à quatre au
sein au sein au sein de mon cabinet.
Donc il papotait entre eux je sais pas
quoi et à un moment il y en a un qui
m'ont fini par avouer mais on n pas lu
les bouquins qui étaient censés préparer
à ce concours-là. On on a on a en fait
pourquoi ? Parce que l'exigence s'est
effondrée chez les aînés.
On est passé d'une d'une école qui
formait les esprits les plus brillants
de la planète, les plus grands
philosophes de Sartrafou en passant je
sais pas quoi à des gens qui lit
aujourd'hui un auteur français, un
philosophe français à l'étranger.
C'est fini.
On a on a Thomas Piquetti en économie
aux États-Unis.
On a encore les systèmes de légitimation
mutuelle des élites en gros
transatlantique. C'est pour ça que je
suis allé à Yel. fait c'est c'est des
liens entre entre institutions qui
permettent de renforcer mutuellement
leur pouvoir et leur légitimité. Ça
existe encore mais c'est en train d'être
fini. De toute façon, les États-Unis
basculent sur le Pacifique aujourd'hui.
Comment vous analysez
Michel Barnier
sa mise en place et comment vous
Attendez, attendez. Est-ce que vous
voulez que que ce Est-ce que vous voulez
que cet entretien et gen une durée de
vie de plus de 3 mois ou parce que dans
3 mois ou dans 6 mois ou dans un an
qu'importe qui sera qui est Michel
Barnier enfin je veux dire non mais vous
voyez enfin on peut on peut parler de
l'épiphénomène du symptôme de mais mais
je pense mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que même aujourd'hui
vous êtes en train de dire que nos deux
précédents entretiens sont toujours
ils ont pas pris une r c'est intéressant
parce que notre entretien qui a fait 5
millions de vues à la fin il l'a fait
par palier il a pas fait 5 millions de
vues en mois non
il a fait 2 millions de vues en un mois
ouais mais voyez c'est que il y a eu en
fait l'actualité, j'ai j'ai annoncé dans
crépuscule Gabriatal, c'était personne à
l'époque qui connaissait Gabriatal.
C'est quand quand vous réussissez à
comprendre comment structurellement le
système se reproduit,
vous arrivez à vous inscrire dans le
temps long parce qu'en fait c'est pas
c'est c'est c'est vous donnez les clés
de compréhension. Vous faites pas du
journalisme à scandale à la Média Part
pour dégommer un mec contre l'autre.
Vous faites pas de règlement de compte.
Vous essayez de donner les éléments de
pas du journaliste. Ils font d'analyse
au Médiia part. C'est intéressant. Moi
j'ai jamais vu euh
je Ils sont connus pour leur qualité de
leur plume. Non, ils font du ils font
qu'ils ont fait avec Sarkozi. C'est
quand même
Ouais. Ouais. C'est de la c'est de la
Prensa Maria, on dit en Espagne. C'est
c'est en gros on a besoin de de
renouveler le nombre d'amonnés annuel en
faisant un scandale et en dégommant
quelqu'un. On demande à X de nous
balancer Y et puis euh on avance comme
ça. Et puis après évidemment impriation
très forte avec le système judiciaire
qui permet de faire perdurer les
affaires et ainsi de suite.
Bon
revenons, revenons à
d'ailleurs mais c'est pas c'est pas ma
critique d'ailleurs. C'est le Mond
Diplot qui a qui avait une critique
assez structurelle sur ce genre de
journalisme en fait quoi. Qui qui à
aucun moment essaie de prévenir les
effets de système et après ils ont leur
directrice générale.
Bon allez, on va pas en parler mais on a
j'ai déjà tweeté à ce sujet sur les
liens avec la Macronie et Al et tout ça.
C'est c'est très intéressant. C'est très
intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est c'est
Barnier. Michel Barnier.
Oui. Par parlons des épus phénomènes
plutôt que des effets de structure. Vous
avez raison.
Ah ça c'est vilain ça.
Donc le premier ministre de la France,
comment vous analysez déjà la démarche
de Macron par rapport au vote précédent
? Comment ça se fait qu'on a Michel
Barnier ? Parce que c'est le premier
ministre qui fait consensus. Parce que
quoi ? Parce queils ont fait des
alliances avec le Rassembl Rassemblement
national. Comment ça se passe ? Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a un mortvivant comme
premier ministre ? Il est pas mort.
Non, il a 73 ans.
Et alors, on connait des personnes de 73
ans qui sont encore très vert.
Bah lui aussi hein.
Il est très vert.
Ouais. Ou
est-ce que Est-ce que j'en ai quelque
chose à faire honnêtement ?
Est-ce que est-ce que le est-ce que le
français qui nous écoute, on a quelque
chose à faire ?
Quand quand je dis mort vivant, c'est
pas du tout une attaque sur l'âge de
Michel. Enfin, il est plus vivant que
Gabriel Atal.
Ça se voit d'ailleurs. Vous avez vu
comment il a mouché à la passation de
pouvoir ? Non non, il y a
c'était c'était d'ailleurs très déplacé
de bien sûr. Très déplacé. Ouais. Ce qui
était déplacé c'était de donner des
leçons à quelqu'un qui depuis 50 ans,
quoi qu'on en pense a eu des fonctions
au sein d'un appareil étatique. Elle est
là quelque part quand même tenté de le
servir avec
euh lorsqu'on est un petit arrivéiste
qui est là par le fait du prince.
Je suis resté très modeste par rapport à
la réalité des des ressorts de ce de ce
parcours.
Il faut être auudess de ça.
Mais oui, mais c'est pour c'est vous qui
m'essayer de m'en faire parler, c'est
incroyable.
Macron.
Ouais,
la France.
Un autre croqu Ouais, on en est où ?
C'est bientôt fini là. On va pas
on essaie de se projeter sur l'après là.
Non, quand même.
On est tranquille, on a le temps.
Non mais non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est on a j'ai passé 7 ans là à essayer
de enfin il y a quoi ? Il y a je vous ai
ramené
ça là. Vous voyez, ils sont un peu dans
le désordre.
C'est 7 ans de production intellectuelle
depuis la dernière fois qu'on s'est
rencontré. Tout ça est paru. La moitié
sont pour analyser euh le
fonctionnement. Oui, je vous les
signerai euh pour analyser. Et donc je
vais vous donner un exemple contre
Macron juillet 2017
au moment de notre première invitation.
4e de coup. Allez, un peu de lecture.
Le macronisme est une nouvelle variante
du fascisme. On m'est tombé dessus à
l'époque et il nous faudra avoir la plus
grande attention à la façon de
débrancher ces êtres de nos institutions
au moment du changement démocratique
nécessaire qu'il qu'ils chercheront
compulsivement à éviter. Juillet 2017,
j'annonce ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment. C'est y compris
avec une élection qu'ils ont perdu, je
répète,
il faudra avoir la plus grande attention
à la façon de débrancher ces aides de
nos institutions au moment du changement
démocratique nécessaire qu'ils
chercheront compulsivement à éviter.
C'est pas cela à qu'on insiste depuis.
Donc
next next, on peut on peut s'en faire de
trois là dans le chronologique.
Chronologiquement, il y a d'abord. Ça
c'est fondamental parce que c'est un
œuvre de c'est un ouvrage contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait penser l'antouverain
de de théorisation politique. On fait
c'est que c'est en gros j'essaie de
réfléchir la notion de surveillance de
d'antisouveraineté, c'est-à-dire comment
quelqu'un survit en n'appartenant pas ou
ne servant pas un appareil de pouvoir.
C'est c'était censé être un séminaire de
philo à l'en donc c'est vraiment genre
vraiment à ride quoi. Je c'est
comment vous vous voyez le fait que
Julian Assange soit reparti en Australie
moins soit sorti de sa prison quartier
de sécurité après 11 ans de de Ouais. de
des tensions successives diverses, que
soit à l'ambassade équateur ou après
dans une prison antiterroriste à Belle
Marche, je pense qu'il considérait qu'il
l'avait suffisamment brisé. premier
point deuxème point il était devenu
exactement vous savez que les États-Unis
ont ont soutenu la transition
démocratique au Sénégal pour la même
raison que ils ont fini par lâcher à
Sange parce que ça devenait un enjeu
électoral c'estàd qu'en gros les vagues
migratoires étaient devenues tellement
intenses entre le Sénégal et les
États-Unis doublé d'un petit problème
technique qu'ils avaient pas réglé à
temps qui consiste à faire que quand
vous êtes un exilé qui arrive à New York
vous êtes obligé d'avoir un un logement
et c'est en train de coûter des sommes
telles que c'était devenu une arme
électorale des républicains contre des
démocrates. C'est toujours le cas.
Et donc les démocrates sont dit "OK, bon
les Français déjà on les a pas suivi sur
Niger parce que toc toc là ils sont en
train de laisser les gens se faire
massacrer et et on est en train de se
retrouver avec ce problème électoral. On
va prendre le lead. Faut savoir que
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et centrale a très
longtemps été la chasse gardée de la
France dans le cadre d'un accord de
coopération avec les États-Unis. C'est
en gros vous nous tenez les communistes
en dehors de ce système de enfin les
communistes en dehors de cette région du
monde et on vous laisse faire ce que
vous voulez. C'était la cortaite qui a
été mise en place. euh après la seconde
guerre mondiale. Et donc on se retrouve
dans une situation où il en gros ils
imposent à la France de lâcher le
dictateur en herbe qu'ils étaient en
train de soutenir. C'est ça ce qui s'est
passé. Et donc à Sange, c'est pareil.
Est-ce que Biden parce qu'on est arrivé
au moment où il allait être extradé et
en gros les anglais leur disaient parce
qu'il était en Angleterre Julien disait
"Oh les cocos là maintenant il faut
qu'on décide. Ça fait 3 ans qu'il est en
détention provisoire dans l'attente de
son extradition. Il va falloir trancher
là. On le garde ou enfin on libère ou on
vous l'envoie." et ça risquait d'arriver
avant les élections de novembre.
Est-ce que Biden à l'époque voulait un
procès de Julien Nassange en pleine
période préélectorale avec tout le
toute la com qu'aurait fait Trum dessus
?
Donc on se débarrasse du problème. Mais
si vous pensez enfin tout est dynamique
de pouvoir, vous pensez vraiment qu'il y
a tout d'un coup les amerloges qui sont
dit "Ah bon en fait la liberté
d'expression c'est important. En fait,
on est en train de se rendre compte que
il a il a mis en danger personne en en
exposant en disant la vérité sur nos
opérations en Irak, en Afghanistan. Ah
non, mais en fait
en fait on est du côté du bien.
Non.
Donc le mec avait passé 11 ans dans il
pensait l'avoir détruit. Ils sont dit on
l'envoit en Australie qui reste quand
même une dépendance de l'empire. Donc il
va pas faire le malin, il va pas
recommencer parce queil sait très bien
ce qui va lui arriver cette fois-ci.
recommence. Et maintenant, on a un homme
qui déjà est en train de se reconstruire
depuis quelques mois et qui ensuite va
devoir faire un choix un choix lourd
parce que lui, contrairement à moi, a
des enfants. Et donc ce choix, c'est
est-ce que je vais au bout de ma mission
ou est-ce que je décide tout simplement
que j'ai assez donné à l'humanité, je me
suis assez sacrifié et je m'en tiens là.
Et quoi qu'il arrive, il sera admirable
et et respectable pour tout ce qu'il
nous a offert. Mais euh c'est ça les
conséquences que
vous subissez lorsque vous vous
retrouvez dans une situation comme
celle-ci. Dans dans les autres bouquins
un intéressant,
donc il y avait crépuscule, ça fait une
mission dessus.
OK.
Un mois avant mon compromate. Tiens
tiens hein. Ou j'annonce d'ailleurs he
parce qu'on m'avait prévenu que ça
allait venir. Donc là avec un joli plan
de Paris qu'on qu'on a remis là dans la
guillotine sur non. Comment est-ce qu'il
faudrait refonder le Paris de la Prê en
gros ? Enfin, comment est-ce qu'il
faudrait rouvrir au peuple
euh la capitale au peuple ? Un petit
manuel insurrectionnel, coup d'état. En
gros, en expliquant que si on veut
vraiment changer les choses dans ce
pays, bah il faut peut-être réfléchir à
un gilet jaune qui cette fois soit
suffisamment armé,
pas donner de mauvaises idées
intellectuellement. Intellectuellement
pour arriver d'état en France, il y a
des élections.
La révolution est un coup d'état qui
enfin la révolution c'est une révolte
qui a débouché sur un coup d'état hein.
Faut arrêter. C'est un moment donné où
vous prenez les institutions parce que
sinon sinon quoi ? Enfin sinon vous
jeune vous faites massacrer.
13 pillard. Alors ça c'est très joli
portrait de d'une petite galerie des
gens des gens qui pourrissent la vie des
des français au quotidien. C'est
vraiment
le gros bouquin noir là c'est
il y a pas méia part mais il pourrait y
être. Euh
ça c'était gratuit pour rien.
Ça c'est l ça c'est juste un une
explication de parce que enfin du
parcours enfin pour comprendre ce qu'il
en est comment comment on arrive à une
situation comme celle-ci. Je suis
désolé, j'ai l'impression d'être au
marché, c'est rigolo. Discours à
Polytechnique parce que les
Polytechniciens m'avaient m'avaient
invité mais ils sont rendus compte que
les gilets jaunes allaient venir et du
coup ils ont fermé au public. C'estàd
qu'il y avait que des C'est incroyable
ça non ? Donc je commence en gros je
réexplique que il était filmé mais que
la République ne vous appartient pas.
J'essaie d'expliquer aux pays
techniciens que
bah leur devenir actuel entre Bernard
Arnaud, Patrick Draille et compagnie
enfin il ferait mieux de se rapprocher
du peuple plutôt que de penser que leur
devenir est est dans ces cheminsl de P.
Ça vous a rapporté tous ces bouquins ?
Alors ils sont tous en libre accès par
ailleurs. Ça c'est un important.
D'ailleurs, crépuscule était avant même.
C'est pour ça aussi que j'ai monre parce
que si vous allez, il y a un certain
nombre, enfin vous tapez le titre du
truc et vous trouvez sans aucune
difficulté parce que euh
ces gens-là, je parle des gilets jaunes
mais aussi de ceux qui derrière ont
acheté crépuscule alors qu'il était en
PDF, ils m'ont sauvé parce que la seule
façon de survivre sans se compromettre,
c'est d'avoir un lien direct ou indirect
avec avec les gens que vous aidez. Et en
l'occurrence,
on en profite, soutenez-nous sur Tipi,
on a besoin de vous. notre indépendance
et ben les Français eux m'ont sauvé
grâce au enfin par l'intermédiaire des
éditeurs qui récoltent grosse partie de
la somme mais parce que il faut savoir
qu'un auteur en France c'est entre 8 et
14 % de droits d'auteur par livre. Ça
c'est important que les gens le sachent.
C'estd que c'est un c'est un scandale
c'est c'est inden que aujourd'hui être
écrivain ou intellectuel et cetera est
impossible
en soi. Il faut appartenir à une
université ou il faut être intégré un
système de pouvoir c'est quasiment
impossible. ou alors miracle comme comme
ce qui m'est arrivé, c'est-à-dire vous
êtes une des 10 euh meilleures ventes de
l'année et ça vous donne pas immense
mais et là lycée vous me posez la
question lycée sur sur ces 5 ans, j'ai
dû toucher euh 200000 €.
Vous avez payé tous vos impôts ?
Non seulement j'ai payé trop d'impôts,
mais vol enfinance pour oui que en
France et surtout pourquoi
trop d'impôts ?
Mais parce que parce que j'étais assez
content. Enfin, c'était assez euh enfin
genre c'est c'est
moi j'étais tellement appuyé et aidé par
euh par la France là pour le coup enfin
en tant qu'entité, c'est en tant enfin
j'ai eu les meilleures écoles enfin les
meilleures formations. Enfin en gros, on
m'a on m'a enf c'était l'idée de se dire
[__] je peux contribuer euh enfin je
peux payer un impôt sur le revenu quoi.
Enfin, voyez, après bon, j'ai découvert
ce que c'était les 2035, tous les enfers
administratifs quand vous créez votre
activité et à quel point c'est vraiment
enfin l'État une peut-être une mafia
comme les autres. Mais enfin, voyez,
mais il y a eu ce moment où genre j'ai
pu sans sans sans me retrouver en
difficulté économique me dire bah j'ai
peut-être aidé certes à payer le salaire
de Gabriel Atal et de Emmanuel Macron,
mais aussi peut-être à un petit morceau
de route et un quoi les infirmières, les
pompiers. Voilà, c'est ça que un ma
petite mesure, enfin voyez, un petit euh
au-delà des trucs invisibles de la TVA
et compagnie. Donc je me souviens un peu
un peu d'avoir été content de de d'avoir
payé cash parce que enfin enfin bref,
enfin c'était c'était pas lycée quoi.
C'était genre d'un coup euh bon bref et
de quoi on parlait ? Donc et ça ça m'a
perd ça ça m'a permis d'aider énormément
de gens. Ça a été un miracle parce qu'en
fait ça m'a permis de probono d'aider
énormément de gilets jaunes, des gens
comme Kemy Seba, ce qui me permet de
garder mon indépendance. Enfin, du coup,
ça me permet de pas avoir de porosité à
l'égard. Bon, maintenant, il est plus
financé du tout par eux, ni de la la
Russie, ni de personne. Enfin, voyez, le
convoi des libertés et cetera, c'est des
gens qui pour qui l'accès à la justice,
c'est impossible. Moi, je me suis
retrouvé quand même avec des citoyens
français dont certains polaccidentés du
travail, enfin au RSA et compagnie ou ou
avec la H euh à se prendre des procès
pénaux initiés par Gérald Darmanin, euh
par Brigitte Emmanuel Macron qui eux
déposant plainte contre un citoyen
français par parce qu'il a fait un post
Facebook parce que il allait se baigner
devant le fort de Brégançon avec un
homar en chantant une chanson parodique
sur Brigitte Emmanuel et ces gens-là ont
le droit aussi à leur vie privée. C'est
quoi le fort de Branson ? La vie privée
genre un gilet jaune qui se qui se qui
se bagne avec un homar gonflable
pour pour ironiser sur arrêtez
franchement non franchement et et il se
retrouve à il se serait fait écraser
s'il avait pas eu un avocat.
l'humiliation, la peine. Enfin, vous
voyez, c'est donc ça m'a il y a eu ça et
après il y a eu la Liga comme on avait
défendé. Je sais pas ça vous intér ça
vous intéresse pas le foot ? Non, mais
il y a un truc marrant avec le foot. Il
y a
préfère le rugby
préférer le rugby. Mais non, mais ça ça
touche parce que c'est sport business en
fait. Le euh c'est bien c'est ma petite
il y a le plus important qui arrive dans
entre moi c'est un roman d'amour qui
raconte en fait parce que
avec ou sans
avec amour ou sans non mais sur parce
que tout
tout ce que je vous raconte en ce qui
est le plus important quand même c'est
notre rapport à l'autre enfin voyez
enfin tout ça c'est des struct des
analyses de structures qui affectent le
rapport à l'autre mais ce qui compte
c'est c'est le face- à faceace et à un
moment donné c'est l'amitié c'est la
capacité aimer donc à un moment donné il
faut revenir à ça sinon vous devenez
C'est comme eux. Enfin, voyez, vous vous
perdez dans des et vous êtes plus Audi,
vous servez plus à rien en fait. Enfin,
vous vous alimentez une machine qui qui
s'arrête jamais. Et le foot, c'était un
peu pareil. C'est j'avais un assistant,
un étudiant de SP qui était en saisure
qui qui était sociaux du Barça mais en
fou de foot mais complètement. Et c'est
au moment où le PSG passionné
fou mais vraiment le PSG rachète enfin
achète Messi au Barça et il m'appelle en
me disant je boss, je peux pas je peux
pas venir au boulot aujourd'hui, je suis
trop déprimé. Ce qui est ce qui est
génial parce que ça ça montre à quel
point là en en parlant de passion et de
enfin comment ça peut
Ouais, il y a quelque chose d'incroyable
non ? Dans l'identification face à
J'ai eu la chance, anecdote personnelle,
j'ai eu la chance de connaître un
entraîneur de gardien de but José
Suarez.
Ouais. et il m'a
mis les yeux en face des trous sur plein
plein de choses et il est mort et c'est
une grande perte je pense.
Donc on lui rend hommage
comment on lui rend hommage ce soirée
quelqu'un de très très bien.
Bon bref donc ce gamin me dit je peux
pas aller au boulot je suis trop déprimé
je sais pas quoi. Non parce que Messi
c'est donc c'est pas seulement le
meilleur joueur de l'histoire mais c'est
un gamin qui était là depuis 13 ans au
Barça. Et le Barça, c'est pas un club,
c'était pas un club comme les autres, ça
l' devenu malheureusement, mais c un
club qui était associatif, c'est qui
appartenait à ses supporters. Ça c'est
vous voyez donc vous avez un une bulle
du fotusiness avec des actionnaires je
sais pas quoi, des oligarques qui
l'utilisent pour pour se blanchir
l'image et et leur et leur fond ou et de
plus en plus des puissances souveraines
type Qatar, Arabie, Saoudite et cetera.
Vous aviez ce système assez spécifique à
l'Espagne a quelques le le plus beau
encore aujourd'hui, c'est l'Athletique
de Bilbao euh qui n'a que des joueurs
basque, qui appartient à ses supporters
et qui enfin voyez qui essaie de tenir
sur cette ligne qui est complètement
finie depuis l'arrêt Bossman de 96.
Bref, on rev, il veut pas faire la même
chose avec le club qui vient de racheter
là.
Avec quand c'est ça ? Mais je vous par
des map parce que justement c'est c'est
l'un amené à l'autre. Et donc il me dit
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup parlé avec
Romain Molina là que et qui on s'est
croisé euh parce qu'il habite à côté de
mon village natal maintenant. il
s'installé un peu, il a raison
d'ailleurs, il s'éloignait des des
centres de pouvoir et donc on se
retrouve à à
je dis bah écoute donc le Barça voilà
club sans publicité pendant très
longtemps, club qui après décide non
seulement de pas avoir de publicité mais
de mettre un petit logo de l'UNICEF pour
reverser de l'argent. Bon bref, tout ce
qu'on peut tout ce qu'on peut avec que
des joueurs du coin du coin et compagnie
donc et avec un très beau très belle
école de foot enfin un jeu esthétique en
plus. Enfin, il y avait tout pour et
donc il y a Messi qui est là depuis les
14 ans et qui devient le plus grand
joueur de de l'histoire alors que c'est
un argentin qui bon bref et ce mec là
tout d'un coup à 33 ans à cause des
contraintes du foot business euh que le
Barça peut plus payer et qui part au
Qatar enfin au PSG racheté par le Qatar
grâce à de SarkoZi pour faire des
opérations d'influence dans la
perspective d'organisation Coupe du
monde et cetera et donc des millions de
personnes qui ont le cœur brisé qui se
disent bah c'est la fin d'une air et moi
je lui dis bah écoute il y a une
distorsion de concurrence je connais
bien le droit européen on On peut
monter, on peut essayer de faire un
recours pour empêcher un référé quoi,
pour empêcher le et en droit, on raison,
on lance le truc, il est sociau, c'est
qu' il est propriétaire d'une petite
part du Barça puisqu'il appartient à ses
super. On se dit, on va on va empêcher
le transfert de Messi au PSG. Donc on
fait presque ça enfin c'est pas pour
rigoler mais enfin pour le côté
romantique n on le fait justement ça
nous prend un temps fou parce que c'est
hyper complexe c'est des règles
européennes n ça fait le tour du monde
tout le monde mais vraiment j'ai fait
des entretiens pour les médias
équatoriens. J'ai un ami avocat qui
travaille dans le Kurdistan qui m'a dit
mais tu sais que quand j'aurais dit que
je te connaissais c'était fou parce que
en fait il faisait des millions de
personnes dans le monde entier qui
étaient brisé parce que parce qu'ils
étaient en train de voir. Ça peut
paraître purile mais ça l'it pas du
tout. Évidemment, la justice française
enfin trouve 1000 façons de contourner
le problème réel qui est dont on
pourrait parler. Mais derrière
euh qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Bah la Liga
se dit tiens, ils sont intéressants ces
gars, ils ont trouvé un truc
juridiquement. Et donc au lieu d'aller
chercher les cabinets d'avocats genre
avec 1500 avocats chacun accompagné un,
il nous disent ben on veut vous confier
le dossier Mbappé
et tous les systèmes de corruption qui
font qu'il reste au PSG. Et donc là
pareil 20000 € par mois pendant pendant
6 mois.
en toute transparence assumé et ça me
permet derrière d'aider gens à nouveau
pendant 2 3 ans.
Oui oui bien sûr. toutes les charges et
compagnies, c'est enfin mais
cisation
mais comme on vit avec avec
enfin il faut il faut apprendre à vivre
de façon modulaire, faut apprendre à à à
vivre dans l'abondance et après de à
renoncer à et on est j'étais dans cette
disposition là et voilà donc ça a
relancé un cycle après crépuscule donc
qui m'avait permis pendant x années de
voilà de de de continuer à tenir parce
que sinon sans avoir à me à me vendre en
fait et en refusant tous les dossiers où
je me sentais pas à l'aise pour une
raison ou une autre avec et la Ligue
Aage, je me sentais à l'aise, je
trouvais ça en fait enfin ça touche à
des enjeux tellement fondamentaux sur la
corruption, sur le politique et sur la
des intervention de Macron pour forcer
Mbappé à rester au PSG. Enfin, on est
dans des enf on dirait qu'on est sous
mobutou quoi. C'est des c'est des choses
complètement complètement folles quoi.
Donc voilà. Et après Anouna et après ça
c'est le plus important, personne
connaît parole c'est des aismes parce
que je reste un gros bourge d'intello.
Enfin vous voyez enfin genre mon
ambition c'est de créer de la beauté
avec l'écriture et euh que
tu sois bourge. Oui mais rentello ça ça
m'étonnerait bien.
Ah bah essayez de lire ça, vous allez
voir ça va vous plaire hein. C'est c'est
de la c'est presque de la poésie. Mais
le miracle de toute cette phase aussi,
c'est que ça m'a donné ça. Ce livre, il
est impubliable aujourd'hui.
Aujourd'hui, on il y a des contraintes
économique. Il y a plus d'écosystème
intellectuel en France. Il y a plus de
valorisation des choses belles en fait
quand on est sur du prête à consommer,
ainsi de suite. Et de part le succès
éditorial qui est pas de mon fait, qui
est du fait de ceux qui ont soutenu ce
livre, ça m'a donné cette marge de
manœuvre soit pour faire des ouvrages de
théories philosophiques hyper
exigeantes, soit des trucs un peu de
poésie. Et au milieu une petite critique
en règle de Hanouna. Euh question
internet, comment vous faites pour vous
informer ? tout, il faut tout lire et
surtout euh il faut il faut il faut en
fait il faut croiser derrière mais il
faut lire en gros aujourd'hui on a on a
une chance miraculeuse c'est qu'on a on
a la source
secondaire merde on a la source primaire
j'ai versé l'eau.
J'avais dit un vocabulaire soutenu.
Pardonnez-moi. On a
on a d'un côté tous les médias bourgeois
institutionnels qui font et défont
l'opinion depuis à peu près un
demi-siècle au moins qui sont qui ont
une vision assez homogène du monde.
C'estàd que du monde au New York Times
en passant par pays et compagnie c'est à
peu près le même regard porter sur c'est
des gens qui ont adoré Macron en gros
quoi. Qui comprennent pas pourquoi on le
déteste. Et à côté, vous avez un accès
non filtré, enfin désormais filtré par
les algorithmes malheureusement, mais à
des sources primaires, à des sources
primaires qui sont de plus en plus
manipulé pour justement enfin à la fois
par des effets de censure politique
explicites, mais aussi tout simplement
par le fait que c'est des plateformes
qui dépendent de la consommation enfin
de publicité et donc du temps que vous
avez passé sur la plateforme et donc
dans la spectac spectacularisation du
réal et ainsi de suite. Et moi, comme
j'ai appartenu à des instances
universitaires qui sont assez
puissantes, j'ai encore accès à des
comptes génériques en fait qui
permettent de tout lire. Ça, j'ai accès
à toute la presse euh en gros euh
institutionnelle, mondiale et euh et en
fait, je contrebalance avec donc en gros
tous les relais du pouvoir d'un côté et
de l'autre
les relais de terrain,
la masse et ensuite évidemment une
confrontation réelle, d'où euh le
travail avec les gilets jaunes sur le
terrain. Donc ce qui est génial comme
avocat, vous quand c'est rien être
avocat. Et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'ils ont des égos délirants parce que
ils ils se ils se confondent avec leurs
clients. C'est leurs clients qui ont des
difficultés. C'est leurs clients qui
sont mises en danger. C'est qui prennent
des risques ou qui sont qui sont des
salots, mais c'est eux qui dans les
dîner en ville peuvent peuvent les
raconter. Et donc très donc vous prenez
aucun risque dans 99 % des cas mais vous
récoltez tout euh tout le produit dérivé
en gros de de ce qui est arrivé à ce que
vous défendez. Par contre, c'est
miraculeux de par les portes que ça
ouvre pour découvrir des réalités
différentes des vôtres. Moi, ce que j'ai
pu voir du monde grâce à cette fonction
et
et et souvent vous êtes et vous êtes
utile que si vous enfin pour moi aller
en prison pour un client c'est naturel.
Voyez, c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
j'essaie de les choisir parce que mais
mais dès le moment que je choisis de
travailler pour défendre quelqu'un, il y
a pas de limite.
Question internet. Ukraine, Gaza,
Sénégal, Yémen, le droit international
a-t-il vraiment un sens ?
Donc droit instrument du politique, donc
résultante de rapport de force. Ça c'est
le premier point. Euh j'étais au Yémen.
Euh
je pense qu'il faudrait faire toute une
émission sur sur cette question.
Il manque la page 122 et 123 dans le PDF
qui PDF mis en ligne gratuitement coup
d'état par Juan. Est-ce que Juan peut
les mettre ?
C'est bizarre ça.
122 123.
Donc pour revenir au bien venu avec
pour pour revenir le droit international
a-t-il vraiment un sens ?
Est-ce que le droit international c'est
pas aussi une façon de faire la leçon
à d'autres pays qui ne font pas partie
de la communauté internationale
c'est de légitimer la la domination d'un
appareil de pouvoir sur un autre. C'est
aussi simple que ça. La CPI mais ma
thèse est sur donc part de la cour pé
internationale et et développe la nature
obsienne de la cour péale c'estàd juste
en fait un syndicat de de chefs d'état
qui qui cherchent à maintenir l'ordre
dans leur propre système. Je je la fait
courte mais mais j'écris 700 pages
dessus donc on pourrait je j'y renvoie
et et on le voit bien. Euh j'étais très
étonné, vous savez. Donc donc après le 7
octobre euh j'ai défendu donc pas mal de
je défends depuis en fait un certain
nombre de victimes. Euh j'ai fait
exfiltrer des des familles de Gazard et
ainsi de suite et et je pensais qu'on
était des centaines d'avocats de par le
monde à défendre des victimes de
palestinienne devant la CPI dans la
procédure en cours. J'ai découvert qu'on
était que 11.
c'est dire le manque de courage et de et
à l'acheter en fait à tous les niveaux
par rapport à à au déploiement de la
violence. En fait, les gens des gens ne
se sentent pas concernés en fait. Il y a
un vrai truc d'émotion, d'indignation,
on consomme du contenu gore, trash et
cetera. Mais quand il s'agit de mettre
en œuvre d'une façon pratique
quelconque, euh de prendre le temps de
faire un effort, de mettre son expertise
au service de personnes qui sont en
difficulté, là ça ça s'effrite à un
niveau un niveau sidérant. Une des
discussions, moi une des propositions
que j'avais fait à Ousman Sonko au
Sénégal, c'était qu'il me nomme
ambassadeur du Sénégal à l'ONU pour une
raison très simple. L'ONU est président,
pardon, le Sénégal est président à l'ONU
du comité pour les droits
inaliennénables des Palestiniens.
Donc c'est une fonction qui permet en
fait de
de mettre en visibilité et d'intervenir
diplomatiquement pour pour aider une
population sord. dont je rappelais la
sororité avec la cause sénégalaise avant
même que que l'offensive poste post
secte octobre. Après, j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de difficultés avec
l'importation systématique du conflit en
France de tous les côtés. C'est qu'il y
a on a ce côté euh en fait néoisadiste
dans laquelle on considère encore que
Jérusalem c'est chez nous quoi. Et que
on va en gros nous sommes chargés de
régler euh ce conflit à la place de ceux
qui sont sur le terrain ou de décider ce
qu'il faudrait ce qui serait juste ou
pas. C'est quelque chose que je trouve
très angoissant parce que de parts et
d'autres, ça crée des montées en tension
qui sont complètement exogènes au
facteurs
au au à la vie réelle des gens sur le
terrain et surtout de notre capacité à
affecter euh la situation là-bas. c'est
qu'on on a on on est d'autant plus dans
dans
l'inflammation discursive qu'on a aucune
capacité euh d'agir réellement sur j'ai
tenu une sorte de position qui consiste
OK, j'aide des gens factuellement,
j'essaie de dans la mesure du possible
dans un système auquel je crois pas euh
de les accompagner de là en faire une
rhtorique enfin voyez un instrument de
valorisation et ainsi de suite. C'est
quelque chose qui m'angoisse
profondément parce que je sais ce que
c'est là. Moi, j'ai vu des linchages au
Centrafrique euh de mes propres yeux
pendant des des moments de crise euh qui
étaient justement instrumentalisés par
BFM, compagnie rossière et cetera. Je
sais les conséquence. J'ai vu un
massacre à à Bazum euh c'était horrible
dans le nord du euh du Centrafrique.
Donc j'étais en décembre 2000 justement
juste avant de rencontrer quand quand
j'ai rencontré Juliane en janvier 2014.
Euh
cet homme que tout le monde décrivait
comme é gotique, obsédé par lui-même et
cetera euh me me demande pendant trois
qu4 d'heur me pose pendant tr qu4 des
questions sur Centrafrique qui aurait eu
cette curiosité parce que j'en revenais
que j'avais passé 3 semaines là-bas. Qui
aurait eu cette curiosité si ce n'est
quelqu'un qui justement est profondément
ancré dans le rapport à la curiosité, à
l'altérité et ainsi de suite ? Et bref,
là-bas, je bazou avec un convoi de l'ONU
parce que après des efforts immenses, il
y avait un père italien qui avait réussi
à à stabiliser la situation avec des
violences entre communautés religieuses
opposées sur une problématique assez
locale. Et la France qui venait
d'envoyer l'opération Sangaris, donc des
milliers de militaires sous prétexte
d'un résistinaire qui n'existait pas,
avait décidé de l'instrumentaliser et
donc ils avaient envoyé un général euh
français avec une dans en hélico, avec
un une équipe de BFM pour montrer leur
réussite à eux dans la pacification et
donc à quel point c'était justifié
d'aller donc évidemment qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Ça fait des mois vous êtes un un
curé. Ça fait des mois que vous faites
l'intermédiaire entre deux personnes qui
sont prêtes à enfin à se enfin deux
groupes deux communautés qui sont prêtes
à à s'autodétruire, à s'entredétruire et
vous leur promettez à chaque fois euh
qu'il faut qu'ils attendent euh
que des gens arrivent de Bangi, de la
capitale pour trancher les différents
points de conflit qui ont été
entre-temps recensés. Il a harmonisé
tout ça pour dire bah voilà en fait
qu'est-ce qui quels sont les désaccords
et difficultés qu'on connaît ? Si ça ça
don un énorme travail de médiation qui
lui avait mis des mois qui avait évité
des massacres. Que font les Français ?
Enfin en tout cas, ils envoient leur
hélico, ils font un sujet BFM de 20
minutes. Moi, j'arrive avec le convoi de
l'ONU qui était attendu pour résoudre
tout ça mais qui du coup est pris de
cours par et bah
le village est en feu, on n pas pu
rentrer. Pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils ont vu
euh les mecs débarquer mais surtout se
barrer tout de suite. Et ils ont ils
sont dit "Mais en fait, on s'est foutu
de notre gueule." C'est qu'on on
prétendait qu'on était en train de nous
aider mais en fait il nous il nous
lâche. Et donc comme dans des situations
de conflit la peur dans dans ces
situation là vous avez peur pour c'est
pas c'est pas une blague, c'est pas
genre ah je suis pas d'accord avec toi,
c'est je le tue pas d'abord, c'est lui
qui va me tuer. Et là ils attendent ils
retiennent ils retiennent retiennent la
violence préventive parce qu'on leur dit
qu'il y a une autorité hyper puissante
qui va arriver qui va protéger tout le
monde en gros qui va départager et il
les voit qu'il repartent littéralement
tris qu4 d'heur après être venu 50
morts.
Question internet. Quel regard
portez-vous sur la République
démocratique du Congo ? Pensez-vous
qu'il puisse y avoir un éveil
patriotique comme au Sénégal ?
Là, en fait, il y a il y a il y a a il y
a un président qui euh qui pour couvrir
les défaillances de l'État congolais et
ses insuffisances, sa corruption et et
aussi les difficultés structurelles qui
sont nées d'un découpage territorial qui
fait que bah entre Kinshasa et Litour et
le Nord Kivou, bah il y a quand même une
distance qui fait que c'est très
difficile de de tenir le territoire,
notamment quand vous faites face au
contraire à un état hyper restructuré
organisé comme le Rwanda avec l'appui de
l'Oganda. On trouvant une situation où
pour couvrir cette incapacité à résoudre
ce problème, on agite la rhtorique
génocidaire. Justement, on commence à
dire il y a un génocide en Itu et
compagnie à Anna et donc vous vous
réactivez un réflexe patriotique mais de
base étage qui est complètement
instrumental. Il y en a rien à faire
d'une moi j'ai passé un mois là-bas dans
le Massici et compagnie. Je peux vous
dire que enfin les politiciens de
Kinshasa n'ont strictement rien à faire
d'autre chose que les ressour le
contrôle sur les ressources qui sont
pillés par l'oranda. Ce qui peut pas
assez se passer pour les populations,
c'est vraiment pas leur difficulté quoi.
Ils ont des gouverneurs qui sont là qui
qui vivent un peu comme des potentats et
qui et en fait c'est des c'est des pur
rapports de prédation. Donc il faut se
méfier de l'instrumentalisation là
encore de ce genre de discours à des
fins de
en fait de d'ofusquation de de la propre
incapacité des des dirigeants
politiciens.
Question internet. Comment explique-t-il
qu'il ne soit ni au fond d'une prison ou
simplement disparu avec tous les réseaux
qu'il dénonce ? et je donc j'ai déjà été
euh on me fait peser la menace euh de
l'être à tout le monde. Vous pensez là
je comprends ce que vous m'avez dit sur
Media Part et compagnie mais vous vous
avez vu les conséquences que ça peut
avoir quand vous attaquez y compris à
des à des organes comme ceux-là. C'est
en fait c'est derrière c'est on essaie
de vous détruire par tous les moyens
imaginables. Moi encore une fois ce qui
m'a permis de tenir jusqu'ici plus ou
moins avec quand même enfin une violence
extraordinaire c'est tous les
instruments qu'on m'avait donné au
préalable. Je connais parfaitement
l'adversaire. Je sais comment il
fonctionne, je sais ce qu'il mobilise
comme arme, je sais quelles sont les
erreurs qu'il attend, qu'il essaie de
construire et ainsi de suite. Donc je
j'essaie et et maintenant par exemple,
donc je vous raconter Haïti et barbecue.
Barbecue c'est qui ? Et donc comme je
vous le disais, le principal chef de
gang haïtien qu'on accuse d' de de
dévorer ses adversaires, de les enfin
d'en faire des barbecu et de les manger.
Je suis assez confiant dans le fait que
c'est en effet un chef de gang avec tout
ce que ça entraîne,
mais que son explication sur ce point
est vraie. Euh c'est-à-dire que
lui lui m'explique, c'est assez
intéressant, il me dit "Mais moi
barbecue c'est un c'est un surnom qu'on
que j'ai depuis l'enfance parce que ma
mère faisait barbecue dans le quartier.
En fait, j'étais le fils de enfin de
l'endroit pour pour le quartier et
compagnie." Et c'est vrai qu'on a jamais
retrouvé une quelconque preuve d'un
quelconque acte de cannibalisme
rattachable à lui à un quelconque
moment. Par contre,
l'instrumentalisation
de la de la fantasmatique du
cannibalisme contre un corps noir qu'on
cherche à écraser, c'est quelque chose
qui existe depuis 5 siècles.
Vous voyez ? Donc à un moment donné, il
faut avoir systématiquement un réflexe
de prudence critique à l'égard de ce
genre de monstruisation de l'adversaire.
On essaie pour éliminer quelqu'un de lui
faire perdre sa qualité humaine en en
faisant un monstre horrible. Et une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai survécu
pendant toute cette période, c'est que
il y a les réseaux sociaux, il y a des
gens comme vous. C'est il y a des gens
qui permettent de voir
qui est vraiment l'autre. Vous voyez,
pas seulement des rapports, des articles
dégueulasses avec des photos qui sont
prises de façon tout d'un coup, il y a
la possibilité pour des gens de vous
voir et de vous entendre en contournant
les plus ou moins hein parce qu'il y a
de plus en plus de censur algorithmique,
tout ce qu'on voudra et cetera, mais
dans une certaine mesure d'entendre
l'autre et ça c'est un rempart immense
contre justement les tentatives de de
dévastation. Et pour Haïti, je vous
disais ça parce que
ça commence à créer une forme de
reconnaissance aussi ces luttes et de
protection sociale. C'est il y a des
gens qui nous aident de la même façon
qu'il y a des gens qui m'ont aidé au
Sénégal. Il y a des gens qui m'ont f Il
y a des je suis beaucoup plus protégé
par la société française que par ces
institutions et je de plus en plus je
suis protégé par la société française
contre les institutions. Et comme ces
institutions sont de plus en plus
instrumentalisées y compris
l'institution judiciaire, il y a un
réflexe
de plus en plus de prendre en charge la
protection de celui qui se voit ciblé
par elle. Et ça c'est très dangereux
parce que c'est la porte ouverte aux
instrumentalisations, manipulation,
au au aux populistes, à tous ceux qui
vont essayer en fait d'arracher enfin de
profiter pour se faire un chemin et et
instrumentaliser les les gens. Mais mais
je crois aussi à la capacité des gens à
élaborer un esprit critique et vous vous
faites tromper une fois, deux fois mais
à la troisième vous commencez à avoir
des réflexes qui vous permettent de
comprendre sur sur quoi vous êtes
confronté.
Question internet. Selon Branco, qui
avait qui avait intérêt à financer et
ordonner l'exécution sommaire du
président de Haïti, le commando armé
entre parenthèses.
Il y a c'est quoi l'effet structurel ?
Euh j'y suis allé pour essayer de
comprendre aussi ce qui s'était passé
autour de autour de cette question euh
avec quand même un commando avec des
gens qui avaient montré des insignes de
la DEA. Donc l'agence américaine
antidrogue pour s'ouvrir le chemin par
rapport aux gardes du corps qui
protégeaient le président et et le
massacrer à bout portant et exfiltrer un
certain nombre de documents qu'il avait.
Vous savez euh
moi je peux passer des mois ou des
années à travailler un sujet avant de
finir par me dire je suis en capacité de
vous dire ce qui s'est passé à Haïti.
J'ai pas j'ai pas eu le temps. J'ai pas
eu le temps notamment à cause de cette
tentative en fait d'instrumentalisation
qui a fait que j'ai compris que j'étais
sur le point de tomber dans un piège et
qu'il fallait et qu'il fallait partir
plus vite que ça. Donc là-dessus, il y a
eu des enquêtes assez intéressantes. Je
recommande
enquête de médiia part
euh non malheureusement non mais il y a
un prix pourzer qui a été qui qui a été
offert à quelqu'un à un groupe de
journalistes qui avait essayé de de
comprendre en fait les liens avec les
trafics de drogues en fait qui qui ont
lieu. Ce que je peux vous dire
structurellement sur Haïti, c'est que
depuis 1915 et la première invasion
états-unienne de cette région, c'est la
chasse gardée de de ce pouvoir et que
enfin de cet état et que l'imbrication
c'est pas la France quoi. La France,
elle joue un rôle, elle est dans le
corps groupe avec le Canada et les
États-Unis. Mais en réalité ceux qui ont
la main mise sur ce qui est en train de
se jouer, c'est les États-Unis
aujourd'hui.
Question internet. Quels outils de
sécurité informatique Ran Brancoo
utilise pour se protéger ? A-t-il des
conseils de base sur ce thème notamment
dans
donné par Assange et Wikiliak ?
Oui. Bah c'est ce qui m'a permis de
survivre. Enfin vous vous imaginez bien
c'est qu'on avait donc à la fois on
remercie Snowden et à la fois on lui
reproche parce qu'il nous a rendu
tellement paranoïque tous que il y a un
effet inhibant dans dans le passage à à
l'acte politique en fait quoi. C'estd
qu'on a
Pourquoi vous dites paranoïque ?
Pourquoi vous dites pas alerte ?
parce que il y a il y a une tendance euh
moi le grand défaut que j'ai par rapport
au geste Snowden, par rapport à ce
sange, c'est qu'il a rendu euh il a révé
les les instruments et pas le contenu
auquel pourtant il avait accès. Donc
c'est-à-dire qu'il nous a rendu aveugle
sur qui était effectivement ciblé. il a
il nous a révélé comment on pouvait
cibler les gens et en gros la toute
puuissance de la NSA et sa capacité en
gros à faire ce qu'elle voulait mais
sans nous montrer effectivement
si ça touche enfin évidemment en théorie
ça touche par exemple il a démontré
comme des pays entiers toutes les
communications étaient systématiquement
par exemple l'Afghanistan il prenait
tout mais il n'a pas montré comment
c'était analysé c'estàd qu'est-ce qu'ils
allaient chercher dedans qui il
ciblaient dans quel dans quelle ampleur
donc c'estàdire que donc théoriquement
il nous a laissé dans un dans un truc
trucci un peu paranoïque potentiellement
ou du mec qui veut brûler un pneu dans
la sous-préfecture de la Creuse jusqu'à
Julian Assange en passant par c'est la
la capacité à savoir si effectivement
ils ont les capacités d'analyse qui vont
permettre d'anticiper ou de vous cramer
avant avant de mener un geste qui serait
légitime. C'est devenu très difficile.
Donc en il y a il y a quand même une
ambivalence du geste que j'imagine euh
construite pour se protéger.
Il a il a cette illusion extraordinaire
qui consiste à avoir un pardon. Enfin,
c'est c'est un c'est un anglicisme,
c'estàdire une une une grâce
présidentielle. Et il a pas compris que
enfin jamais de la vie il pourra
remettre et donc nourrissant
artificiellement cet espoir, il s'est
dit qu'il fallait pas qu'il mette à nu
complètement. C'est qu' il ne devait
qu'exposer la partie technique mais pour
moi c'est ça ça retient rien à son
héroïsme et enfin et au service qui est
rendu mais ça ça crée en fait un un
système qui est qui est difficile. Et
donc dans la guillotine si
si je vous dis William Binet et Stellar
Wind ça vous parle ?
Bah oui Stellarwind bien sûr B ça fait
partie des dispositifs d'espionnage
qu'il a qu'il a révélé. Oui, mais on les
connaît par cœur. On a tout on a tout
regardé, dépioté pour et comme on était
ciblé en partie par eux, mais j'ai pu la
guillotine ou euh la guillotine. Donc il
y a toute une dernière partie qui
s'appelle la surveillance, le dernier
chapitre et où je donne à la fois
Vous pouvez nous en lire une page ?
Yes, faut que je retrouve. C'est
l'avant-dernière, il y a la méthode
d'abord, pardon.
Voilà. Surveillance.
Bon, le début c'est définition la
surveillance engendre la solitude. On la
confond souvent avec la répression là où
elle n'en est que l'antichambre et la
condition. Paranoïante, la surveillance
l'est parce qu'elle est l'étape
préalable à la violence mais qu'elle
demeure parfaitement intangible,
impalpable et indéterminable en théorie.
Donc ensuite, je décris euh donc
j'essaie d'abord une définition euh
théorique et pratique, ensuite les
déductions dont on doit faire don qu'on
doit tirer. Et enfin je donne des
conseils
euh sur deux pages. Euh
deux conseils,
bah le premier enjeu est de sécuriser
ces données, de les extraire de l' en
prise desgâs femmes, donc Google,
Facebook, Amazon, Microsoft et cetera.
Toute interaction passant par un réseau
social contemporain est non seulement
surveillé en direct mais enregistré
immobilisable des années plus tard. Les
appels téléphoniques, les SMS, les
conversations simples sur Telegram,
Messenger, Snapchat, Instagram, mais
aussi les courriels ne sont pas chiffrés
par nature et sont lisible en clair par
n'importe quelle structure de pouvoir
doté de capacité d'interception
minimale. Et ensuite, je détaille
comment contourner ces difficultés. Vous
savez combien de de d'agents la CIA a
une en en couverture totale,
c'est-à-dire infiltré en de façon
intégrale dans un appareil ennemi.
Dans un appareil ennemi ou mondialement
? mondialement, mais enfin de sur une
cible. Non, non, non. Des des euh des
agents sous couverture intégrale,
c'est-à-dire c'est-à-dire qu'ils vivent
voilà les gendes complète, c'est ils
vivent euh comme s'ils étaient euh ce
qui ce qu' ce qu' ne sont pas une idée
et d'où est-ce que vous tenez cette
information
? Bah euh elle est complètement sourcée.
Je vais pas vous donner la source mais
je peux vous assurer que c'est
vérifiable. Il y en a moins de 400.
Combien ?
Moins de 400
en France. Non, dans le monde.
Dans le monde.
Dans le monde. Donc c'est là, c'est ce
que je décris par rapport au au système
enfin à l'effet paranoïsant. Il y a un
côté des capacités technologiques
immenses mais derrière un étau qui est
un la capacité à former des analyses de
haut niveau, la capacité à traiter
l'information et la capacité à
l'exploiter et enfin à éventuellement à
déstabiliser. Donc évidemment, on est
face à des appareils de pouvoir massif
mais attention à ne pas les surestimer.
D'ailleurs, les gilets jaunes ont pris
de cours nos très brillants esprits de
la DGSI. euh
euh sans sans grande difficulté.
J'aime pas la
Ça c'est ça c'est très intéressant ça.
Je vais je vais quand même la poser euh
pour voir votre réaction. N'avez-vous
pas peur avec vos nombreux présupposés,
entre parenthèses, lutte de pouvoir,
manipulation des élite, fermez la
parenthèse,
d'expliquer les faits avec votre vérité
et non de rechercher la vérité des
faits. Par ailleurs, je salue votre
combat car même si vous n'avez sans
doute pas raison dans 100 % des cas, au
moins vous suscitez la réflexion.
Merci à lui ou à elle. à lui
si je fais cet effort systématiquement
d'essayer de m'approcher du réel, c'est
pour éviter toute présomption.
Si j'essaie si je vais sur des terrains
au plus près des corps, des enjeux de
pouvoir et compagnie, c'est pour essayer
d'éviter de tomber justement dans dans
le réflexe qu'il décrit. Je vais vous
donner un exemple par rapport à DGSI. À
18 ans, je suis tombé amoureux d'une
femme qui était qui était à moitié russe
et qui était à science po comme moi et
qui était passionné par la géopolitique
compagnie était a été super favorable à
Poutine à l'époque et moi c'était
l'inverse. Moi j'étais en mode la guerre
en Chichini non massif il sair souvent
hein. Ouais.
Non mais donc ouais voilà, elle venait
d'un milieu bourgeois du 16e
arrondissement et et debouiller et
compagnie avait été scolarisé à à Ganson
et
et moi je venais d'une toute autre rive
parce que quelque chose qu'on qu'on ne
sait pas souvent c'est que les
bourgeoisies y compris à Paris sont très
multiples et très contradictoires. C'est
pas un ensemble homogène, il y a pas une
classe dominante. C'est c'est des codes
culturels symboliques, compagnie très
très différents avec des priorités.
Et donc cette femme qui était religieuse
par ailleurs vraiment tout l'inverse du
républicain lacar que j'étais à l'époque
de gauche naana euh
vous êtes
je pense que je suis quand même plus
malin que que ce que j'étais à l'époque.
Enfin genre plus complexe quoi. C'est
plus plus ouvert sur le monde que moins
certain. Et donc je me retrouvais, on se
retrouve avec cette et elle fréquentait
du coup les églises orthodoxes
euh avec sa mère et ainsi de suite. Et
euh et un jour, elle me dit "Écoute,
j'ai un truc hyper bizarre, il faut que
je t'en parle et cetera." Et comme on
était très proche et enfin en gros ma
famille l'avait accueilli pour des
raisons X Y, elle était cétait elle elle
me raconte qu'elle y a un certain Loï
qui l'a qui l'a abordé qui lui a
expliqué que euh il avait accès à à
toutes ses communications. Il lui avait
parlé de mail qu'on s'est échangé
compagnie et qui lui avait proposé
demandé de travailler avec lui. Et en
fait, elle avait elle avait 19 ans, je
veux dire. Enfin, ces gens-là enfin
vivent vraiment dans un rapport à
l'autre qui en fait est inexistant quoi.
C'estàd qu' ils ont leurs intérêts,
leurs objectifs, ils en ont rien à faire
de conséquences que ça peut avoir pour
un pour un gamin ou une gamine sur
Et donc il demande à cette fille d'aller
infiltrer à cette femme que que j'aimais
enfin pardon j'ai j'ai 10 filles les
événements organisés par l'ambassade de
Russie en France et compagnie et lui
promettent en échange une forme de
protection. Elle elle hésite, elle est
elle est traumatisée, elle veut pas
vivre dans ce monde-là. Enfin, on n'est
pas nécessairement fait pour être un
James de catégorie et je sais pas quoi
dit. Sauf qu' lui disent que voilà, si
elle veut rentrer au quadoris plus tard
et cetera, elle ferait elle aurait
intérêt à à rentrer dans dans dans cette
disposition là. Elle part en 3e année à
Moscou au M Guimo, donc qui est la
grande école d'oration internationale
de Russie.
Donc là, il y a le Gru qui lui propose
exactement le même deal.
Non, pas pas justement. Enfin, il y a il
y a un truc où euh je pense que
l'ambassade, elle essayait de enfin
était intéressée par son profil de
Russie en France, mais pas de ce que je
sais et je je suis assez confiant sur le
fait que c'est pas arrivé. Euh il la il
il la tamponne pas. il attend pas une
page parce que je pense qu'ils ils
essaient ils étaient plutôt sur une des
opérations d'influence à
voilà à à moyen et long terme en fait
quoi. Voyez, c'est plutôt essayer de
former des relais euh et euh et en fait
euh donc elle elle fait un stage à
l'ambassade au service santé et
compagnie et elle finit par euh par
rentrer en France par passer le le quai
où la DGSI va l'appuyer
effectivement pour qu'elle puisse
rentrer. elle va avoir
sa naturalisation et elle va être
envoyée à l'ambassade de France à Moscou
peu avant la guerre et aujourd'hui est
sous-directrice Russie et donc elle se
retrouve on se retrouve au moment de la
guerre en février
et là vous venez de balancer son nom là
bah c'est son parcours est est public he
enfin c'est une fonctionnaire pas le
fait qu'elle soit fait tamponner à 19
ans par DGSI
bah ouais mais enfin c'est c'est elle
travaille pour l'état français enfin
donc je veux dire qu'elle fait d'une
façon d'une autre aujourd'hui elle sert
si elle travaillait pour la Russie oui
là là sert français en Russie là
non non justement il est plus non quand
même enfin il faut pas il faut pas il
faut pas arriver mais ce qui m'intéresse
dans cette histoire
c'est que en au moment de la du
déclenchement de de l'offensive russe en
Ukraine vous vous souvenez des des
pitoyables aller retour d'Emmanuel
Macron pour essayer de convaincre
Poutine que c'était une mauvaise idée
que les chars étaient rentrés de Kiev ?
On se souvient plutôt de tous ces
analystes qui ont rien vu venir.
Mais c'est pas qu'ils ont rien vu moi je
vous parle de quelqu'un qui était
porte-parole euh de l'ambassade de
France en Russie et vous savez mais non
essayer de protéger l'identité des gens.
Vous savez ce qu'elle fait ? Elle elle
elle m'écrit pas savoir.
Mais non mais c'est magnifique. Elle
m'écrit pour me pour me demander de
mettre en place une pétition avec des
artistes contre la guerre en me disant
que en gros que on va l'éviter, qu'il
faut faire tout le possible et qu'il
faut pas qu'on s'inquiète à Paris qu'il
gère. Mais
vous vous rendez compte dans quel dans
quel espace mental ces gens vivent ? Ils
essayent de faire des choses.
Il y a des chars à la porte de Kiev
et la chancellerie
en plus dans le délire c'estàd pris dans
l'ego une sorte de délire égotique de
penser qu' ils tiennent le destin du
monde c'est qu'en fait ils sont capables
de avec une pétition d'artistes.
C'est niveau des gens qui nous dirigent
aujourd'hui. C'est niveau des gens qui
nous dirigent aujourd'hui. Et je tiens à
prévenir et c'est pour ça que j'en
parle. Je tiens à prévenir les Français
des personnes qui aujourd'hui prennent
des décisions qui demain pourront
t'amener à une guerre conventionnel ou
nucléaire. Je veux dire, c'est ces
gens-là qui aujourd'hui alimentent et
n'importe qui qui a vu le documentaire
sur la sur l'action diplomatique de
Macron par rapport à guerre en Russie
là où il fait fuiter une conversation
entre lui et
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
ça, c'est le niveau
des diplomates qui l'accompagnent du
conseiller diplomatique de l'Élysée ces
gens-là. pouz pas vous faire votre
opinion. C'était sur un tout petit
document peut-être qu'il travaille
énormément derrière.
Je conseille à tout le monde de regarder
le niveau d'intelligence tactique et
stratégique de ces gens-là tel qu'il est
montré mais même la tenue. Ces gens-là
n'ont plus aucun rapport un au réel et
de à l'exigence. Donc vous avez à
travers cette histoire de choses. D'un
côté euh le côté vraiment sans sans
complexe
des services de renseignement, la façon
dont ils vont aller chercher des proies
là où ils peuvent sans aucune
il y a pas pire il y a pas pire comme
monde que celui du renseignement. Il y a
eu tout un effort à travers la le bureau
des légendes et compagnie d'essayer de
romantiser le travail de ces êtres.
C'est un travail par essence misérable
et sale et je tiens à prévenir les
français.
La définition c'est un métier de
moi je dis rien de roi fait par des
Non c'est pas du tout un métier de ro
c'est un métier de roi fait par des gu
mais non mais non pas du tout pas du
tout il faut pas mépriser les personnes
qui le font qui justement sont pris par
l'illusion d'eux et compagnie nana ces
gens-là ont par nature. J'ai jamais été
Ça a détruit ma vie d'être confronté à
ces appareils de pouvoir. Ça détruit des
vies en c'est leur fonction. Ouais, mais
ça peut en sauver aussi
par le par le par
par le renseignement
le renseignement économique.
Ouais,
ça peut faire gagner des points
au détriment d'un autre
par par le mensonge, par l'infiltration,
par l'entrave. C'est ça. Et quand ces
structures se superposent et se protéger
contre des attentats terroristes et
s'interpose s'interpose à des à au choix
démocratiques, ce qui est
malheureusement
ça peut éviter que certaines ingérences.
Ah oui, très efficacement. Ouais. Vous
savez combien d'agents de la DGS sont
chargés de de faire le contre-espionnage
par rapport à la CIA, à la station de la
CIA qui est boulevard Osman ? Aucun
idée.
Et les de 200 agents il y en a quatre.
Ouais, mais c'est peut-être quatre super
bons.
Ouais. Ouais. 4 contre 200. Ouais.
Moi moi le nombre d'histoires
d'interférence, d'ingérence, de
destruction de vie de la mienne mais
aussi de c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a mis en
c'est là en en en dans un rapport de
rupture radicale.
C'est quand j'ai vu les tentatives
d'emprise, il y en a il y a deux
niveaux. Il y a l'oligarchique
suprapolitique et il y a
l'infrapolitique. C'est les services en
gros de renseignement. Je ne pardonnerai
jamais ce qu'ils m'ont fait et je prie
pour eux. Je prie pour eux que je n'ai
jamais accès aux archives qu'ils ont
produit sur moi depuis 2015
et que je mette la main sur ceux qui ont
produit ces archives.
Question internet. Pour Branco,
l'invasion du Capitol entre parenthèses
par les supporteurs de Trump n'était
donc pas une violence. Point
d'interrogation.
Bah pardon hein, enfin
une violence, l'invasion du capital par
rapport à à la violence quotidienne qui
habite les États-Unis. Il y a ça a quand
même tiré dans le Capitol.
Arrêtez-vous vraiment c'est du
spectacle. Enfin franchement vous
rigolez a quelqu'un qui est mort.
Il y a combien de morts par an à cause
de la crise des opioïdes aux États-Unis
?
On veut parler de violence qui qui il y
a combien de milliards qui ont été faits
par par les industries pharmaceutiques
et les familles qui les détiennent sur
la mise en dépendance volontaire de
millions de citoyens américains dans une
crise sanitaire fabriquée par eux. Vous
voulez parler de violence et ces gens
vous imaginez la violence non seulement
de voir la vie de vos proches aimé
détruite par ces systèmes de prédation
économique et par l'instrumentalisation
volontaire euh
Trump avait perdu l'élection
mais vous vous rendez compte on a le
spectacle
est-ce que vous voyez le le
donc on on a le spectacle et on a la
structure voyez on a des millions de
vies affectées et on a une scène de
théâtre qu'est-ce qu'on préfère
commenter l'écummenter barnier commenter
ou comment s'intéresser à au fait que la
famille qui était propriétaire de et
fabricante de ces opioïdes n'a jamais
été poursuivi, bénéficier encore de
milliards de rentes provenant de la
destruction de ces millions de
personnes. Qu'est-ce qui nous intéresse
plus ? On n pas sur CNN là.
Question internet,
question sincère. Bonsoir monsieur
Branco, pour qui tu roules ?
pour mon pays parce que c'est mon pays
qui me protège.
Enfin, c'est mon ambition, ça pas
aujourd'hui, mais je veux dire, je sais
que si un jour je serai sauvé, ce sera
parce que mon pays changera et abattra
un certain nombre de structures de
pouvoir contre lequel je suis opposé. Et
si je le fais, c'est évidemment il y a
pas de Robin Débot absolu, c'est pour
qu'il me sauve aussi. c'est vous voyez
enfin il y a il y a ce mais par contre
là il y a quelque chose de très
important chez moi, c'est justement au
fondement de tout ça, il y a le lien
pas euh pas l'ambition pas et j'essaie
et par ailleurs, j'espère ne rouler
inconsciemment pour personne, c'est de
pas être un instrument euh de et
j'essaie de limiter au maximum tout ce
qui euh
Alors, un commentaire qui est une
information entre guillemets, personne
ne s'est fait piquer au en festival
fermer les guillemets pour reprendre vos
déclarations.
Dois-je l'emmener en stage dans mon
service hospitalier pour interrogation ?
Je sais pas. Moi, je conseille plutôt de
lire les rapports euh que je décris sur
justement euh 5 ans après euh euh
les preuves qui ont qui ont été obtenues
sur euh sur cette sur cette question et
les recherches universitaires sur
l'exacte identité entre cette panique
morale et celle de du siècle dernier.
Il y a énormément de questions. On va en
prendre une dernière, on va aller tout
au fond. Je suis désolé pour toutes les
questions qu'on vient de
Bon, on peut en prendre quelques-unes he
enfin faut pas c'est on va pas me revoir
tout de suite he donc profitons-en. Moi
non mais vraiment enfin je puis si on se
voit tous les 5 ans
non on se revoit malgré deux trois
choses qui m'ont chauffé les oreilles
mais on se revoit parce que Ran Branco
n'est pas une balance
devant les flics. Ron Branco n'est pas
une balance et je le répète
donc c'est quelqu'un qui Ouais mais ça
ça pour le coup c'est important ne pas
trahir c'est fondamental
question internet un avis sur la
situation en Argentine
que peut-il nous dire sur l'arrestation
de Paul Watson
donc
MF Watson on peut
ça sera pas intéressant j'aurais des
choses à vous dire mais
Que pense R Branco de la couverture des
médias en France et occidentaux sur ce
qui se passe actuellement à Gaza en
Israël 6 Jordanie et au Liban ? Comment
les médias africains couvrent ce sujet ?
Point interrogation.
Les médias africains n'ont pas les
moyens de couvrir directement la
question.
Euh et euh quant au à l'indessence de la
couverture médiatique française en
particulier, je pense qu'elle est elle
est très bénéfique pour tous parce
qu'elle elle nous permet de nous nous
détacher définitivement de toute
illusion quand à quand tu as leur
capacité à
à être autre chose que des relais de
pouvoir à varier. Vraiment, je pense que
c'est c'est ça a été un j'espère pour
beaucoup une prise de conscience
importante. Question euh personnelle
d'un
d'un de nos followers.
Bonjour, je travaille au Yémen et en
Afrique pour des sociétés travaillantes
pour les Nations- Unies. J'ai eu affaire
et été témoin de plusieurs cas de
corruption au sein de plusieurs de leurs
organismes. Est-ce possible de porter
plainte et de les poursuivre en justice
si oui auprès de quel cours et dans quel
pays ? Point interrogation. Quelle est
la juridiction point interrogation ?
A-t-il des cabinets d'avocats
spécialisés dans le domaine et comment
appelle-t-on cette spécialité juridique
pour interrogation ? Merci. C'est ça
dépend beaucoup des de des statuts des
personnes concernant parce qu'il y a des
accords d'immunité par rapport à au aux
ag à la plupart des agences de l'ONU
ainsi de suite. Moi, j'avais dénoncé en
mais moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il
réfléchisse au-delà de du phénomène de
corruption
phénoménologiquement, c'est-à-dire de
l'acte réel de corruption sur ce que ça
implique. Je vous donne dis ça parce
qu'en 2018 j'ai été recruté par enfin
par la cour spéciale qui venait d'être
créé au Centrafrique et qui était
financé par l'ONU pour enquêter sur les
violences qui étaient commises sur place
et on était payé 400 dollars la journée
en sachant que le revenu moyen était
inférieur à 2 dollars.
Donc en fait, il y a il y a un problème
structurel au-delà la corruption, c'est
presque un épiphénomène en comparaison à
l'indessence
de ces systèmes. Et et d'ailleurs, j'ai
pas tenu une semaine parce que c'était
insupportable et par ailleurs, j'ai
découvert très rapidement qu'on avait
pour fonction de de couvrir les crimes
qui avaient été notamment commis par les
casques bleus qui là aussi sont attirés.
principe, c'est une source de revenu
très important pour un certain nombre de
pays du sud, les l'émission des casques
bleus et euh et en fait et et bref et
souvent ça mène à des c'est là il y a un
truc incroyable. Vous avez pas vu en
Haïti là ce qu'ils ont inventé. Une
mission de Kenya a été envoyée à Haïti
pour stabiliser la situation. Je
rappelle qu'au Kenya, on parle anglais
hein, on parle pas français, on parle
pas créole. Euh ils ont envoyé des
kignans, je sais pas parce qu'ils sont
noirs peut-être euh en en Haïti dans
l'espoir que ils vont régler le problème
à leur même et ça c'est une émission qui
est fondamentale de celle que vous avez
faite que c'est la précédente
force multilatérale qui avait été
envoyée à Haïti qui a provoqué une des
pires épidémies de choléra de l'histoire
et ça notre émission. Elle est elle est
fondamentale parce qu'en fait euh vous
la regardez, vous dites c'est énorme,
c'est vrai, c'est pas vrai et cetera.
vous allez lire tous les rapports et
cetera et c'est euh et en fait c'est un
c'est c'est une émission qui est je
pense c'est c'est peut-être l'une de
l'émission la plus importantes que vous
ayez jamais fait parce que
non c'est non il y a la
si si je pense parce que il y a il y a
un effet de
euh en fait de
dissémination d'une information auquelle
à laquelle personne euh ne se serait
intéressé en lisant des rapports et
compag on serait dit ou une choléra pays
pauvre enfin 40000 morts bon voyez et là
en fait il y a il y a quelqu'un qui vous
amène
un professeur médecine,
voilà et qui en fait qui vous fait
rentrer dans l'engrenage, dans la façon
dont ça s'est fait
c'est c'est extraordinaire parce que
tout un coup on découvre et on se dit
"Mais comment vous voulez que les
Haïtiens et un quelconque désir de se
retrouver à nouveau dans une situation
similaire après ce qu'ils ont vécu quoi
à forceuri avec des cignons. Enfin, je
pense qu'ils préfèrent se massacrer
entre eux que enfin se faire massacrer
par des par des chefs de gang que de
Question internet. Bonsoir. Le symbole
de la guillotine est plus noté à la
terreur ou à la révolution.
Entre parenthèses. Après ça, le chaos
pour la classe moyenne. Fermez la
parenthèse.
C'est la la guillotine, c'est quand même
un symbole très ambivalent parce que
vous savez quand même que le premier qui
s'est fait exécuter avec la guillotine,
c'était un voleur de mouchoir.
C'est ça pas été utilisé pour pour
mettre au pas des classes dirigeantes
corrompues immédiatement. Et en fait et
très rapidement et c'est pour ça que ça
que la peine de mort a fini par être
appolie en France. Euh parce que très
rapidement c'est devenu un instrument de
maintien de l'ordre qu'on utilisait pour
contre contre les monstres euh que
génère toute société mais à aucun moment
pour faire peur aux classes bourgeoises.
Ça a pas été inventé pour éviter euh que
les gens euh
ça a été inventé pour que ça passe d'un
coup.
Ouais. Vous savez que le docteur qui
guillotin qui l' inventé qui n'est pas
qui en fait l'avait présenté à
l'assemblée enfin de l'Assemblée à
l'époque et tout le monde tout le monde
avait ri de lui et il s'était fait
sortir et c'est seulement je pense 2 ans
plus tard qu' un moment on s dit ah en
fait tiens ça serait peut-être utile
parce que sinon c'était à la hache des
fois il se loupaiit
ouais non mais enfin la la guillotine
loupait aussi à force de mais mais
c'était surtout pas très pas agréable
comme et fonctionnel comme dispositif
quoi. Donc à partir de là euh j'étais
distrait pardon par un bruit. Du coup
j'ai pu j'ai perdu le film. Mais
mais l'histoire de la guillotine est
assez intéressante et assez ambivalente.
C'est qu'il faut pas en faire un c'est
un objet symbolique. Euh il faut pas en
faire évidemment l'alpha et l'oméga d'un
des instruments de lutte. Mais c'est
aussi une façon en fait c'est aussi il y
a il y a quand même une petite inside
joke pour mes amis pour le coup pas de
gauche mais
gauchiste donc plus à gauche que que la
gauche qui ont été importants pour les g
jaun enfin ce qui était magnifique g
jaune c'est que ça allait des
anarchistes royalistes. Il y avait un
truc bon il y a eu quelques frictions
mais enfin il y avait une sorte de
résurgence d'un d'une idée qui
transcendait des clivages qui qui avait
semblé jusqu'à complètement
inconciliable. Moi, j'étais très fier de
défendre Damien Tarel, celui qui a
souffleté Emmanuel Macron
euh et qui est en fait un un royaliste
purju jus et je partage rien des idées
qu'il le défend, mais justement c'est
des jonctions qui ont été permises par
ce mouvement. Euh pourquoi je disais ça
? Parce que ils ont il y a un an, il y a
un un livre que j'ai acheté avec une
certaine appétence qui est paru qui
s'appelle How tolow Up Pipeline.
Comment faire sauter un péter un
pipeline
qui n'a pas été lu par
canalisation ? Non
non. Non, un gazoduc enfin oui ou
unoduc. Donc ça avait pas été lu par par
la CAN et de les services ukrainien
parce que contrairement à ce que son
titre
indique, c'est pas du tout un guide
pratique de sabotage ou de c'est une
sorte de recension un peu un peu chip de
toutes les luttes écologistes qui ont eu
lieu à droite à gauche. Et en fait c'est
un très bel objet à mettre dans les
salons des classes moyennes citadines
qui se veulent de gauche un peu
transgressives et qui peuvent le poser
là et dire oh qu'est-ce que je suis
transgressif. Et moins tout cet ouvrage
est aussi construit contre cette
hypocrisie du rapport à la révolution.
Ça c'est assez fondamental. C'est cette
idée que on narrête pas de dire faut
faire la révolution, c'est pas possible
et cetera, mais qui est vraiment prêt à
se confronter aux conséquences réelles
d'une révolution qui est qui est
vraiment prêt à s'organiser
politiquement parce que ça prend des
années de mettre en œuvre une
révolution. Ça prend des années de
cibler les endroits, de se préparer à
prendre les endroits qui éventuellement
permettront une une révolution
politique. Ça prend des années de
réfléchir à quel monde alternatif. Et
moi ça m'a pris toutes ces années pour
arriver justement à cette conclusion, à
cet ouvrage, à donner des instruments
qui pourront servir. Quoi qu'il
m'arrive, ça aussi c'est quand même
fondamental parce que je sais qu'à
n'importe quel moment, soit par un
compromat, soit par une opération de
déglingue physique, soit par quoi que ce
soit, je peux disparaître. Donc pourquoi
tous ces livres aussi ? C'est une façon
que ça soit là. Ça ça ça peut pas être
tué ça ça restera quoi qu'il arrive. Et
donc c'est une façon aussi de mettre
tous mes mes amis pseudor
révolutionnaires face à face à leur
inconséquence leur dire est-ce que vous
êtes vraiment prêts à assumer les
conséquences d'un tel geste ? et ils
sont lourds. C'est pas drôle la
révolution, c'est pas drôle le
politique. Est-ce que c'est pas la même
chose d'aller dans le Cantal construire
une ferme parce que c'est pas bien le
monde moderne et compagnie en lâchant
tout le monde en reste campagne ou
d'aller faire la bringue dans une manif
de temps en temps dans un état
démocratique. On est à peu près sûr
qu'on s'en tirera dans un état en tout
cas qui respecte un minimum ces règles
là. C'est pas même chose de se dire "OK
là on rentre dans le dur. Là, on dur
parce qu'il y a vraiment des gens à
sauver, pas que pour moi, parce qu'il y
a vraiment des enjeux et j'en suis pr je
suis prêt à en payer le prix. Et là, ils
ont les instruments pour le faire. Ils
pourront pas prétendre qu'il qu'il ne
savent pas ce qu'il faudrait faire.
Est-ce que vous avez un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec notre
communauté et avec nous ?
Alors, je peux poser une question sur
Palvelof en attendant pour vous laisser
le temps de réfléchir ?
Ouais, ouais. Ouais. Euh,
j'étais effrayé hein parce que
ça ça me permet, vous allez me dire "Je
suis monomaniaque", mais ça va permettre
de finir là-dessus. Enfin, parce que
c'était rigolo, c'est plutôt de lors de
l'anecdotique. Mais je pense que j'étais
le premier à alerter sur le fait que
Macron lui avait donné la nationalité
française et a posé la question
publiquement. Le tweet est retraçable
d'ailleurs pourquoi Emmanuel Macron a
naturalisé cet homme de la même façon
pour servic en en courtcircutant toutes
les procédures habituelles. Pourquoi il
a fait la même chose avec le fondateur
de Snapchat ? Qu'est-ce qui dat
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Voilà. Non mais
OK, question rhtorique mais non parce
que la question c'est quel est le deal ?
Ça on le sait pas. Quel est le niveau
d'accès, sur quel contenu, quoi et
cetera. N Macron utilise Telegram depuis
la mi-2010 pour toutes ces
communications en non chiffré. tous les
groupes de discussion euh de ces
conseillers par exemple sur mon affaire,
ça a été révélé par un livre qui
s'appelle Ministère d'injustice publ
chez Grasset par des journalistes qui
qui ont dit que la concier justice de
l'Élysée était informée de toutes les
étapes de mon affaire en un monde des
décisions prises par les magistrats et
comment elle l'était par des boucles
télégramé avec 5 à 10 conseillers qui
faisaient remonter euh et qui après
redescendait des instructions au
procureur et ainsi de suite qui était
sur Telegram. Or, les groupes sur
Telegram sont non chiffrés, c'est-à-dire
que ils sont en clair pour ceux qui sont
sur télé, enfin ceux qui détiennent des
serveurs Telégram Telegram qui ont
infiltré d'une façon ou une autre. Donc,
il y a de quoi faire sauter 100 fois ce
régime
sur les serveurs Telegram. Donc, la
première question, c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'il lui offre la nationalité ?
Je je sors le truc un an après le monde
fait un article sur le sujet,
il se fait arrêter
et là je ressors la question de dire
qu'est-ce et là il y a il y a mon cher
ami Edou qui fait un tweet en disant wou
le monde pose pose une super question
super importante. Pourquoi je sais pas
quoi ? Et là je pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que et là je dis et ooui c'est pas le
monde qui pose la question c'est moi qui
la pose depuis 3 ans. Premier point
c'est moi qui ai fait un tweet un
million de vues qui enfin c'est moi qui
vient de la mettre et le monde si le
truc. Et deuxième question pourquoi tu
dis que c'est pas moi ? Parce que le
même mec qui t'a aidé à fonder ton
canard est le propriétaire du monde. Et
ce mec c'est Xavier Niel et qui appelle
Durof
en garde à vue
Xavier Niel.
Qui Dur du RO appelle en garde à vue ?
Qui vous avez le droit de prévenir une
personne quand vous êtes passé en garde
à vue. Qui prévient ? pas sa meuf enfin
pas Xavierel. Pourquoi ? Pour faire le
pont immédiatement avec Emmanuel Macron.
Quand j'ai vu ça
et donc
je pas spéculer plus en un mont, j'ai
été approché par des intermédiaires pour
le défendre. Euh notamment euh il a une
fondation en fait qu'il a créé qui qui
fait de la cryptomonnaie euh qui est en
fait la principale source de revenu de
télégram aujourd'hui. Euh
j'ai refusé à donc il voulait en fait
une sorte de défense officielle avec bah
tous les mecs enfin don un avocat qui
qui a mis son examen pour faux et usage
de faux qui qui est justement un proche
de de la macronie de de ces personnes-là
et il voulait je pense des proxis qui
soient pas directement lié à lui enfin
voyez enfin sortes de et et moi j'ai dit
il y a une chose je justement et ça
c'est la clé depuis toujours justement
je ne roule pour personne sans le dire
explicitement et sans que ce soit su
publiquement je ne je ne prendrai jamais
la parole en public pour défendre une
cause ou une personne sans qu'on sache
si j'ai un lien d'intérêt avec celle-ci,
même indirect. Ça c'est ma règle. Donc
ce si vous voulez que je défende,
je peux vous dire que je pense que Durit
plus de ce monde si si s'il m'avait
désigné et parce que Macron sait très
bien ce qui serait passé derrière.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
J'en aurais euh
peut-être en
peut-être pour prendre le rebour du de
la folie de cette époque. Euh d'abord un
livre de de Dostoyevski euh Crimé et
châtiment pour une raison très simple.
Aujourd'hui, comme les bouquins de
Pushkin et compagnie et là encore le
monde de la même façon qui s'était
quasiment félicité de mon arrestation a
fait un article audatif à l'égard des
Ukrainiens qui faisaient ça. Euh
l'Ukraine c'est quand même une culture
russe he enfin pour ceux qui savent pas
c'est c'est d'ailleurs c'est un des
foyers de la naissance de la culture
russe quoi. C'est voir le foyer en
fait qu'ils sont ukrainiens quoi.
On peut en discuter ce qu'on veut mais
bon TKOF il est russe enfin enfin il il
est il est né en Ukraine. Enfin, je veux
dire, on peut c'est c'est je pas je veux
pas je veux pas ni artificiellement
l'éventuelle naissance existence d'une
identité ukrainienne à part entière.
C'est pas c'est pas mon propos. Mais
voilà. Et bien, ils ont décidé, il y a
un mouvement massif de euh destruction
de tous les auteurs russes dans les
bibliothèques ukrainiennes.
Donc Dostoyevski, Pushkin et compagnie,
tout ça, c'est devenu en fait, ils sont
soit rangés dans les réserves, soit
jetés et compagnie. Et donc vous avez un
article du monde qui décrit ça dans des
termes positifs
et et moi je pense on est dans on est
rentré dans une enfin enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est dire encore une fois on en
revient à ça le niveau des gens qui
aujourd'hui font l'opinion publique nous
dirigent et la catastrophe à laquelle
ils peuvent nous mener donc crimer
châtiment Dostevski parce que c'est une
des plus belles œuvres de de l'histoire
de la de l'humanité les les misérables
de Victor Hugo parce que ça vous donne
une charpente littéraire politique
intellectuelle et que c'est pas du tout
un livre chiant. En fait, c'est le genre
de livre qu'on qui sont au programme à
l'école et donc on se dit qu'ils sont
pas faits pour nous. Enfin que et en
fait c'est des livres merveilleux à
découvrir par soi-même et à se les
approprier. Et j'essaie de pas me
répéter par rapport au conseil que je
vous avais donné que vous m'aviez
demandé la la fois précédente s'il y a 5
ans. Mais je sais que je vous ai parlé
des enfant de Valzer, donc j'ai essayé
d'en trouver un autre. Laissez-moi un
instant parce que c'est c'est
fondamental et euh et euh
l'avantage de Seview, c'est qu'on peut
prendre son temps parce que c'est la
communauté qui nous finance. On n pas de
pub, on n pas de pub sur YouTube et et
continuez de nous financer sur Tipi. On
a besoin de vous et grâce à vous, on est
indépendant, on on est fort et et on
continuera d'être fort grâce à vous.
Euh
non mais il y en a
voyage au bout de la nuit de Céline
parce que c'est le plus grand livre de
littérature du 20e siècle de très loin.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable que vous laisserez sur
internet.
L'inverse de ce que vous a dit l'autre
là la semaine dernière, croyez et aimez.
Croyez, aimez et et trompez-vous. Viv
quoi ? Arrêtez de arrêter cette guerre
civile, l'attente qui a les mêmes gamins
là, les Normiens qui étaient là, c'était
il y a 2 ans, il ne me parlait d'amour
que sous le prisme mitou violence
sexuelle à 20 ans. C'est que tout était
telle telle telle personne était
violente, telle personne était dénoncée,
telle personne était en garde à vue à 20
ans. C'est une catastrophe. Vous rendez
pas compte à quel point la crainte qui
est en train de s'imisser dans tous les
rapports humains et la violence que
c'est en train de générer et à quel
point la folie qui consiste à penser que
l'appareil judiciaire qui est la pire
des choses que l'humanité construit pu
céder mais il faut il faut les protéger
ces personnes-là mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec le mouvement de dévastation
sociétale qu'on est en train de générer.
C'est pas c'est pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va qu'on va réussir à protéger.
Moi, j'ai accompagné des victimes dans
des procédures pénales. Vous imaginez
pas à quel point c'est dévastateur.
C'est horrible la justice. La justice,
c'est des surveillances, c'est des
gardes, c'est de la violence partout. Et
la violence ne purge jamais la violence.
Moi, j'admire euh
la Suède,
non, pourquoi j'étais avocat de de de
Pavlenski et compagnie ? Parce que en
fait la la vraie nature de leur geste,
ça consisté à se venger d'un outrage et
à couper les couilles de celui qui avait
pardonnez-moi, j'étais vulgaire, qui qui
avait commis cet ouvrage cet outrage.
C'est dire il a essayé de détruire ou il
a détruit quelqu'un, il va voir, vous
voyez, c'est il y a a il y a pas il y a
pas il y a pas de victimisation, il y a
pas de il y a il y a aussi une forme de
violence, hein,
c'est une rétribution et c'est comme ça
aussi qu'on se répare. en en en en bien
sûr ça été c'est mais là on pourrait
revenir sur cette affaire parce que
on viendra plus tard sur cette affaire.
Ouais, parce que c'est en fait c'est
c'est c'est à la fois extraordinairement
violent et vous avez parfaitement
raison, extraordinairement violent et
d'une violence qui est qui est triste et
et en même temps, il y a 1000 raisons
pour lesquelles je pourrais vous
expliquer pourquoi quelque part il y a
quelque chose qui s'est joué autour de
de cette affaire qui qui va bien au-delà
de cette pseudo violence dont on parle.
Mais mais laissons ça de côté, c'est un
moment en fait, c'est d'érisation
fascinante d'ailleurs dans l'espace
public français par rapport à la
sexualité turgisscente d'un homme tout
d'un coup comment c'est devenu un objet
de fixation libidineuse assez étrange,
assez assez dégoûtante. Mais
vous avez fini votre conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Oui mais du coup on l' on l' dit là on
est parti sur un truc était un autre
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Ouais. Non, mais soyez enfin vraiment ce
qui est critique c'est ouvrez-vous au
monde et ayez conscience
du on est on est à la veille vraiment,
je l'ai dit en passant mais en fait
c'est ça l'élément fondamental. On est
dans un monde sans pitié où il y a un
risque fondamental
que l'on devienne
les esclaves de ceux que l'on a
exploité.
Et il faut qu'on fasse très attention
d'une part à ne plus abuser de notre
pouvoir et d'autre part à nous protéger
parce que ça sera pas drôle si demain un
régime chinois agressif offensif décide
de prendre assise et de se venger des
humiliations qu'il a subi notamment au
19e siècle et et et tout au long du du
20e siècle. Il faut faire très attention
d'une part à ce qu'on a généré, mais
d'autre part à ne pas avoir de fausse
naïveté et à rentrer dans une
disposition où on se sacrifierait. Euh
euh ce qui se passe en Russie, moi une
inquiétude dont personne ne parle. On on
considère que la Russie c'est quoi qu'il
arrive l'Europe, c'est le méchant de
l'Europe. OK. Mais quoi qu'il arrive, ça
restera l'Europe. Euh, vous pensez que
les Chinois
qui ont quand même une frontière qui est
pas petite avec la l'amour
et je peux vous dire que c'est pas les
mêmes systèmes de pensée, c'est pas les
mêmes systèmes philosophiques, c'est pas
les mêmes systèmes politiques et que
l'enracinement de la Russie dans une
culture européenne est non seulement
fondamental,
c'est ce que disait Macron d'ailleurs.
Et un des enjeux Ouais. un moi moi comme
je vous le disais enfin j'ai j'ai j'ai
permis à à à mon amoureuse de de
basculer d'un d'un poutinisme un peu
aveugle à à servir la DGSI et la Paris
France et donc enfin je suis pas
soupçonnable de quoi que ce soit mais
c'est quoi notre alternative aujourd'hui
à Poutine parce que à force de donner
des coups
c'est l'Afrique
et d'essayer de déstabiliser un un
régime qui a commis 1000 horreur qui est
abusif de 1000 façon dont on comprend
mal la jeunèse c'est-à-dire la décennie
de pillage ahurissant qui a subi la
population russe. Pourquoi est-ce que
vous pensez qu'ils ont fini par se
conformer à un régime autoritaire comme
le régime russe ? Vous vous rendez
compte de la violence invisible qu'ils
ont subi dans les années 90 et le le
système de prédation que nous avons mis
en œuvre là-bas contre si on comprend
pas ça, si on comprend pas la façon dont
on a détruit toute la partie
structurante qu'avait généré l'Union
soviétique avec tous ces excès mais sur
le rapport à l'éducation
à 1000 à 1000 domaines qui avaient fait
de la Russie quand même une puissance
mondiale et comment d'un coup on a
décidé de tout vider et de tout
s'approprier en se disant c'est une
terulous un peu comme avec l'Afrique au
19e siècle on arrive on br tout dans
bar, on comprend pas la surréaction
autoritaire et l'absence.
On comprend surtout pas la classe
générationnelle qui est au pouvoir
maintenant qui a vécu ça. Les gamins de
10 15 ans qui voyaient le l'effondrement
du bloc soviétique et
moi j'étais très très naïf par rapport à
ça. Moi, j'ai eu une phase où j'étais
comment il s'appelait l'oligarque là qui
qui a passé 7 ans en prison dans un dans
un
beaucoup. Non, mais le celui qui habite
aujourd'hui en Suisse qui a une
fondation là qui était euh qui qui était
lié à Gasprom, comment il s'appelle le
principal euh, on l'a oublié tellement
euh mais bon, qui est devenu aujourd'hui
un héros euh des droits humains qui
était juste un mec en fait qui euh qui a
qui s'était approprié la moitié des
ressources en gaz naturel du pays et qui
en avait joui pendant 10 ans et qui à un
moment donné, bah il s'est fait
retrouver et on en avait fait un héros
des droits humains.
on ait pas conscience de ce que ça
impliquait en terme de prédation pour
des millions de personnes qui vivaient à
ce moment-là dans une misère noire sans
aucune capacité à se saisir de de leur
propre destin. Et donc
Michel Kodourkowski,
voilà, Kodorkowski, voilà, qui aujourd'
une fondation humain et cetera. Et moi
moi je peux vous dire que j'étais j'ai
même conseillé une copine qui qui a
l'ONU d'aller travailler dans sa
fondation à l'époque parce qu'elle était
Canada russe en disant bah voilà mais
on était au conseil pour les jeunes
générations
mais c'est la capacité à à s'identifier
à des à des faux héros. C'est très
dangereux. Enfin, voyez, cette
fabrication de de faux idoles qui vont
en fait dévier complètement, ils vont
vous faire oublier le destin massif et
euh euh enfin les les implications
massives que leurs actes ont pu avoir
sur sur beaucoup. Donc ça fait partie
des euh
Ouais. Enfin, j'en ai plein de enfin par
ailleurs se battent comme des chiens
pour pour la paix pour construire une
partie de la paix à un moment où on est
à ça on est à ça d'une catastrophe avec
des des gens cyniques à des milliers de
kilomètres de nous aux États-Unis et
compagnie on rien à faire voir se
satisfaire quelque part qu'on soit
emporté dans une spirale
spirale dévastatrice. Ça veut pas dire
être naïf, ça veut pas dire tolérer quoi
que ce soit mais c'est du calme du
calme.
Ran Branco, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]